CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE. SO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
WILL CONVENE IN 60S.
YES, IT'S. SPARSE. I KNOW.
EVERY TIME I ALWAYS. WHERE. WHEN
I PICK MY HARVARD ONLINE
CLASSES. WHY DON'T YOU TURN YOUR
MIC ON, SENATOR, THIS IS
IMPORTANT. SO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE EDUCATION WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING, EVERYBODY.
THERE ARE 21 BILLS ON TODAY'S
COMMITTEE AGENDA, HOWEVER, ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT, AB 2254 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR, EIGHT
BILLS ARE ON CONSENT. LET ME
LIST THEM. THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 2500. ITEM
NUMBER THREE, AB 2931. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB 2080. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB 2096. ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
20 2317. ITEM NUMBER 11 AB 2350.
ITEM NUMBER 17 AB 2821. ITEM
NUMBER 20 AB 3067, TODAY'S
HEARING WITNESSES WILL BE ASKED
TO LIMIT THE TESTIMONY TO TWO
MINUTES. TWO MINUTES APIECE. TO
ENSURE THE COMMITTEE IS ABLE TO
COMPLETE TODAY'S AGENDA IN A
TIMELY FASHION, SEEING NO
QUORUM, WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE WITH THE FIRST
WITH WITH THE FIRST BILL, BUT
BEFORE I DO THAT, LET ME SALUTE
THE SHADOW CHAIR. SENATOR
WEALTH, THIS IS ACTUALLY SENATOR
WILKES LAST REGULAR HEARING OF
THIS COMMITTEE. I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT SNUCK UP ON YOU, BUT WE OWE
YOU A WE. IT MAKES US SAD TO ME.
WE OWE YOU A GREAT DEBT. YOU'VE
BEEN A WONDERFUL MEMBER FOR
LONGER THAN I'VE BEEN A MEMBER.
SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO SAY A FEW
WORDS, I DON'T. YOU DO NOT. HE
WILL SAVE THOSE WORDS FOR
EXTEMPORANEOUS SPEECH DURING
EVERY SINGLE BILL AS WE HAVE
COME TO KNOW IT. SO NOTHING TO
ADD AT LEAST. OKAY, APPRECIATE
IT. BUT ACTUALLY I DO A ROUND OF
APPLAUSE FOR THIS FINE SENATOR
RIGHT HERE. YEAH YOU KNOW HOW
SHY I AM, CHAIR. YEAH, I
UNDERSTAND HE'S A MAN OF FEW
WORDS, SO FIRST, IN ORDER, WE
HAVE AB 1142 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FUNG. WELCOME, YOU MAY BEGIN
WHEN READY. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE 142 WILL EXTEND THE
SUNSET DATE FOR THE CIVIC CENTER
ACT AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES FROM
JANUARY 1ST, 2025 TO JANUARY
1ST, 2030. THE CIVIC CENTER ACT
WAS ENACTED IN 2014 TO ENSURE
THAT STRUCTURES AND FACILITIES
BUILT WITH PUBLIC FUNDS ARE
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC FOR
USES BEYOND SCHOOLING. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZED TO OFFER THE USE OF
FACILITIES AND GROUNDS TO A
VARIETY OF ORGANIZATIONS USING A
FAIR MARKET, FAIR RENTAL VALUE
METHODOLOGY. HOWEVER, THE
AUTHORIZATION IS SET TO EXPIRE
ON JANUARY 1ST, 2025. ASSEMBLY
BILL 1142 EXTENDS THE SUNSET
DATE BY FIVE YEARS. THIS WILL
ENSURE THAT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND CLUBS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
ACTIVITIES FOR ATHLETICS, FOR
YOUTH, FOR CHARITABLE PURPOSES,
OR THE CIVIC WELL-BEING OF OUR
COMMUNITY CAN CONTINUE TO USE
THE COLLEGE FACILITIES AND
GROUNDS AND MINIMAL TO NO COST
UNTIL JANUARY 1ST OF 2030. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE IS LINDA VASQUEZ,
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
STATE AND FEDERAL RELATIONS AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. MISS
VASQUEZ, WELCOME. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
NEWMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB 1142. LOCAL GOVERNING
BOARDS ARE AUTHORIZED TO ALLOW
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS, CLUBS
AND OTHER ASSOCIATIONS TO USE
THEIR FACILITIES AT NO COST. IN
2014, THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCOTT
WILK Ã CHAMPIONED AB 1906, THE
CIVIC CENTER ACT, TO ENABLE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO CHARGE A
FEE TO COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
TO USE THEIR CAMPUS FACILITIES.
AB 1906 PROHIBITS THOSE FEES
FROM EXCEEDING THE DIRECT COST
OF USE OR THE FAIR RENTAL VALUE
FOR THE FACILITIES. THIS IS A
GOOD THING COLLEGES HAVE
WELCOMED THE FLEXIBILITY WHICH
HAS MADE IT POSSIBLE TO OPEN
THEIR DOORS TO COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS, WHILE ALSO
ALLOWING THEM TO COVER THE COST
OF MAINTENANCE, REPAIRS AND
JANITORIAL STAFF TIME. OUR BOARD
OF GOVERNORS ADOPTED REGULATIONS
THAT SPECIFY PROPORTIONAL COSTS
THAT A DISTRICT CAN INCLUDE IN
THEIR FEES. THE CIVIC CENTER ACT
HELPED MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
USE THEIR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITIES WITHOUT FACING DEEP
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES, ESPECIALLY
UNDER RESOURCED ORGANIZATIONS,
BUT WITHOUT THE EXTENSION OF THE
CIVIC CENTER ACT, THAT
FLEXIBILITY GOES AWAY. COLLEGES
WILL NO LONGER BE ABLE TO CHARGE
A MAINTENANCE FEE FOR USE OF
FACILITIES, WHICH MEANS THAT
THEY WILL HAVE TO ABSORB STAFF
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS.
ADDITIONALLY, OUR BOARD WILL
LIKELY NEED TO REVISE ITS
REGULATIONS AND GUIDANCE ON
ALLOWABLE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
LOANING THOSE FACILITIES, AS
SHARED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG.
THIS BILL REQUESTS APPROVAL FROM
THE LEGISLATURE TO EXTEND
CURRENT IMPLEMENTATION OF LAW BY
EXTENDING IT FOR ANOTHER FIVE
YEARS. IF YOU'RE ASKING WHY FIVE
YEARS, IT'S FAIRLY COMMON FOR
THERE TO BE A SUNSET ON PUT A
SUNSET DATE ON LEGISLATION IN
FACT, SEVERAL OF OUR PROGRAMS
EXPIRE EVERY FIVE YEARS, AND
WHEN IT IS TIME TO RENEW THEM,
WE RESPECTFULLY COME TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO REQUEST AN
EXTENSION. AND SO TODAY, WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG REQUEST AN EXTENSION FOR
THIS EFFORT. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB 1142. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. IF ANYONE IS IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS CONTROVERSIAL
MEASURE, SEEING NONE, LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. I'D BE
SURPRISED IF THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR
HAS SOMETHING TO SAY HERE. I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE VERY SHY.
WELL, I APPRECIATE THE SHOUT
OUT, BUT THE FULL TITLE OF THE
LEGISLATION IS SCOTT WILK CIVIC
CENTER ACT. YES, THE SCOTT WILK.
SO THERE YOU GO. ANYWAY, YEAH,
WE DID THIS BECAUSE OF ALL THE
CONTROVERSY BEFORE, AND IT WAS
UNFAIR TO PUT ON THE TAXPAYERS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COSTS FOR
ORGANIZATIONS THAT USE IT. SO I
IT'S MY PROBABLY MY STELLAR
PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN MY 12
YEARS HERE THAT ALSO IS NOT
TRUE. AND NOBODY LAUGHED.
EVERYBODY TOOK THAT TOTALLY AT
FACE VALUE. THAT'D BE LIKE THE
FIRST TIME EVER. BUT ANYWAY. SO
YEAH, THANK YOU FOR DOING THIS
AND KEEPING MY LEGACY ALIVE. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT.
APPRECIATE YOU. ALL RIGHT.
HOPEFULLY YOU'RE HERE LONG
ENOUGH. YOU CAN REAUTHORIZE IN
FIVE YEARS, ONE DAY AT A TIME.
RIGHT? AND THERE YOU GO. AND
ERASE THE SPECTER OF AND HAPPY
TO, MAKE THE MOTION WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM. AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE WHEN WE HAVE
A QUORUM, IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SO, IN THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM, WE WILL
TAKE THAT UP. AND WE DO HAVE
ONE. THANK YOU, MISS VASQUEZ.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG,
WELCOME TO MY VICE CHAIR,
SENATOR JOE BORG. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN, WELCOME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME, MR.
CHAIR. AS ALWAYS, A PRIVILEGE
AND A PLEASURE TO BE. IT IS OUR
PRIVILEGE. AND ALSO, I WANT TO
THANK SENATOR WILK FOR ALL THAT
YOU'VE DONE THROUGHOUT THE
YEARS. YOU ARE THE WALKING
BUDDHA OF ALL THINGS GOOD. WHEN
I LOOK IN THE MIRROR, I ASK
MYSELF, WHAT WOULD SCOTT WILK
DO? AND THEN I ACT ACCORDINGLY.
DON'T WE ALL? I ASK MYSELF, WHAT
WOULD VANESSA WILK DO? EVEN
BETTER. SO AGAIN, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB 3167. UNDER CURRENT
LAW, MANY NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES
FALL IN THE SAME REGULATORY
CATEGORY AS VOCATIONAL SCHOOLS.
THIS IMPORTANT LAW, ESTABLISHED
TO PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
PREDATORY INSTITUTIONS, NOW HAS
AN OUTSIZE EFFECT ON
INSTITUTIONS THAT MERGE WITH
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS SUCH AS
NORTHEASTERN UNIVERSITY AND
MILLS COLLEGE. WHILE THIS
IMPORTANT LAW PROTECTS AGAINST
FRAUD THAT COULD LEAD TO LOSS OF
STUDENTS TUITION AND FEES, IT NO
LONGER SERVES STUDENTS ATTENDING
CERTAIN HIGHLY QUALIFIED
INSTITUTIONS THAT REMAIN
COMMITTED TO EDUCATING
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. AS MORE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES MERGE,
HIGHLY QUALIFIED NONPROFIT
INSTITUTIONS WITH APPROVAL TO
OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
BE REQUIRED TO SUBJECT STUDENTS
TO A BURDENSOME REGULATIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS BASED ON BUREAU
RULES THAT WERE ESTABLISHED FOR
MORE RISKY INSTITUTIONS.
CURRENTLY, STUDENTS ATTENDING
NONPROFIT UNIVERSITIES REGULATED
BY THE PRIVATE POST-SECONDARY
BUREAU MUST DECLARE A COURSE OF
STUDY BEFORE BEGINNING COURSES.
STUDENTS MUST ALSO PAY A FEE,
KNOWN AS THE STUDENT TUITION
RECOVERY FUND. STUDENTS
ATTENDING PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES
ARE EXEMPT FROM BUREAU
REGULATION AND ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO DECLARE A MAJOR OR PAY WHAT
WE CALL THE STRF. AB 3167 OFFERS
HIGHLY QUALIFIED INSTITUTIONS AN
ALTERNATIVE APPROVAL PATHWAY
WHILE MAINTAINING BUREAU
OVERSIGHT AND SAFEGUARD FOR
STUDENTS. THIS BILL ENSURES
IMPORTANT SAFEGUARDS ARE IN
PLACE. TO BE CONSIDERED HIGHLY
QUALIFIED, AN INSTITUTION MUST
BE NONPROFIT, NOT HAVE OPERATED
FOR PROFIT IN THE LAST 20 YEARS,
AWARDED AT LEAST 500 DEGREES PER
YEAR, BE ACCREDITED FOR AT LEAST
TEN YEARS, AND THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS MUST NOT HAVE EQUITY
INTERESTS IN THE ACCREDITING
AGENCIES HERE TO TESTIFY. WE
HAVE RENAMED JEALOUS LOVER OF
NORTHEASTERN UNIVERSITY. ALEX
GRAVES OF IQ. WE ALSO HAVE MIKE
FERRARI OF NORTHEASTERN
UNIVERSITY FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
CHAIR NEWMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS RENE LEVER.
I AM VICE PRESIDENT FOR CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATION AND STRATEGIC
INITIATIVES AT NORTHEASTERN
UNIVERSITY, OAKLAND. PRIOR TO
JOINING NORTHEASTERN FOR 31
YEARS, I SERVED IN A VARIETY OF
LEADERSHIP ROLES AT MILLS
COLLEGE, AN HISTORIC PRIVATE
LIBERAL ARTS COLLEGE AND LEADERS
ON ISSUES OF EQUITY, SOCIAL
JUSTICE, AND WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP.
FOUNDED IN 1898, NORTHEASTERN
UNIVERSITY IS A COMPREHENSIVE,
NONPROFIT GLOBAL RESEARCH
UNIVERSITY AND THE RECOGNIZED
LEADER IN EXPERIENTIAL LEARNING.
IN JULY OF 2022, MILLS COLLEGE
MERGED WITH NORTHEASTERN,
JOINING NORTHEASTERN'S NETWORK
OF 13 CAMPUSES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES, CANADA, AND THE UNITED
KINGDOM, INCLUDING A CAMPUS
OFFERING GRADUATE PROGRAMS IN
SAN JOSE, WHICH OPENED IN 2015.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, HIGH QUALITY
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS THAT
MAINTAIN A PHYSICAL PRESENCE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WHICH ARE
HEADQUARTERED OUTSIDE THE STATE,
SUCH AS NORTHEASTERN, FALL INTO
THE SAME REGULATORY CATEGORY AS
PRIVATE FOR PROFIT INSTITUTIONS
AND VOCATIONAL SCHOOLS OFFERING
SHORT TERM TRAINING PROGRAMS.
THE INTENT OF AB 3167 IS SIMPLE
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
OVERSIGHT FROM THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
FOR HIGH QUALITY NONPROFITS LIKE
NORTHEASTERN, BUT ONLY WHEN
THOSE INSTITUTIONS MEET RIGOROUS
QUALITY STANDARDS, PROTECT
STUDENTS AND MAINTAIN CONSUMER
SAFEGUARDS. IMPORTANTLY, THE
BILL WOULD ELIMINATE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER CURRENT LAW
THAT IMPEDE STUDENT ACADEMIC
PROGRESS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. FOR EXAMPLE, AT
COMPREHENSIVE NONPROFIT RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES, ACADEMIC
EXPLORATION AND DISCOVERY ARE
THE HALLMARK OF AN UNDERGRADUATE
EDUCATION, PARTICULARLY DURING
THE FIRST YEAR. THE BILL WOULD
CORRECT THE PRACTICE OF
REQUIRING STUDENTS AT SUCH
INSTITUTIONS TO ENROLL IN A
DEGREE PROGRAM BEFORE THEY HAVE
DECIDED ON A MAJOR AND CAREER
PATHWAY. ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL
WOULD EASE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDENS AND REDUCE DELAYS FOR
NEW PROGRAM APPROVAL SO THAT
HIGHLY QUALIFIED NONPROFITS CAN
RESPOND QUICKLY TO MARKET
DEMANDS AND MEET THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS FOR SKILLED
TALENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE, AND THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR. GRAVES.
GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
APOLOGIES FOR COMING RUNNING IN.
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF GETTING
TO BE IN TWO PLACES AT ONCE.
THIS MORNING. ALEX GRAVES HERE
ON BEHALF OF AQ AND OUR 89
MEMBER INSTITUTIONS, ALL OF
WHICH ARE PRIVATE, NONPROFIT,
ACCREDITED COLLEGES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE OUR
MEMBERS ARE EXEMPT FROM BPP, WE
DO APPRECIATE AND VALUE THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THEY PLAY IN
PROVIDING STRONG CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND SAFEGUARDS FOR
STUDENTS HERE IN THE STATE. WITH
THE CHANGING HIGHER EDUCATION
LANDSCAPE, WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
MAKES SOME MODEST BUT IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO ADDRESS SOME UNIQUE
ISSUES THAT NORTHEASTERN HAS
HIGHLIGHTED, AND WE BELIEVE THAT
EVEN WITH THIS, THIS LEGISLATION
THAT'S PUT FORWARD, THERE ARE
STILL, AGAIN, THOSE STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
STUDENTS IN PLACE THROUGH THE
BUREAU'S ROLE. SO WITH THAT, I
WOULD JUST SAY THANK YOU AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM? SO
COME FORWARD SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WELCOME
GOOD MORNING. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, BARRETT SCHNEIDER ON
BEHALF OF THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
RAISED SOME ISSUES WITH THE BILL
IN BNP EARLIER IN THE WEEK. MY
COLLEAGUE DAVID NEVIN. WE'VE
COMMUNICATED WITH STAFF. YOU
HAVE OUR LETTER, WE'VE TALKED TO
THE AUTHOR. I HAVE A COMMITMENT
TO WORK ON THAT OVER THE SUMMER.
SO JUST WANTED TO WE'RE KIND OF
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. WE'RE GOING TO WORK ON
IT OVER THE SUMMER. AND THANKS
FOR YOUR WILLING TO WILLINGNESS
TO DO THAT. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, ANY
TWEENERS SEEING? NONE. THANK
YOU, MR. SCHNEIDER, BACK TO THE
DAIS. QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. OKAY. YOU'RE GOOD.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE A QUORUM, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
OUR WITNESSES AND ALSO OUR
OPPOSITION. WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY ON ALLEVIATING SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE. AND
I BELIEVE THAT WE CAN COME TO A
CONSENSUS BEFORE SUMMER RECESS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WELL,
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE BEFORE
DURING, THANK YOU. I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT IT. WE'LL TAKE A MOTION
WHEN WE DO HAVE A THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES. THANK YOU, MR.
GRAVES. WELL DONE. YOU CAN RUN
FROM HERE, NEXT UP, I SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. WELCOME.
YOU ARE PRESENTING AB 2711. YOU
ARE WELCOME TO PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
SENATORS, I WANT TO THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD START OFF BY
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
WHICH ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WHO
SEEK OUT HELP FOR THEIR
SUBSTANCE USE ARE NOT PUNISHED.
AB 2711 BRINGS UP BRINGS US A
STEP CLOSER TO SUPPORTING OUR
YOUTH, WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING
WITH SUBSTANCE USE. IT AIMS TO
BE PROACTIVE RATHER THAN
REACTIVE WHEN ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES. IT MAKES THE CRUCIAL
MOVE OF ENSURING STUDENTS ARE
OFFERED SUPPORTIVE SERVICES,
PROVIDING A MUCH NEEDED LIFELINE
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE STRUGGLING.
THE NUMBERS SHOW THAT THE STATUS
QUO OF RESORTING STRAIGHT TO
SUSPENSION IS NEGATIVELY
AFFECTING OUR YOUTH, ESPECIALLY
BOYS, SOCIOECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND YOUTH
OF COLOR. IN ORDER TO BETTER
PROTECT OUR YOUTH, WE MUST LOOK
TO AT ADDRESSING THE HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS IN THESE
SITUATIONS TO REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF FUTURE SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND ADDICTION. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IS LUCIEN
MORDECAI AND WITH THE SACRAMENTO
YOUTH ACTION BOARD AND DANNY,
THERE ARE C¯ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK,
WELCOME TO THE WITNESSES. YOU
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES. PLEASE,
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
DANNY COLE, PUBLIC POLICY
COORDINATOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH EMPOWERMENT NETWORK, ALSO
KNOWN AS KHN. AND WE ARE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF AB 2711. KHN IS
A TRANSITIONAL AGED, YOUTH LED
OR TÊ LED ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO EMPOWERING YOUTH AGES 15 TO
26 ACROSS THE STATE TO INFLUENCE
AND CREATE MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH POLICY THAT
DIRECTLY AFFECTS THEM. WE HAVE A
PROGRAM CALLED THE I AM
COLLABORATIVE THAT EMPOWERS
LGBTQIA+ AND BIPOC TÊ TO
ADVOCATE FOR SUBSTANCE USE
PREVENTION THROUGH SOCIAL CHANGE
CAMPAIGNS AND ADVOCACY THROUGH
ART IN SACRAMENTO AND LOS
ANGELES. WE HAVE TALKED DIRECTLY
WITH YOUTH WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE
OF SUBSTANCE USE CHALLENGES IN
ALL CORNERS OF OUR STATE ABOUT
HOW WE CAN BETTER SUPPORT THEM,
AND THE CONSENSUS IS CLEAR OUR
YOUTH WANT HELP AND SUPPORT.
THEY WANT TO BE ABLE TO CONFIDE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY OR SCHOOL AND
RECEIVE SUPPORT AND SERVICES,
BUT FEAR PUNISHMENT FOR
DISCLOSING THEIR SUBSTANCE USE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, YOUTH ARE
SUBJECTED TO DISCRETIONARY
DISCIPLINARY POLICIES IN SCHOOLS
THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
YOUTH OF COLOR. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION REPORTED
THAT 83% OF DRUG RELATED
SUSPENSIONS ARE OF
SOCIOECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS, AND 83% OF THOSE
SUSPENDED ARE YOUTH OF COLOR.
THESE PUNITIVE POLICIES DO NOT
PROVIDE A SAFE AND SUPPORTIVE
ENVIRONMENT FOR YOUTH TO STEP
FORWARD AND ASK FOR HELP. IN
FACT, THEY DO THE OPPOSITE. THEY
CLOAK US IN FEAR AND PUSH YOUTH
AWAY, FURTHER STIGMATIZING THE
ISSUE AND MAKING MATTERS MUCH,
MUCH WORSE. THE CURRENT USE OF
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS TO
ADDRESS SUBSTANCE USE HAS
LIFELONG IMPLICATIONS.
SUSPENDING OUR YOUTH ISOLATES
THEM FROM FURTHER SCHOOL, FROM
SCHOOL RESOURCES, INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME AND THEIR SUPPORT SYSTEM.
THIS OFTEN LEADS TO CONTINUED
SUBSTANCE USE AND CAN RESULT IN
JUSTICE SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT WELL
INTO THEIR ADULT LIVES,
PERPETUATING THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE. AB 2711
EMPOWERS OUR YOUTH TO BE ABLE TO
ASK FOR HELP WITHOUT THOSE
REPERCUSSIONS, ENSURING OUR
SCHOOLS CAN CONNECT OUR YOUTH
WITH THE SUPPORT AND SERVICES
THEY ARE ASKING FOR. WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ON AB 2711,
WHICH WILL SUPPORT YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA STRUGGLING WITH
SUBSTANCE USE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS,
GOOD MORNING, MY NAME IS LUCIAN
MORDECAI, AND I'M PART OF THE
SACRAMENTO YOUTH ACTION BOARD.
I'M A QUEER YOUNG PERSON IN
RECOVERY, AT THE AGE OF 14, I
SOUGHT REFUGE IN SUBSTANCES
DURING AN ERA OF PROFOUND
PERSONAL STRUGGLE. HIGH SCHOOL.
REFLECTING ON THE PAST DECADE, I
RECOGNIZE A PATTERN THAT I SEE
TOO OFTEN A FAILED SYSTEM.
SADLY, THE INTERVENTIONS TO
ADDRESS MY ACTIONS WERE
INTIMIDATING, DEVOID OF
NURTURING SUPPORT, AND FURTHERED
MY RELIANCE ON SUBSTANCES. THE
CONSEQUENCES I FACE CAUSED
SHAME, GUILT, AND ISOLATION. THE
SYSTEM'S FAILURE TO RECOGNIZE
THE TRUE ISSUE, THAT OF ITS OWN
FLOOD RESPONSE TO THE PLIGHT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE ME, WAS
GLARINGLY APPARENT. ITS
UNDENIABLE REALITY THAT YOUTH
WHO ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR,
LGBTQIA, UNHOUSED OR WITHIN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM BEAR THE BRUNT OF
PUNITIVE MEASURES RELATED TO
SUBSTANCE USE. THESE
INTERSECTIONALITIES AMPLIFY
THEIR SUFFERING, YET THIS
CRITICAL LENS IS FREQUENTLY
IGNORED OR SILENCED WHEN IN
DISCUSSION. NAVIGATING THROUGH
MULTIPLE LAYERS OF SYSTEMATIC
OPPRESSION, THEY FACE THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE, AS WELL AS
DISPROPORTIONATELY SEVERE
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS. OUR
ADVOCACY MUST BE INFUSED WITH
EMPATHY AND COMMITMENT TO
EQUITY, ENSURING THAT OUR YOUTH
ARE MET WHERE THEY ARE AT WITH
CARE, RATHER THAN CONDEMNATION.
TOGETHER, WE CAN DISMANTLE THE
BARRIER TO HEALING ONLY BY TRULY
LISTENING TO THE YOUTH THAT ARE
OUR FUTURES. TOO MANY OF MY
FRIENDS, PEERS AND LOVED ONES
HAVE BEEN LOST TO A SYSTEM THAT
MASQUERADED PUNITIVE MEASURES AS
SUPPORT, LEAVING BEHIND SO MANY
DREAMS THAT SHOULD HAVE
FLOURISHED INTO BEAUTIFUL
FUTURES. I REFUSE TO STAND BY
AND WATCH AS MORE YOUTH ARE
PUSHED INTO JAILS, INSTITUTIONS
OR DEATH BECAUSE OF A FLAWED
SYSTEM. SUBSTANCE USE IS A
REALITY THAT CANNOT BE IGNORED,
A PERSISTENT CHALLENGE THAT
DEMANDS OUR ATTENTION AND
COMPASSION. IT ISN'T SOMETHING
THAT WILL DISAPPEAR AND OUR
YOUTH WILL CONTINUE TO FACE IT.
THEY NEED OUR UNWAVERING SUPPORT
AND OUR WILLINGNESS TO TRULY
LISTEN AND UNDERSTAND THE DEPTH
OF HOW THEY FEEL THROUGH BEALL
2711 I BELIEVE WE MAY START TO
PROVIDE THE KIND OF SUPPORT THAT
EMPOWERS OUR YOUTH TO THRIVE
INTO THE FUTURES THEY SO
RIGHTFULLY DESERVE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD WITH YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION, YOUR POSITION.
GOOD MORNING, KELLY BROOKS, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, CLIFTON WILSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
SUPPORT, THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
RACHEL BHAGWAT, WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ON ARCHIMEDES, ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS PAMELA
GIBBS, REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, AND WE SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
LIZZIE KUTSUNA HERE. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. ADRIAN
SHILTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. PROUD CO-SPONSOR.
THANK YOU, NORA LYNN. WITH
CHILDREN NOW PROUD CO-SPONSOR.
THANK YOU CHEN. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, ELLA
CONNELLY ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO
AND OAKLAND UNIFIED IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, PAIGE
CLARK WITH THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR YOUTH LAW IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. JANINE COHEN, PARENT
TO HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND PART
OF, BERKELEY FAMILIES FOR
COLLECTIVE LIBERATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, CANDICE
YOUNGBLOOD. I'M IN SUPPORT. I'M
A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER. THANK
YOU. CHARISSE TAYLOR, BERKELEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT PUBLIC
EDUCATION TEACHER IN SUPPORT.
I'M SORRY I COULDN'T HEAR YOU.
CHARISSE TAYLOR, BERKELEY
UNIFIED SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANN WOLFE, EDUCATOR AND BERKELEY
PARENTS FOR COLLECTIVE
LIBERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
BERKELEY PARENT AND, PART OF THE
BERKELEY FAMILIES FOR,
COLLECTIVE LIBERATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE THANK YOU NICOLE WATERMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MISS WILLMAN, DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, ANY
OPPOSITION HERE SEEING NONE,
LET'S COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, COLLEAGUES
ON THE MEASURE. SENATOR CHOBOQ.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
MEASURE FORWARD. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO I
ABSOLUTELY SYMPATHIZE WITH THE
IDEA THAT IF A STUDENT IS, IS
SEEKING HELP, THAT I DON'T KNOW
IF ANY SCHOOL, I DON'T KNOW,
MAYBE YOU HAVE THE DATA. I DON'T
HAVE THE DATA OF SCHOOLS
ACTUALLY SUSPENDING STUDENTS OR
EXPELLING STUDENTS FOR HAVING,
THE SUBSTANCES ON, ON HAND. BUT
DO WE HAVE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT
WE HAVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS, THAT
IF A STUDENT IS SEEKING HELP,
THAT THEY ARE BEING EXPELLED OR
SUSPENDED? THIS BILL WOULD PUT
FORWARD THAT THAT STIPULATION
THAT IF A STUDENT IS ASKING FOR
HELP, THAT THEY CAN'T BE THEN
SUSPENDED OR EXPELLED FOR
SEEKING THAT TREATMENT EARLY ON
IN THE BILL ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE, WE GOT INTO DIFFERENT
DEBATES AND WE TOOK SOME
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
SOME OF THOSE CHANGES. OKAY,
BECAUSE I JUST I WAS JUST GOING
TO CURIOUS. WE'RE VERY DATA
DRIVEN IN THE LEGISLATURE. SO I
WAS JUST WONDERING WHETHER OR
NOT WE ACTUALLY HAD RECORD OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACTUALLY
SUSPENDING STUDENTS FOR, FOR
SEEKING HELP, ADMITTING THAT
THEY HAVE AN ISSUE OR SUBSTANCE
ON THEMSELVES AND SEEKING HELP
AND BEING EXPELLED. I DON'T KNOW
IF WE HAVE THE DATA. DO WE HAVE
I'M NOT SURE IF THE COMMITTEE
KNOWS OR NOT, BUT, SO THAT WAS
MY QUESTION AND NUMBER TWO, THE
CONCERN THAT I WOULD HAVE IS IF
A STUDENT IS DOING SOMETHING
WRONG, I MEAN, PRETTY HEAVY AT A
SCHOOL, I CAN'T THINK OF AN
EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW. BUT IF
THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING, SAY
ILLICIT OR SOMETHING THAT IS
DANGEROUS AT THE SCHOOL CAMPUS,
CAN A STUDENT, USE THIS AS A
MEASURE TO AVOID GETTING IN
TROUBLE AND BEING REDIRECTED, TO
GET HELP AND RESOURCES, WHICH
ULTIMATELY IS WHAT WE WANT THEM
TO DO. BUT WILL THIS BE USED?
BASICALLY AS A QUOTE UNQUOTE COP
OUT FROM GETTING IN TROUBLE? SO
PART OF THE DATA DOES SHOW THAT
OVER 70% OF ADULTS THAT ARE
ADDICTED TO SOME TYPE OF FORM OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE, ALCOHOLISM, AND
OTHER THINGS STARTED OFF AT AN
EARLY AGE IN K THROUGH 12. THIS
IS A PROACTIVE MEASURE TO START
TO SEEK THOSE RESOURCES AND GET
THEM THE RESOURCES THEY NEED. IF
THEY SO CHOOSE TO COME FORWARD
AND SAY THEY HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
SOME SUBSTANCE ABUSE AS FAR AS
THE COMPONENT IN THE BILL THAT
NOW IS AMENDED OUT, WILL DRAFT,
WILL BE WORKING WITH THAT NEXT
YEAR THAT DEALT WITH THE
DIFFERENT LIABILITIES AND
DIFFERENT AREAS IN THERE, WHAT
CAN BE SUSPENDED AND WHAT
COULDN'T BE WITH, DIFFERENT
SUBSTANCE, LIKE FENTANYL AND
THOSE THINGS THIS IS PURELY
TRYING TO BE A PROACTIVE TO
SOMEBODY THAT'S SEEKING SUPPORT
FROM THE SCHOOL SYSTEM TO BE
ABLE TO BE AFFORDED THAT THAT
RESOURCE IN FRONT OF THEM. IT'S
NOT MEANT TO BE A PREVENTIVE
MEASURE FOR SOMEONE TO NOT BE
ABLE TO BE EXPELLED, BUT THEY
CAN'T BE EXPELLED FOR PURELY
ASKING FOR THAT HELP. AND I
ABSOLUTELY, I ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND THAT POINT. I'M JUST,
YOU KNOW, KIDS ARE VERY SMART,
PEOPLE ARE VERY SMART. AND I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE COULD BE A
POTENTIAL THAT IF A STUDENT DOES
SOMETHING WRONG, THEY COULD SAY,
WELL, YOU KNOW, I HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH ALCOHOL OR DRUGS. I NEED
HELP AND THEREFORE NOT BE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THEIR ACTIONS.
THAT'S THE CONCERN THAT I WANT
TO EXPRESS, BECAUSE I KNOW A LOT
OF TEACHERS, ESPECIALLY IN HIGH
SCHOOL, ARE VERY FRUSTRATED THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS
IN ORDER TO, EXERCISE DISCIPLINE
AND ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF THE
BEHAVIORS THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
THE CLASSROOMS. HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHEN WE, YOU
AND I WENT TO SCHOOL, BUT AND
TEACHERS ARE CHALLENGED WITH A
LOT OF BEHAVIORS THAT REALLY ARE
VERY DISRUPTIVE. SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS,
WELL-INTENDED, COULD ALSO HAVE,
CONSEQUENCES IN WHICH PEOPLE
COULD OR STUDENTS IN THIS CASE
COULD USE IT TO GET AWAY WITH,
WITH, BEHAVIORS THAT ARE NOT
THAT ARE DISRUPTIVE. I'LL JUST
PUT IT THAT WAY. WELL, THANK YOU
FOR THAT. AND FOR YOUR QUESTION.
THIS IS MEANT TO BE PROACTIVE,
EVEN IF IT SAVES ONE YOUTH FROM
GOING DOWN THAT TRACK OF
ADDICTION. AS AN ADULT. WE'RE
DOING OUR PART AS A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT'S TIME THAT WE
START TO BE MORE PROACTIVE. AND
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN,
IF SOMEONE IS USING IT FOR THAT
SENSE TO MOVE FORWARD, ISN'T IT
WORTH IT HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR OUR YOUTH TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A VOICE TO SAY, I
NEED HELP AND GET THEM THE
SERVICES THEY NEED EARLY ON,
RATHER THAN DEALING WITH THE 70%
THAT'S OUT THERE THAT'S ADDICTED
TO SUBSTANCE ABUSE, ALCOHOLISM
THAT STARTED OFF AT A YOUNG AGE.
I THINK THIS BILL STARTS TO
BRING THAT BALANCE BACK INTO
PLAY. I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
YOU ON ON THAT END, I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND
WHAT THAT AND THAT'S WHY I WAS
ASKING. MY FIRST QUESTION WAS
WITH REGARDS TO THE DATA AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WERE KNOWN
TO EXPEL STUDENTS OR SUSPEND
STUDENTS FOR SEEKING HELP WITH
REGARDS TO DISCLOSING WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'RE ADDICTED. THAT'S WHY
MY FIRST QUESTION AND THEN MY
FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO THAT, THIS
BILL WOULD MAKE IT SO THAT
SOMEONE THAT IS SEEKING HELP
CANNOT BE EXPELLED OR SUSPENDED
FOR PURELY SEEKING THAT THAT
HELP. I APPRECIATE THAT AND ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS, SENATOR WILK
ANYTHING, LET ME ADD, I MEAN, I
THINK IT'S A TESTAMENT TO THE
BILL THAT THERE WERE SO MANY,
SCHOOL RELATED ENTITIES HERE TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS, ETC. WHICH
SPEAKS, I THINK, TO THE VALIDITY
OF THE OBJECTIVE HERE. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM, WE DO NOT YET, BUT WE'LL
TAKE UP A MOTION WHEN WE DO. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE, THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS
FROM THE DAIS. I TRULY LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT. AND I
ASK FOR AN AYE AYE RECO ON THIS
BILL. AND I VOTE ON THIS BILL
WHEN IT COMES FORWARD. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES, IT WILL TAKE THAT UP
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM, NEXT I
SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S SORIA.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING. I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAD SOME TRAFFIC
ISSUES. YOU HAVE MADE IT THROUGH.
AND WELCOME. YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING AB 2104, AT YOUR
READY AND WELCOME TO YOUR
WITNESSES. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THAT I'D LIKE TO
START BY THANKING, THE CHAIR AND
YOUR STAFF FOR THE HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL AND HELPING FACILITATE
ALSO CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN OUR
OFFICE AND SENATOR ROTH'S
OFFICE. I WOULD ALSO JUST
UPFRONT, WANT TO STATE UP STATE
MY COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH SENATOR ROTH'S
OFFICE TO REACH AN AGREEMENT ON
HOW BOTH OF OUR BILLS WILL MOVE
FORWARD. THAT PRESERVES THE
AMENDMENTS MADE BY THIS
COMMITTEE TO SB 895. AB 2104,
WHICH IS A LATINO CAUCUS AND
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY, WILL
HELP ADDRESS OUR HEALTH CARE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE AND IMPROVE
THE ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY OF
A NURSING DEGREE BY ESTABLISHING
A PILOT PROGRAM ALLOWING
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO
ESTABLISH NURSING BACHELOR
DEGREES. ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT CONSEQUENCES OF
COVID 19 PANDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN AN UNPRECEDENTED
NURSING SHORTAGE. CALIFORNIA IS
PROJECTED TO BE SHORT OVER
44,000 REGISTERED NURSES BY
2030. THIS SHORTAGE IS FELT THE
HARDEST IN RURAL AREAS LIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, WHICH I
REPRESENT, WHERE WE'VE ALREADY
SEEN MADERA COMMUNITY HOSPITAL
CLOSE IN PART DUE TO ITS LACK OF
AVAILABLE LOCAL MEDICAL
PERSONNEL. WHILE OUR EXCEPTIONAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM HAS
PROVIDED MANY STUDENTS WITH AN
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE IN NURSING,
OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM MORE
FREQUENTLY DEMANDS A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. WHILE OUR RURAL STUDENTS
WOULD LOVE TO COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION AT A CSU CAMPUS, THEY
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE
TRANSPORTATION TO REACH THESE
SCHOOLS. AND WHEN THEY DO, THERE
MAY NOT BE ANY SLOTS LEFT. IN
PARTICULAR, IN MY DISTRICT, MANY
IN THE RURAL COMMUNITIES HAVE TO
TRAVEL MORE THAN AN HOUR, PLUS,
TO BE ABLE TO REACH A STATE
UNIVERSITY WITH HOUSING COSTS
AND TRANSPORTATION COSTS
INCREASING EVERY YEAR, THIS IS
BECOMING A GREATER BURDEN FOR
OUR STUDENTS IN THESE SMALL
RURAL COMMUNITIES. AND SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT TWO COMMON ARE
MOST PROMISING STUDENTS HAVE TO
UPROOT THEIR LIVES TO GO TO
SCHOOLS IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE, EVEN OUT OF STATE, AND
NEVER COMING BACK OR ATTENDING
CLOSER. WHEN YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY GO AND ATTEND A
PRIVATE UNIVERSITY, THEY NEVER
COME BACK OR THEY ARE SADDLED
WITH A LOT OF DEBT BECAUSE HOW
EXPENSIVE THESE PROGRAMS ARE
WHEN THEY GO TO PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES. SO WE ALSO KNOW
THAT DATA SHOWS THAT STUDENTS
WHO ARE LIKE ARE LIKELIER TO
STAY WHERE THEY, ESSENTIALLY GET
EDUCATED AND TRAINED AND SO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE THE MOST
AFFORDABLE. I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB TO ENSURE THAT.
AND THEY'RE THE MOST ACCESSIBLE
WHEN IT COMES TO HIGHER
EDUCATION OPTIONS FOR OUR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. AND I WILL
SAY FOR RURAL STUDENTS,
PREDOMINANTLY, THEY ARE THE
SOLUTION, PART OF THE SOLUTION
TO OUR HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE THAT HAS BEEN STARING
US IN THE FACE THIS WHOLE TIME,
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE READY
TO MEET THIS CHALLENGE, ALL WE
HAVE TO DO IS ALLOW THEM TO. SO
AB 2104 DOES THIS BY DIRECTING
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO SELECT UP
TO 15 COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS, TO PARTICIPATE IN A
PILOT PROGRAM OR PROJECT, TO
OFFER A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
NURSING? WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. I HAVE, DOCTOR CAROL
GOLDSMITH, THE CHANCELLOR OF
STATE CENTER COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
WHICH IS IN MY DISTRICT, AND
THEN ALSO VANESSA GONZALEZ,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION. GOOD
MORNING. WHO'S FIRST DOCTOR?
GOLDSMITH. YES, PLEASE PROCEED.
YES. GOOD MORNING, AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
ON THIS MATTER. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME, MY NAME IS
CAROL GOLDSMITH. I'M THE
CHANCELLOR OF THE FOUR COLLEGES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AS
ASSEMBLYWOMAN SORIA SHARED, THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS REALLY FACING
A SIGNIFICANT NURSING SHORTAGE,
AS IS THE STATE. BUT IT'S REALLY
BEEN EXACERBATED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THIS IS IN AN AREA WHERE
THE POPULATION IS MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AND HAS CONTINUING
GROWING HEALTH CARE NEEDS. THE
CRISIS IS CRITICALLY EVIDENT IN
MY REGION. EXCUSE ME, WHERE A
NUMBER OF LIMITED NURSING
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN IMPACTED,
LEAVING MANY OF OUR YOUNG,
TALENTED NO OTHER CHOICE BUT TO
SEEK OUTSIDE OPTIONS OUTSIDE OUR
STATE, OUTSIDE OUR REGION, OR
PERHAPS ENROLL IN VERY EXPENSIVE
PRIVATE PROGRAMS, SOME CHARGING
UP TO UPWARDS OF $150,000 PER
YEAR. THE SHORTAGE HAS ALSO
CREATED A RELIANCE ON TRAVELING
NURSES, WHICH HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
INCREASED COSTS OF PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE, AND WAS IN PART DUE
TO THE CLOSURE OF MADERA
COMMUNITY HOSPITAL. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE INCREASED DEMAND FOR
BACHELOR PREPARED NURSES AT OUR
HOSPITALS ARE FORCING OUR
HOSPITALS TO NOT BE ABLE TO MEET
THAT NEED, AND MANY OF OUR
HOSPITALS IN OUR REGION ARE ON A
WATCH LIST BECAUSE OF THAT.
THANKFULLY, ASSEMBLY BILL 2104,
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN SORIA,
AIMS TO HELP ALLEVIATE THESE
ISSUES BY ESTABLISHING A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALLOW
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO OFFER
BACHELOR'S IN SCIENCE AND
NURSING, COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DEGREE PROGRAMS ARE EXTREMELY
AFFORDABLE. NEW NURSES, WE KNOW
THAT LEAVE THE PRIVATE
POST-SECONDARY ENTER INTO JUST A
WORLD OF DEBT, WE KNOW THAT
STUDENTS IN OUR AREA OFTEN ARE
FIRST GENERATION, OFTEN COMING
FROM IMPOVERISHED HOMES. THIS
JUST SEEMS LIKE AN UNBEARABLE
DEBT BURDEN FOR THESE STUDENTS,
ALLOWING COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
OFFER THIS DEGREE SERVES AS AN
IMPORTANT SOCIAL NEED. NOT ONLY
WILL EXPAND EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR A BROADER
RANGE OF POTENTIAL APPLICANTS,
PARTICULARLY IN THE RURAL AREA.
I WANT TO ASK YOU TO FINISH UP.
SURE, BUT IT WILL ALSO ESTABLISH
A HEALTH CARE SYSTEM BETTER TO
SERVE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BY ENHANCING THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR PROFESSION. WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
ITS HALLMARK, IS SERVING DIVERSE
STUDENTS. WE KNOW THAT BEING
ABLE TO DO THIS, WE'LL BE ABLE
TO HAVE A MORE DIVERSE
WORKFORCE, A MORE DIVERSE
POPULATION TO SERVE. WE ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MISS GONZALEZ.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, VANESSA GONZALEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION, REPRESENTING OVER
400 HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS
IN CALIFORNIA, HERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB 2104 AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA FOR
HER WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
AS YOU KNOW, CALIFORNIA IS IN A
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE CRISIS.
ACCORDING TO A STUDY BY UC SAN
FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA HAD A
SHORTAGE OF 40,000 REGISTERED
NURSES IN 2021, AND OUR MEMBERS
CONTINUE TO REPORT CHALLENGES
FINDING AND RETAINING NURSES.
WITH NURSING POSITIONS BEING
OPEN FOR MONTHS AT A TIME, THE
CHALLENGES ARE EVEN GREATER IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
RURAL PARTS OF THE STATE. THIS
CRITICAL ISSUE HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF INNOVATIVE
SOLUTIONS. ONE SUCH SOLUTION IS
TO ADDRESS THE NURSING SHORTAGE
IS BY UTILIZING CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. COMMUNITY
COLLEGES PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE, ACCESSIBLE
AND QUALITY POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION, PARTICULARLY FOR
STUDENTS FACING FINANCIAL AND
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES. BY
EXPANDING BACCALAUREATE DEGREES
IN NURSING TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AB 2104 WOULD EMPOWER
MORE STUDENTS TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND NURSING, WHICH
WILL HELP MEET THE DEMAND FOR
HIGHLY QUALIFIED NURSES AND
HOSPITALS AND OTHER HEALTH CARE
SETTINGS. ADDITIONALLY, BECAUSE
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
AFFORDABLE AND SERVE A DIVERSE
STUDENT POPULATION, THE NURSING
WORKFORCE WILL BECOME MORE
REFLECTIVE OF THE COMMUNITIES IT
SERVES, LEADING TO BETTER
PATIENT CARE AND OUTCOMES.
FINALLY, WHILE THE MAJORITY OF
HOSPITALS DO NOT REQUIRE BSN
DEGREES, MANY HOSPITALS PREFER
NURSES TO HOLD BACCALAUREATE
DEGREES TO MEET ACCREDITATION
AND QUALITY STANDARDS. AB 2104
WILL HELP PROVIDE GRADUATES WITH
MORE JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND
AVENUES FOR CAREER ADVANCEMENT.
FOR THESE REASONS, THE CHA
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 2104. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. JUSTIN VAN ZYL. ON BEHALF
OF PRESIDENT CHRIS VITELLI OF
MERCED COLLEGE, ALSO IN SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NURSE
ANESTHESIOLOGY AND DAVITA. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE,
CHAIR. MEMBERS ANNA MATTHEWS, ON
BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING.
LORRAINE SMITH, DEAN OF NURSING
AT FRESNO CITY COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE,
ON ARCHIMEDES, ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, ELLA CONNELLY, ON
BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO UNIFIED IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. KELLY
BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA, THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, ALL HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, CHRISTY FOY, WITH
ARNOLD AND ASSOCIATES HERE ON
BEHALF OF FRESENIUS MEDICAL CARE
IN CALIFORNIA. KIDNEY CARE
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA, REPRESENTING THE
STATE'S 116 COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI.
GOOD MORNING, CAROL GONZALEZ, ON
BEHALF OF LONG BEACH CITY
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HI, KEISHA HUNT WITH
NOSSAMAN HERE ON BEHALF OF
CITRUS COLLEGE, NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE, AND
MOUNT SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE, JANINE COHEN,
PARENT AND CONSTITUENT OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. CHARISSE TAYLOR, PUBLIC
EDUCATOR AT BERKELEY HIGH SCHOOL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OKAY,
OPPOSITION. DO WE HAVE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES? WE DO.
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
TABLE. WELCOME. EACH OF YOU WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES AS WELL. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I AM RAMONA TARR,
THE DIRECTOR OF HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR. WE
BELIEVE THAT AB 2104 WON'T
ACHIEVE ITS GOALS, AND IT WON'T
ADD MORE NURSES INTO
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE TO BE
CLEAR, ADN TO BSN PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE CSU HAVE NO
WAITING LIST AND ACCEPT ALL
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS. THERE ARE
NUMEROUS ONLINE PROGRAMS TO
SERVE RURAL STUDENTS. THEREFORE,
AB 2104 WILL ONLY SERVE TO
SIPHON OFF STUDENTS FROM
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADN PROGRAMS.
COMING INTO THE CSU.
ADDITIONALLY, AB 2104 WILL NOT
CREATE ANY ADDITIONAL NURSES
SINCE IT DOESN'T OVERCOME CORE
NURSING EDUCATIONAL BARRIERS
SUCH AS CLINICAL PLACEMENTS AND
STRICT REGULATIONS BY THE
STATE'S BURDEN, WHICH AFFECTS
ALL NURSING PROGRAMS. DESPITE
THIS, THE CSU HAS INVESTED IN
EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THESE CHALLENGES THROUGH ONLINE
PROGRAMS, WHICH CAN SERVE RURAL
AND NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS, AS
WELL AS PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS.
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS INCREASE
ACCESSIBILITY AND REDUCES THE
TIME OF COMPLETION OF BOTH AN
ADN AND BSN DEGREE PROGRAM FROM
4 TO 6 YEARS TO 3 TO 5.
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS ARE COST
EFFECTIVE AND PROVIDE
STREAMLINED CURRICULUMS.
NATIONAL ACCREDITATION FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, CLINICAL
PLACEMENT COORDINATION, FASTER
PATHWAYS TO GRADUATION, AND
BUILT IN FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS. 13 CSU HAVE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS WITH OVER
35 COMMUNITY COLLEGES, WITH MORE
UPCOMING AND UNFORTUNATELY,
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE HAS CHOSEN
NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS. THE CSU IS
RENOWNED FOR ITS EXCELLENT
QUALITY NURSING EDUCATION.
ON-TIME COMPLETION RATE,
GRADUATION RATE, LICENSURE PASS
RATES AS WELL. EVERY CSU NURSING
SCHOOL HAS AN NCLEX PASS RATES
OF AT LEAST 92% AND ABOVE,
COMPARED TO COMMUNITY COLLEGES
86. BACHELOR'S DEGREE NURSING
PROGRAMS ARE NOT EASY TO
ESTABLISH. THEY ARE RESOURCE
INTENSIVE INITIATIVES THAT
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL FACULTY
ADMINISTRATION, CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS, AND ACCREDITATION
EXPENSES. I ALSO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO LOOK INTO THE COSTS
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACHELOR'S
DEGREE PROGRAMS AND CONSIDER THE
EDUCATION CODE CURRENTLY
AUTHORIZES COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OFFERING BACHELOR'S DEGREE
PROGRAMS TO CHARGE FEES UP TO
WHAT THE CSU CHARGES, THEREFORE
PROVIDING NO FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES TO STUDENTS. AND I
HAVE TO ASK YOU TO FINISH THEM.
IN SUM, AB 20 104 IS NOT
NECESSARY. IT IS COSTLY. IT
CREATES A PRECEDENT OF
DUPLICATION, WHICH WILL BE
HARMFUL FOR INTERSEGMENTAL
EFFECTIVENESS AND COLLABORATIONS
FOR THESE REASONS, THE CSU
REQUESTS A NO VOTE ON AB 20 104.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. WELCOME.
THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS NICK
ROMO WITH CRUZ STRATEGIES ON
BEHALF OF IQ PINCH-HITTING.
TODAY ON BEHALF OF ALEX GRAVES,
I'M AQ REPRESENTING 89
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE,
INCLUDING OVER TWO DOZEN THAT
OFFER NURSING PROGRAMS, OUR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ARE A
LEADER IN THE STATE'S PRODUCTION
OF THE NURSING WORKFORCE. AND
2122 OUR PROGRAM PRODUCED 46% OF
THE NEW BACCALAUREATE DEGREES IN
NURSING IN THE STATE. AND IF YOU
INCLUDE ADVANCED DEGREES, WE'RE
LOOKING AT OVER 50% OF THE FOUR
YEAR ADVANCED DEGREE NURSING
STUDENTS IN THE STATE. AND WE
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT WE WELCOME
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW THE STATE CAN
WORK TO IMPROVE AND EXPAND THE
NURSING WORKFORCE AND HOW TO
MEET RURAL HEALTHCARE NEEDS. OUR
OPPOSITION IS ROOTED IN THREE
KEY ISSUES. CHAIR THE MAJOR
IMPEDIMENTS TO INCREASING
ENROLLMENTS IN NURSING PROGRAMS
ARE REALLY A LACK OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS AND A LACK OF
QUALIFIED FACULTY TO TEACHING
PROGRAMS. NEITHER OF THOSE
ISSUES ARE ADDRESSED IN THIS
BILL, AND THEREFORE WE DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THIS LEGISLATION
WILL ADD A SINGLE ADDITIONAL
NURSING STUDENT INTO THE
PIPELINE TO ADDRESS WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES. ACCORDING TO THAT
RESEARCH FROM UCSF. IN FACT, THE
NURSING SHORTAGE IN THE STATE IS
EXPECTED TO BE RESOLVED IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS. LOOKING AT 2728,
WHICH BRINGS INTO QUESTION WHY
WE ARE IN SUCH A RUSH TO EXPAND
THE DEGREE AUTHORITY IN THIS
CASE. WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
DISINCENTIVIZES INTERSEGMENTAL
COLLABORATION, WHICH HAVE BEEN
DEMONSTRATED TO PROVIDE
COLLABORATIVE, EFFECTIVE AND
EXPEDITED ADDING OF BSN PATHWAYS
FOR STUDENTS. NOW, THESE
PROGRAMS AND PIPELINES ALREADY
ARE ALREADY EQUIPPED WITH THE
RESOURCES SUCH AS ADEQUATE
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS, DISTANCE
LEARNING MODALITIES AND FACULTY
TO TEACH AT THIS LEVEL.
ADDITIONALLY, TO NOTE THAT THE
STATE BUDGET INCLUDES $60
MILLION THAT, AMONG OTHER
THINGS, SUPPORTS FURTHER
EXPANSION OF THESE MODELS
BETWEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
THE FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS. IT
HAS BEEN SUGGESTED THAT PRIVATE
COLLEGES ARE UNAFFORDABLE. ON
THAT, I WILL NOTE THAT NATIONAL
UNIVERSITY OFFERS ADDING TO BSN
ONLINE PROGRAM THAT COSTS
$17,000. I HAVE TO ASK YOU TO
FINISH UP MR. CHAIR. IN SUM, WE
ARE IN SHORT, WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
NURSING SHORTAGE. WE BELIEVE THE
BILL IS A JAILBREAK OF LAST
SESSION'S AGREEMENT THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SHOULD HAVE
EXPANDED BACCALAUREATE
AUTHORITY. THANK YOU, OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. RON NORBY,
DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL OF
NURSING, CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, DOMINGUEZ HILLS, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. PENNY
WEISSMULLER, DIRECTOR OF THE
SCHOOL OF NURSING AT CAL STATE
FULLERTON, IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MICHELLE
BEST, DEAN FOR THE COLLEGE OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN DEVELOPMENT AT
CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE, NURSING IS
IN OUR COLLEGE. WE OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. DAVE SAU. I'M THE DEAN OF
THE COLLEGE OF NATURAL SCIENCES
AT CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
CHICO, WHICH INCLUDES THE SCHOOL
OF NURSING. OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
CELESTINA BARBOSA LEIKER, DEAN
OF THE COLLEGE OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN DEVELOPMENT, WHICH
INCLUDES THE SCHOOL OF NURSING
AT CAL STATE FULLERTON. OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. CHRISTINE ISAACSON,
FACULTY MEMBER, SENATOR,
ACADEMIC SENATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM, REPRESENTING ALL 23 CSU
CAMPUSES. WE'RE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, DOCTOR MARLA
SECHREST, DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL
OF NURSING AT STAN STATE. AND WE
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. PHYLLIS
SALOPEK, ASSISTANT DIRECTOR AT
CSU CHICO, IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HI. ELAINE
MUSSELMAN, DIRECTOR OF SCHOOL OF
NURSING AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY. OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
HI, LISA RAUSCH, DIRECTOR OF THE
VALLEY FOUNDATION SCHOOL OF
NURSING AT SAN JOSE STATE.
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. HELLO,
REBECCA. CHILD PROGRAM DIRECTOR
AT CAL STATE UNIVERSITY,
NORTHRIDGE. WE HAVE UNLIMITED
ENROLLMENTS ONLINE. FALL. JUST
PUTTING A PLUG OUT THERE FOR ALL
OF YOU, EVEN IN YOUR DISTRICT.
THANK YOU. TANYA ALTMAN, CHAIR
OF THE SACRAMENTO STATE SCHOOL
OF NURSING. IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. FAYE MITCHELL BROWN,
DIRECTOR OF SCHOOL OF NURSING,
CSU CHICO, A RURAL AREA WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. STEVEN. FILLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, JASON MURPHY, ON BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL AT THIS TIME. HOWEVER,
THE UNIVERSITY DOES OFFER BSN
PROGRAMS AT BOTH IRVINE AND
UCLA. WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DUPLICATION PRESENTED HERE. I
APPRECIATE THAT, THANK YOU, COME
BACK TO THE DAIS, COLLEAGUES,
QUESTION COMMENTS. SENATOR
CHOBO, GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. SIR.
CHAIRMAN SIR. SEARS. FINE GOOD.
WELCOME. GLAD TO HEAR THIS,
BILL. AND I KNOW WE'VE HEARD
SIMILAR ONES FROM, SENATOR ROTH.
SO A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS, THAT
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO PUT ON RECORD
HERE. SO WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT OCCUR IN
SECURING CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SITES FOR NURSING STUDENTS. HOW
WOULD THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES
DIFFERENTLY FROM WHAT OUR,
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY DO? SO THE
BULK OF THE CLINICAL SITES AT
THE HOSPITAL SITES HAPPENS
DURING THE FIRST TWO YEARS OF
EDUCATION. WHICH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ALREADY PROVIDE FOR THE
BACHELOR'S PORTION, THAT
COMMUNITY HEALTH REQUIREMENT OR
PRACTICUM WORK IS NOT AT THE
HOSPITAL SITE. SO ONE ON ONE
PRACTICUM, IT CAN BE DONE IN A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
SETTINGS. IT CAN BE DONE WITH
THEIR SUPERVISOR. IT'S DONE POST
LICENSURE. IT DOES NOT TAKE AWAY
ANY CLINICAL SITES IN THE
TRADITIONAL SITE AND TRADITIONAL
METHOD OF MEANING CLINICAL.
BEING AT THE HOSPITAL SITE, IT'S
MORE OF A PRACTICUM. IT'S A ONE
ON ONE. MANY OF OUR ADJUNCTS
COULD ALSO SERVE IN THAT ROLE.
TO BE ABLE TO BE THE PRACTICUM
ADVISOR DURING THAT BACHELOR
HIGHER ED COMPONENT. SO IT'S NOT
THE CLINICAL SITES THAT WE OFTEN
THINK ABOUT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
THE JUGGERNAUT OF WHICH TO
EXPAND. OKAY. SO IT'S DONE. THE
FIRST TWO YEARS, NOT THE SECOND
YEAR. AND THEY COULD BE DONE IN
ALTERNATIVE OTHER THAN THE
CLINICAL SITES. SO WE GOT WE GOT
THAT ADDRESSED, DOES THE CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE OF ADN TO BSN AND
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS IN THE
STATE ADEQUATELY SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF NURSING PROGRAMS TO
MEET THE WORKFORCE DEMANDS FOR
BSN GRADUATES WHO GRADUATE IN A
TIMELY FASHION? YEAH, I WOULD
ARGUE IT DOESN'T. AND I WOULD
THINK THIS IS NOT A ZERO SUM
GAME. THIS IS A HEALTH CRISIS. I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO NEED ALL OF
OUR INSTITUTIONS WORKING
TOGETHER. AND IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED HERE THAT FRESNO STATE
AND FRESNO CITY IS NOT WORKING
TOGETHER. FRESNO CITY AND FRESNO
STATE IS WORKING TOGETHER. AND
IN FACT, THEY'RE HELPING US WITH
OUR ASEAN, LICENSURE. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF GRANTS TOGETHER, WE
KNOW THAT THEY TURN AWAY
STUDENTS. WE TURN AWAY STUDENTS.
WE CANNOT, AS A STATE, TURN AWAY
ANY STUDENT, THE PRIVATES, THE
FOUR YEAR OR THE TWO YEAR. SO
IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE I, I
HEARD FROM ONE OF THE WITNESSES
THAT THERE ARE CURRENTLY NO
WAITLISTS FOR NURSING. THERE ARE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I CAN'T
SPEAK TO WHAT THE WOMAN SPOKE TO
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OR THE
OTHER PART, BUT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, THEY'RE NOT ONLY
WAITLIST, BUT WE'RE TURNING AWAY
HUNDREDS OF STUDENTS. OKAY WELL,
SEND US A DATA AND WE CAN WE CAN
LOOK AT THAT, IF YOU DISAGREE,
IN REGARD TO THE FACULTY
SHORTAGES, WHICH IS A HUGE
COMPONENT THAT WE'VE HEARD IN
THE PAST, NOT JUST IN THIS
COMMITTEE, BUT IN OTHER, IN
OTHER, FORMATS OF DISCUSSION.
WHAT STRATEGIES ARE IN PLACE TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE ENOUGH
QUALIFIED FACULTY MEMBERS TO
TEACH IN BOTH YOUR UNIVERSITIES
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS? SURE SO IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO TEACH, THE REQUIREMENT
TO TEACH FOR A BACHELOR'S
PROGRAM IS A MASTER'S DEGREE.
EVERY COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
MEMBER ALSO HAS TO MEET A
MINIMUM QUALS, WHICH IS A
MASTER'S DEGREE. OUR FACULTY ARE
PREPARED TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THAT. IN ADDITION TO THAT, WE
KNOW THAT IT'S ALSO BENEFICIAL
TO HAVE DOCTORATE PREPARED
NURSES. WE PARTNER AGAIN WITH
THE CSU, WHO OFFER DOCTORATE
DEGREES IN NURSING, WHICH ALSO
KIND OF WENT OUT OF THE LANE OF
THE HIGHER ED PLAN WRITTEN BACK
IN THE 50S, THEY'RE PUTTING OUT
FANTASTIC DOCTOR PREPARED
NURSES, MANY OF WHOM ARE
EMPLOYED AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. BUT AGAIN, CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY MUST
HAVE A MASTER'S. THAT IS THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENT IN ORDER TO
TEACH AT A BACHELOR'S PROGRAM.
SO THEY WOULD CONTINUE.
BASICALLY, YOU'RE STATING THAT
THEY WOULD CONTINUE FROM
TEACHING THE FROM THE
ASSOCIATE'S DEGREE INTO THE TO
THE BACHELOR'S DEGREE. CORRECT.
THE SAME STAFF WOULD DO THE FULL
TIME. YES. OKAY, AND THEN SO WE
GOT THAT COVERED AND THE LAST,
THE LAST QUESTION THAT I HAVE
FOR YOU HAS TO DO WITH THE
ACCREDITATION WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT NOT ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE ACCREDITED. AND IN ORDER TO,
MOVE FORWARD WITH THESE PILOT
PROGRAMS, WILL YOU BE TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION WHEN
ASSIGNING THEM TO CERTAIN,
COMMUNITY COLLEGES? SURE SO
THEIR REQUIREMENT, BE THAT THEY
ARE ACCREDITED? SURE. SO ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE PROGRAMS
ARE ACCREDITED THROUGH OCC, JC,
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS GO THROUGH
ACCREDITATION THROUGH THE BURN
IN ORDER TO HAVE A BACHELOR'S
PREPARED PROGRAM, YOU MUST HAVE
THOSE AS A MINIMUM. THE ROTH
BILL. AND I BELIEVE THE SAU BILL
PUT AN ADDITIONAL, ACCREDITATION
REQUIREMENT, WHICH IS THE ACN.
IT'S A NATIONAL ACCREDITATION,
IT IS NOT A MUST HAVE, BUT IT IS
A GOOD ACCREDITATION. MANY OF
THE COLLEGES ARE SEEKING THAT.
MY COLLEGE IS ONE OF THEM. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES NOW THAT
ALREADY HAVE THAT, NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION, AGAIN, ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF US WORKING WITH OUR
LOCAL CSU, THEY'VE HELPED US
WITH THAT ACCREDITATION. AND
WE'RE IN CANDIDACY RIGHT NOW.
OKAY. AND HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE
FOR THE CANDIDACY TO BE
COMPLETED? OUR OUR LAST VISIT
WILL BE HELD THIS SPRING. OKAY.
SO YOU WILL BE, THEY WILL BE
FULLY ACCREDITED BEFORE THE
PILOT PROGRAMS BEGIN. CORRECT.
AND THERE ARE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
NOW THAT HAVE THAT,
ACCREDITATION. DELTA COLLEGE IS
ONE OF THEM. AND THAT'S IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR WILK. ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? NO. LET ME
ASK A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS, BUT
LET ME NOTE BEFORE I DO THAT,
THAT THIS BILL OVERLAPS
SUBSTANTIALLY WITH SENATOR
ROTH'S SB 95 AND THAT BILL HAS
MOVED, AND SO, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PARALLEL PATHS,
EVEN IF THIS BILL FAILS TODAY,
YOU KNOW, MUCH OF THE POLICY
WILL PROCEED CERTAINLY TO THE
APPROPRIATE STEP IN THE NEXT
HOUSE. SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO, TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE, AND
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS SINCE,
IS MATCH THESE BILLS UP SO THAT
THEY DON'T CONFLICT. BUT I DO
WANT TO I WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION. SO IT'S THE ASSERTIONS
BEEN MADE THAT THERE'S A NURSING
SHORTAGE. THE ASSERTIONS HAVE
MADE COUNTER THAT THERE IS NOT.
AND SO IS THERE OR ISN'T THERE.
AND I GUESS THE LARGER POINT IS
WOULD THIS BILL, IF THERE WERE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT
WON'T WILL THAT MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESS THE NURSING SHORTAGE?
THIS IS ABOUT ACCESS AS AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, NOT NECESSARILY
ABOUT AN INCREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF CANDIDATES. SO TO THE AUTHOR,
FIRST, AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION, CHAIRMAN. I DO BELIEVE
IN THAT IN THE VALLEY WE ARE
FACING A MUCH DIRE CRISIS WHEN
IT COMES TO OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. WE SAW THIS REALLY
IMPACT THE MADERA COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT
SOME OF THE FACTORS. ONE OF THE
ISSUES IN THE CLOSURE WAS THAT
40% OF THE NURSES, HIRED BY THE
HOSPITAL WERE TRAVELER NURSES,
NOT LOCAL NURSES FROM OUR
COMMUNITY. AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TACKLING
THAT ISSUE. THAT'S WHY MY
SPECIFIC LEGISLATION WAS MUCH
MORE TARGETED. I UNDERSTAND THAT
SENATOR ROTH OBVIOUSLY HAS A
PARALLEL LEGISLATION, BUT FOR
ME, IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO
PRIORITIZE THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I
DON'T WANT ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN THIS, YOU KNOW, BUILDING TO
BE ABLE TO EXPERIENCE WHAT MY
COMMUNITY IS FACING RIGHT NOW
WHERE WE HAVE A DESERT HOSPITAL,
BECAUSE A RESULT OF THE
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE IN OUR REGION
AND SO THAT'S WHY, FOR ME, THIS
BILL HAS BEEN VERY IMPORTANT IN
REALLY HIGHLIGHTING THE
DISPARATE NEED THAT EXISTS IN
THE VALLEY, AND THAT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT FOLKS THAT LIVE IN
HURON, THAT IT TAKES THEM WELL
OVER AN HOUR AND 20 MINUTES TO
DRIVE TO FRESNO STATE. STUDENTS
AREN'T MOVING TO LIVE IN THE
CITY OF FRESNO BECAUSE IT'S MORE
EXPENSIVE. THEY'RE STAYING AT
HOME. SO THEIR CLOSEST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS ONLY 20 MINUTES AWAY.
AND SO THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
FOR ME. IT'S ABOUT ACCESS AND
EQUITY TO RURAL STUDENTS, AND TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP THEM IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO THAT THEY
NOT ONLY GET EDUCATED AND
TRAINED IN THOSE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CLINICS, BUT ACTUALLY
STAY IN SERVICE, PROVIDE, YOU
KNOW, THE QUALITY CARE THAT
THOSE FOLKS IN THE RURAL
COMMUNITIES DESERVE. I
APPRECIATE THAT. SO LET ME LET
ME ASK A QUESTION TO DOCTOR
GOLDSMITH. YOU'VE MADE THE
ASSERTION I'VE HEARD BEFORE THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE BETTER
SUITED TO PROVIDE NURSING
INSTRUCTION AT A REDUCED COST.
I'VE HEARD THE OPPOSITE FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT AT THE END OF
THE DAY, ONCE YOU FACTOR IN, ALL
THE VARIOUS INPUTS THAT IT'S NOT
THAT DIFFERENT. SO CAN YOU
PLEASE ELABORATE THERE? SURE. I
WANT TO HIT ON THE DIVERSITY
PIECE AS WELL. IF YOU GO ON TO
THE BURN WEBSITE AND YOU SEARCH
FOR YOUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, AND YOU LOOK AT
THE DIVERSITY, YOU'LL FIND THAT
THE LAST YEAR'S COHORT HAD NO
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS IN IT.
HOWEVER, IF YOU LOOK AT THE TWO
YEAR PUBLIC CENTRAL VALLEY,
YOU'LL SEE THAT THERE WERE 45.
SO THERE'S ISSUES OF DIVERSITY,
THERE'S ISSUES OF ACCESS,
THERE'S ISSUES OF COST. AND I
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND SITTING
NEXT TO ME ABOUT THE COST. WE
KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BACHELOR
PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING OFFERED
NOW ARE OFFERED AT A GREAT
REDUCED RATE, AGAIN, I DON'T
THINK THIS SHOULD BE A ZERO SUM
GAME. WE NEED ALL OF OUR CSUS.
WE NEED THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
AND WE NEED OUR PRIVATES IN THIS
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THE NEED BEFORE WE
SEE MORE HOSPITAL CLOSES. OKAY.
APPRECIATE THAT, AND LAST, WELL,
LET ME LET ME FINISH, YOU KNOW,
I THINK THE VERY VALID POINT HAS
BEEN RAISED ABOUT THE PRECEDENT
AS IT RELATES TO DUPLICATION
ACROSS SEGMENTS, WHICH IS A
LARGER PROBLEM. AND, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
DISCUSSED, THAT WE'VE EXAMINED.
I THINK THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO
DIG INTO IT AND ACTUALLY RESOLVE
TO GREATER CLARITY, BECAUSE IT
IS PROBLEMATIC OVER TIME. THE
MASTER PLAN, ASSUMED A FAIRLY
SORT OF CLEAR SORT OF, DIVISION
OF LABOR, IF YOU WILL, BETWEEN
THE SEGMENTS AND BECOME LARGELY
BECAUSE OF GEOGRAPHICAL AND
WORKFORCE NEEDS. WE'RE SEEING
THAT ERODE. I BELIEVE THAT IS
PROBLEMATIC. I DON'T IT'S
NOBODY'S FAULT HERE. BUT I THINK
IN THE FUTURE WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO RESOLVE THAT TO SOME
GREATER LEVEL OF CLARITY. BUT
THAT DOES PLAY IN HERE. SENATOR
OKOBOJI, IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION,
I THINK I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT
THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS LIMITED
TO TEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT
WILL BE EXERCISED, THIS AND
THAT. IT WILL ALSO SUNSET IN
2031. SO IT'S NOT ONGOING. I
THINK AT THAT TIME WE CAN
REEVALUATE AS A STATE WHETHER OR
NOT THEIR WORKFORCE DEMAND IS
STILL THERE OR THE SHORTAGE. I
SHOULD SAY THE SHORTAGE IS STILL
THERE. AND WHETHER OR NOT THIS
CAN CONTINUE, BECAUSE THERE IS A
CONCERN FOR SOME AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT IT
WILL SIPHON OFF, STUDENTS FROM
THE CSU SYSTEM. AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE CONCERNS THAT I HAVE AS
WELL IS THE FACT THAT, IT WOULD
CREATE A, A SHORTAGE OF STUDENTS
IN THE CSU, WHICH WE NEED AS
WELL. WE NEED I THINK WE THE
BEAUTY ABOUT OUR CSU'S, OUR UCS
AND UCS IS THAT THEY CATER TO
DIFFERENT STUDENTS FOR DIFFERENT
NEEDS. THEY'RE VERY, VERY
DISTINCT SYSTEMS. I KNOW THE
STATE HAS BEEN VERY, A LACK FOR,
FOR A BETTER WORD, AGGRESSIVE IN
COMBINING AND MAKING THEM ALL
KIND OF SIMILAR TO EACH OTHER.
BUT THEY DO HAVE DIFFERENT
ROLES, FOR SPECIFIC STUDENTS AT
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF WHERE
STUDENTS ARE. SO, I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD THAT ON
RECORD THAT THIS DOES HAVE A
SUNSET FOR 2031, AND THE STATE
CAN THEN REEVALUATE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS ACTUALLY A
CONTINUED NEED, FOR, FOR THIS
PROGRAM. LET ME. I'M SORRY,
LET'S LET'S ACTUALLY HEAR FROM
THE CSU IN RESPONSE. I
APPRECIATE THAT, CHAIR, I WANTED
TO ADDRESS FIRST IN REGARDS TO
WHETHER THERE'S A SHORTAGE OR
THERE'S NOT A SHORTAGE, BECAUSE
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO ADDRESS THE BURN
PARTNERS WITH UCSF THAT DOES AN
ANNUAL WORKFORCE REPORT ON OUR
NURSING WORKFORCE AT ALL LEVELS,
PARTICULARLY AT THE BSN LEVEL.
THE REPORT HAS STATED. BY 2027
THAT IF WE DON'T CHANGE ANYTHING
IN THE STATUS QUO IS WHAT IT IS
TODAY, WE WILL HAVE MET THAT
NEED. SO THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GETTING OUR DATA FROM, THE
SECOND ASPECT I WANTED TO
ADDRESS IS IN REGARDS TO THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH PLACEMENT. YES.
THEY DO NOT OCCUR IN THE
HOSPITAL OR A CLINICAL SETTING,
BUT EVEN WITHIN OUR OWN
UNIVERSITIES, THEY ARE A
CHALLENGE FOR US TO RECEIVE
THESE SPOTS, EVEN IF WE HAVE
FACULTY THAT ARE ABLE TO PRESENT
THEM, THE SPOTS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE. SO IT'S GOING TO BE A
CHALLENGE THAT'S GOING TO
EQUALLY AFFECT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS WELL, AND THEN
LASTLY, I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT I DID MENTION THAT NONE OF
OUR PROGRAMS, OUR ADN TO BSN
PROGRAMS ARE IMPACTED OR HAVE
WAITLIST THAT IS PERVASIVE
THROUGHOUT OUR OUR SYSTEM AND
ADDITIONALLY, I UNDERSTAND THAT
FRESNO CITY COLLEGE HAS
PARTNERED A LOT WITH UC. I MEAN,
WITH OUR FRESNO STATE ON A
VARIETY OF INITIATIVES.
UNFORTUNATELY PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS AREN'T ONE OF THOSE. I
BELIEVE PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS ARE
VERY EFFECTIVE. SO SURE, SURE.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU, IT IS FRESNO
STATE ACTUALLY WAS A WITNESS IN
SUPPORT, CORRECT? FRESNO CITY
OKAY, MISS HENDERSON, PLEASE
PROCEED. YEAH ABSOLUTELY, WE
BELIEVE THAT PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS ARE VERY COST EFFECTIVE
AND EFFICIENT. I THINK THE
RESULTS THAT YOU'LL SEE IN
PRODUCING MORE BSNS WOULD BE
MUCH QUICKER THAN WAITING FOR
THESE BSN PROGRAMS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO BE
ESTABLISHED IN ESSENCE, WE NEED
BOTH ADN AND BSN DEGREE
PROFESSIONALS, ESPECIALLY IN
THESE MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
AREAS, UNFORTUNATELY, IF WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE AWAY CAPACITIES
FOR ADN STUDENTS, THEN PRODUCE
MORE ADN THEN WE'RE JUST NOT
DOING ANYTHING FOR THE NURSING
WORKFORCE, ESSENTIALLY. AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
Kò. AND THEN LASTLY, IN REGARDS
TO THE DUPLICATION ASPECT OF IT,
I DO WANT TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT FOR OUR DOCTORAL
DEGREES, WHERE WE WERE PURSUING
THAT WE WORKED THAT IN
COORDINATION WITH THE UCS, AND
WE HAD A STRICT PROCESS IN
REGARDS TO DUPLICATION, WE THINK
THAT HAVING THIS SORT OF
INTERSEGMENTAL COLLABORATION AS
WELL AS COORDINATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT. I THINK AS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS, WE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB TO
LEVERAGE THE RESOURCES THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE INSTEAD OF
INVESTING MORE RESOURCES ON THAT
TO SEE WHERE WE CAN PARTNER
WITH. WE CAN WE CAN LEVERAGE
EACH OTHER'S UNIQUE ASPECTS AND
ALSO SEE WHICH WAYS THAT WE CAN
TAKE TO SUPPORT STUDENTS AND
MAKE IT MORE EQUITABLE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. BUT I GUESS, YOU
KNOW, LET ME LET THE AUTHOR
RESPOND. SO I THINK THE ONE OF
THE OPERATIVE ISSUES HERE IS
PLACE BOUND. CHALLENGES. RIGHT.
AND THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT'S
WHAT SENATOR ROTH WAS TRYING TO.
YEAH. AS WELL. FOR ME, IT'S THE
ACCESS PIECE. AND, YOU KNOW, I
INVITE MY CÁC, THE CSU PARTNERS,
TO COME AND ACTUALLY LISTEN TO
THE STORIES FROM STUDENTS IN MY
REGION, ONE WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO GET INTO FRESNO STATE OR
EVEN UP UP NORTH TO STAN STATE
BECAUSE OF, YOU KNOW, THE ISSUES
OF WAITING LIST AND WAITING OVER
TWO, SOMETIMES EVEN FOUR YEARS
TO GET INTO THESE BACHELOR
PROGRAMS IN MY REGION. I WELCOME
YOU TO COME AND SEE WHAT MADERA
HOSPITAL LOOKS LIKE, CLOSED,
BECAUSE WE DO HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
SHORTAGE AND IT'S NOT BECAUSE,
YOU KNOW, WE DON'T HAVE THE
NURSES. THE NURSES ARE NOT THERE
LOCALLY. THAT ARE QUALIFIED AND
TRAINED TO SERVE IN THE
CAPACITY, AND SO I INVITE THEM
TO REALLY SEE WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN MY AREA. YES. OUR AREA IS
DIFFERENT THAN MAYBE SOME OTHER
AREAS THAT ARE NOT EXPERIENCING
THE, THE SHORTAGES, YOU KNOW,
LIKE WE ARE I WILL ALSO SAY THAT
THE DATA BY UCSF ONLY TELLS ONE
PART OF THE STORY I'VE HEARD
COUNTLESS STORIES DIRECTLY FROM
THE PEOPLE THAT I SERVE, THAT
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO GET TO THESE
PROGRAMS THAT END UP HAVING TO
LEAVE OUT OF STATE. ALSO, TO BE
ABLE TO GO GET A BACHELOR'S IN
NURSING OR THAT END UP GOING TO
A PRIVATE INSTITUTION AND END UP
COMING WITH A LOT OF DEBT AND
YES, CSU MAY BE NOT AS
EXPENSIVE, BUT WHEN WE ARE
FACTORING IN COST OF LIVING AND
STUDENTS HAVING FROM RURAL
COMMUNITIES, FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES, JUST LIKE THE ONE
THAT I GREW UP HAVING TO MOVE TO
THE CITY OF FRESNO TO GO TO A
BACHELOR'S PROGRAM FROM EITHER A
SMALL LIKE FIREBAUGH OR HURON.
THE COST OF LIVING IS
OUTRAGEOUS. AND I THINK THAT,
FOR THESE STUDENTS, I THINK WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THINK OUTSIDE
THE BOX. AND AGAIN, THIS IS NOT
A PROGRAM THAT IS A PERMANENT
PROGRAM. IT IS A PROGRAM THAT IS
SPECIFIC THAT I BELIEVE THAT IN
THE SHORT TERM WILL HELP US,
ESPECIALLY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY, ADDRESS THE NEEDS THAT
WE HAVE. AND MY GOAL IS THAT
THIS WORKFORCE THAT WE WILL HAVE
IN OUR REGION THAT IS EDUCATED
AND TRAINED CAN ACTUALLY HELP US
REOPEN THAT MADERA HOSPITAL. AND
THAT IS MY NUMBER ONE PRIORITY,
CHAIRMAN. AND SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR GUYS'S
SUPPORT. SO THAT IN MY REGION,
WE HAVE ACCESS, WE HAVE EQUITY
TO HIRE ACCESS OF EDUCATION FOR
THESE STUDENTS THAT WANT TO
PURSUE THESE HEALTH CARE
CAREERS, TO ULTIMATELY ENSURE
THAT ALSO THE QUALITY OF CARE IS
PROVIDED TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT
I REPRESENT. THANK YOU. CAN I
TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES? SO
THAT WAS AN AWESOME CLOSE, JUST
A FEW COMMENTS BEFORE WE MOVE
ON, YOU KNOW, THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES. I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY, BUT WITH
MISGIVINGS FOR SIMILAR REASONS.
I THINK WE'VE TOUCHED ON, NOT
THE LEAST OF WHICH IS THIS
QUESTION OF PRECEDENT. AND IT
TRULY IS, PROBLEMATIC. I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE SEEN THIS IN
MANY OTHER SPHERES AS WELL. AT
SOME POINT, THAT BECOMES SORT OF
THE DE FACTO POLICY, AND IT
SHOULDN'T BE, BUT THERE SHOULD
BE GREATER CLARITY. AND I
APPRECIATE EACH OF THE SEGMENTS
JEALOUSLY PROTECTS ITS TURF FOR
REALLY ADMIRABLE REASONS, AND WE
OFTEN INTERFERE WITH THAT BY WAY
OF THESE BILLS. AND SO THAT'S AN
ISSUE. BUT I WANT TO POINT OUT
THE REASON I'M DOING THIS. I
GUESS THERE'S TWO ONE, AS NOTED,
THERE'S A PARALLEL BILL THAT
BILL IS MOVING FORWARD. SO IF I
WERE TO IF THIS BILL WERE TO
FAIL TODAY, THAT THAT POLICY
CONTINUES TO MOVE WHAT WE'RE
ENDEAVORING TO DO IS MAKE SURE
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHAW'S BILL
ALIGNS PROPERLY AS IT MOVES
FORWARD WITH SENATOR ROSS. AND
SO, YOU HAVE AGREED TO WORK. YOU
KNOW, BOTH OF YOU DELIBERATELY
TO WORK ON SORT OF THE
CHAPTERING AND ENROLLMENT
QUESTIONS THAT WILL ARISE IF AND
WHEN BOTH OF THESE BILLS GET TO
THE. YES, MISTER CHAIR. I
ADDRESSED THAT INITIALLY IN MY
STATEMENT. AND SO MY COMMITMENT
IS TO WORK ON THAT. APPRECIATE
IT. THE OTHER REASON I'M WILLING
TO SUPPORT IT IS THIS IS A PILOT
AND QUITE OFTEN WE USE PILOTS AS
KIND OF COVER FOR INSTITUTING
POLICIES THAT GO ON. BUT I THINK
IN THIS CASE, THIS PILOT WILL BE
USEFUL AND IT'LL BE IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK CLARIFYING TO LOOK
AT THE DATA AS WE GET TWO,
THREE, FOUR YEARS INTO IT,
ACCOMMODATIONS HAVE ALSO BEEN
MADE KIND OF ACROSS BOTH BILLS
FOR ACCREDITATION FOR SCHOOLS
THAT ARE NOT YET FOR, YOU KNOW,
THAT ALLOWANCE FOR NOT YET
ACCREDITED. SO THEY CAN
PARTICIPATE AT SOME POINT IF AND
WHEN THEY ARE. SO. SO WITH THAT,
AGAIN, WILLING TO SUPPORT IT,
BUT GRATEFUL FOR THE TESTIMONY
AND MINDFUL OF SOME OF THE
FRICTION THAT THIS NECESSARILY
ENTAILS, MY COLLEAGUE POINTED
OUT AND I THINK IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT AS PART OF THIS
PILOT, PARTICIPANTS WERE LIMITED
TO 25% OF THE CCDS ASSOCIATE
DEGREE IN NURSING CLASS SIZE.
AND THEN THERE'S AN ALLOWANCE
FOR IMPOVERISHED COMMUNITIES. SO
AGAIN, WITH THE PILOT, WE WILL
SEE IF THIS MAKES A MEANINGFUL
IMPACT, ESPECIALLY ON THAT
QUESTION OF ACCESS AND PLACE
BOUNDEDNESS. AND IF NOT, I THINK
THE LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE TO
TAKE A DIFFERENT APPROACH. BUT
AS WE DO, I THINK WE HAVE TO
LOOK DELIBERATELY AT HOW ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS INTERSECT ACROSS
THE SEGMENTS AND TO THE FIGHT,
AND AS WELL AS TO THE
INDEPENDENCE AND TO, YOU KNOW,
TO YOUR CONSTITUENTS. I YOU
KNOW, I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
IS NOTED, AND THAT IS A
NECESSARY CONVERSATION. SO DO
NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM TO REPORT
A NOTE THAT THREE MEMBERS OF MY
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY CONSTITUTE A
QUORUM ON ANOTHER COMMITTEE THAT
MEETS SIMULTANEOUSLY, WHICH IS
NOT A GOOD IDEA IF YOU ASK ME.
BUT IT'S NOT MY CHOICE. BUT WHEN
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE
A MOTION AND WE'LL MOVE THE
BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. THE
WITNESSES. WHAT'S THAT, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN, I SEE YOU'VE BEEN
WAITING PATIENTLY. WELCOME YOU
WILL BE PRESENTING AB 2193, AND
YOU MAY PROCEED WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE, FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT TODAY ON ASSEMBLY
BILL 2193, DEALING WITH HAZING
ACCOUNTABILITY. I WOULD LIKE TO
START OFF BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
OUR OFFICE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
AND I'M PREPARED TO ACCEPT THEM.
IF IT PLEASES THE CHAIR, I'D
LIKE TO IF I COULD READ INTO THE
RECORD WHAT THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE, PLEASE. YEP LET'S SEE.
SPECIFICALLY, STAFF RECOMMENDS.
AND WE ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT TO
SPECIFY THAT INSTITUTIONS MAY BE
LIABLE ONLY FOR HAZING INCIDENTS
THAT OCCURRED ON OR AFTER THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF THE BILL,
THEREBY PROHIBITING RETROACTIVE
LIABILITY, WHICH WAS, FOR THE
RECORD, ALWAYS OUR INTENTION. SO
I APPRECIATE I APPRECIATE THE
CLARITY. AND THE SECOND IS AN
AMENDMENT TO USE THE DEFINITION
OF HAZING THAT IS CURRENTLY IN
THE BILL RELATIVE TO CIVIL
ACTIONS, WHICH IS ALIGNED WITH
THE EXISTING DEFINITION OF THE
PENAL CODE. THOSE ARE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE STAFF IS
RECOMMENDING, AND WE ARE
ACCEPTING. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE YOU NOTING THIS AT
THE OUTSET. YEP AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA ALREADY
CODIFIED LAWS IN 2006 THAT MAKE
ENGAGING IN HAZING UNLAWFUL.
DESPITE THIS, WE CONTINUE TO SEE
HAZING INCIDENTS OCCUR AROUND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS,
OFTENTIMES PROVING TO BE FATAL.
IT IS CLEAR THAT OUR LAWS ARE
OVERLOOKING A KEY PLAYER WHEN
OUTLINING RESPONSIBLE PARTIES.
THE EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
THEMSELVES. THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR
A CIVIL ACTION TO BE BROUGHT
AGAINST AN EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION THAT KNEW, OR SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN OF THE DANGERS
DANGEROUS HAZING PRACTICES OF AN
AFFILIATE ORGANIZATION.
ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION THAT AN EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION TOOK REASONABLE
STEPS TO ADDRESS HAZING IF THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION HAD
TAKEN SPECIFIED ANTI-HAZING
MEASURES, IT IS TIME TO HOLD ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED RESPONSIBLE FOR
THESE TRAGEDIES AND HOPE THAT WE
CAN COME TOGETHER TO PREVENT
THEM IN THE FUTURE. HERE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2193
ATTORNEY AT LAW CHRISTA RAMEY
AND THE FAMILY MEMBERS WHOSE SON,
TYLER, WAS A VICTIM OF HAZING,
MYEISHA CAMPBELL AND WILLIAM
HILLIARD, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE. THANK YOU, AND WELCOME
TO IT. SO, MISS RAMEY, ARE YOU?
FIRST, WE'LL START WITH THE
CAMPBELL MAIENSCHEIN. WILLIAM.
MRS. CAMPBELL, WELCOME. OKAY
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. OUR SON
TYLER WAS BORN MARCH 26TH, 1998.
HE WOULD HAVE TURNED 26 THIS
YEAR. TYLER LOVED SPENDING TIME
WITH FAMILY AND FRIENDS. HE
LOVED DANCING AND BASEBALL,
WHICH HE STARTED PLAYING AT THE
AGE OF SEVEN. OUR SON HAD A
PASSION FOR LEARNING. WE SENT
OUR SON TO UC RIVERSIDE TO GET
AN EDUCATION, BUT TWO YEARS INTO
HIS COLLEGE EDUCATION, WHO WOULD
HAVE PREDICTED WE WOULD HAVE TO
LAY OUR SON TO REST? ONE OF
TYLER'S GOALS AND ASPIRATIONS
WAS TO BECOME AN ALPHA, BECAUSE
ONE OF HIS ROLE MODELS, DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING, WAS ALSO AN
ALPHA. THE THOUGHT OF LOSING A
CHILD IS JUST HEART WRENCHING.
BUT THE TREATMENT THAT HE
RECEIVED FROM AN ORGANIZATION
THAT HE HELD SO DEAR TO HIS
HEART IS SOMETIMES UNBEARABLE.
WE ARE FORCED TO RELIVE THE
NIGHTMARE OF LOSING TYLER EVERY
TIME WE SEE A YOUNG MAN DANCING,
PLAYING BASEBALL EVERY HOLIDAY
LIKE CHRISTMAS AND THANKSGIVING,
MOTHER'S DAY, FATHER'S DAY, HIS
BIRTHDAY, EVEN LOOKING AT OUR
YOUNGEST SON, IT IS A GUT
WRENCHING PAIN OF A NIGHTMARE
THAT I CANNOT WAKE UP FROM. THE
PAIN IS THAT MUCH MORE
UNBEARABLE BECAUSE THIS COULD
HAVE ALL BEEN PREVENTED AND THIS
BILL WOULD HELP ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THE REGENTS SAY THEY DID NOT
HAVE A DUTY OF CARE TOWARDS MY
SON, BUT THE FRATERNITY WON'T
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY EITHER. WHO
WAS LOOKING OUT FOR OUR CHILDREN?
IMAGINE SITTING AT THE SIDE OF
YOUR CHILD'S HOSPITAL BED WHILE
HE OR SHE IS ATTACHED TO A
VENTILATOR, UNRESPONSIVE,
FEELING HELPLESS, BEGGING GOD TO
SAVE YOUR CHILD AND TO TAKE YOU
INSTEAD BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU
WOULD TRADE PLACES WITHOUT A
SECOND THOUGHT. AND NOW YOU HAVE
TO MAKE THE DECISION TO REMOVE
YOUR CHILD FROM LIFE SUPPORT
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING ELSE
THAT COULD BE DONE. WE BEG YOU
TODAY, IN THE NAME OF TYLER AND
OTHERS BEFORE HIM, TO PASS THIS
BILL SO THAT NO OTHER PARENT HAS
TO EXPERIENCE THE LOSS OF A
CHILD AS A RESULT OF HAZING.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I'M SO
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK YOU,
MISS REMY. HAVE A STRICT POLICY
NEVER TO LET ANYONE CRY ALONE IN
MY PRESENCE. APPARENTLY. YOU'RE.
YOU SHOULD WAIVE THAT TODAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT, GOOD AFTERNOON,
AND THANK YOU. CHAIRMAN NEWMAN.
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
AND MY NAME IS CHRISTA REMY. I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF AB 2193. I AM AN ATTORNEY WHO
REPRESENTS CHILDREN WHO'VE BEEN
THE VICTIMS OF BULLYING, SEX
ABUSE, HAZING. AND I AM THE
PERSON THAT PARENTS CALL WHEN
THE SCHOOLS FAIL. OUR CHILDREN,
CHILDREN HAVE A DUTY. OUR
SCHOOLS RATHER HAVE A DUTY NOT
JUST TO EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN,
BUT TO KEEP THEM SAFE. AND MY
HEART BREAKS WHEN I HEAR STORIES
LIKE THE ONE THAT WAS SUFFERED
BY MYESHA KIMBALL AND WILLIAM
HILLARD. THEIR CASE, THE REGENTS
HAVE SAID THEY DID NOT OWE A
DUTY TO TYLER FOR HIS OFF CAMPUS
ACTIVITIES. WHILE FRATERNITIES
MIGHT EXIST OFF CAMPUS, THEY
RECRUIT THEIR MEMBERS ON CAMPUS,
AND THEY RECEIVE THE BENEFITS OF
HAVING THOSE FRATERNITIES
AFFILIATED WITH THEIR
UNIVERSITIES SCHOOLS. WE BELIEVE
THAT 2193 MADE THE NECESSARY
CHANGES TO THE BILL THAT WAS
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR THAT THE
GOVERNOR VETOED TO ADDRESS THE
GOVERNOR'S CONCERNS. THIS BILL
NOW USES THE MORE COMMON, KNOWN
OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN STANDARD
THAT WE SEE IN ALL GOVERNMENT
ENTITY LIABILITY CLAIMS OR,
ACTIONS. THERE IS ALSO A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION IN THIS
BILL, TO BE CLEAR, THE CÁC HAS
NEVER SUPPORTED A BILL WITH A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION IN IT. WE
HAVE ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT IT'S
BEST TO HAVE THE TRIER OF FACT.
THE JUDGES, JUDGES AND JURIES TO
LOOK AT THOSE ISSUES. HOWEVER,
WE HAVE DECIDED THAT WE WOULD
LOOK AT THESE ISSUES ON A CASE
BY CASE BASIS WHEN THEY COME UP
AND THIS LEGISLATION, AND
PROPOSED LEGISLATION, THIS BILL,
FIT WITHIN WHAT WE THOUGHT WAS
NECESSARY TO LOOK AT AND TO
SUPPORT, BECAUSE IN THIS
INSTANCE, IT ADDRESSES THE
CURRENT INABILITY TO HOLD
UNIVERSITIES ACCOUNTABLE WHEN
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR HARM.
TO BE CLEAR, LAWSUITS ARE AN
EXAMPLE OF THE FREE MARKET
WORKING. THEY HELP MAKE SURE
THAT PRODUCTS AND INSTITUTIONS
ARE SAFER. THE IDEA THAT IF A
LAW WOULD PASS, IT WOULD OPEN
SOME SORT OF FLOODGATES OF
LITIGATION DOES NOT BEAR OUT IN
REALITY, THEY BECOME SAFER. I
HAVE TO ASK YOU TO FINISH UP.
OKAY. THANK YOU. SUBSECTION C OF
THE PROPOSED LEGISLATION
ADDRESSES HOW TO AVOID LIABILITY
FOR UNIVERSITIES. THEY NOW HAVE
WOULD HAVE A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION THAT THEY ARE NOT
NEGLIGENT. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
LAWSUITS ONLY MAKE UP FOR HARM
CAUSED. AND DO NOT UNDO THE
WRONG. BUT WHEN THERE IS A
THREAT OF LITIGATION, CONDUCT
DOES CHANGE. AND THIS WILL HELP
KEEP OUR SCHOOLS SAFER FOR
CHILDREN. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WELCOME,
TIFFANY MOORLACH IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ON BEHALF OF CFT, A
UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS. AND
THANK YOU TO THE WITNESS FOR HER
COURAGE AND TESTIMONY. THANK YOU.
ANNA MATHEWS WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. SORRY FOR THE
WITNESSES LOSS. THANK YOU. TONY
KAMIYA, CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND
MOTHER IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
WELCOME. WE HAVE TWO. WE HAVE TO
FIND YOU A CHAIR. DO YOU WANT.
DO YOU MIND, ALEX? OKAY. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. ERIC BARKER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY BEFORE I BEGIN MY
TESTIMONY, I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR DEEPEST SYMPATHIES.
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
YOUR TESTIMONY FORWARD. I'M A
FATHER OF TWO BOYS, AND I CAN'T
EVEN IMAGINE WHAT YOU'RE GOING
THROUGH. TO BEGIN, I DO WANT TO,
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE AMENDMENTS. WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU'VE SPENT
WORKING WITH US. THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS. WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS LAST
YEAR AS WELL. SO THIS HAS BEEN A
LONG CONVERSATION. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS.
ADDRESSING THE TWO ISSUES IN
TODAY'S COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ARE
IMPORTANT. THEY'RE SIGNIFICANT.
AND I THINK THEY PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY CLARITY AND GUIDANCE
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL.
HOWEVER, WE DO FEEL LIKE
ADDITIONAL CLARITY IS NECESSARY.
WE'VE SHARED OUR PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WITH THE AUTHOR IN
HOPES THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT. AND I'LL JUST
TOUCH ON ONE PARTICULAR EXAMPLE,
SECTION 66308B, REQUIRES THAT AN
INSTITUTION IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE PREVENTION PROGRAM
THAT INCLUDES A RANGE OF
PREVENTION STRATEGIES,
INCLUDING, BUT NOT LIMITED TO,
IN OUR EXPERIENCE, THE COURTS
HAVE SIDED AGAINST INSTITUTIONS
WHEN RANGES ARE REQUIRED WITH
JURIES CITING THAT NOT ENOUGH
WAS DONE TO PREVENT THE INCIDENT,
AS AN EXAMPLE, THE CSU MAY HAVE
INSTITUTED TI¾N PREVENTION
STRATEGIES, BUT THE JURY WOULD
HAVE FOUND THAT 11 WOULD HAVE
BEEN MOST APPROPRIATE. IT'S
DIFFICULT TO GAUGE WHAT OUR
OBLIGATION IS IN THAT SCENARIO.
WE'RE JUST SIMPLY ASKING FOR
CLARITY AND SPECIFICITY ABOUT
WHAT THOSE OBLIGATIONS ARE. WE
ARE COMMITTED TO FOLLOWING
THROUGH WITH THOSE OBLIGATIONS,
BUT WE DO NEED TO HAVE THAT
CLARITY SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE. SO WE WANT TO STILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION, WE SHARED, AS I
SAID EARLIER, WE SHARED THESE
AMENDMENTS WITH THE AUTHOR AND
AS WELL AS SOME OTHER PROVISIONS
THAT WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
DIALOG, AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD. FOR THE TIME BEING, WE
STILL REMAIN IN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. THANK YOU, MR.
GRAVES. GOOD MORNING AGAIN,
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. ALEX GRAVES
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES AND OUR 89
MEMBER INSTITUTIONS. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE FAMILY FOR
SHARING THEIR TESTIMONY
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS. AND
TURNING THAT PAIN INTO ACTION.
ALSO, LIKE MY COLLEAGUE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHORS,
OFFICE AND STAFF FOR THE ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS AND A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THROUGH THIS PROCESS, THERE IS
MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED, THERE
ARE STILL A HANDFUL OF ISSUES
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK
THROUGH. I HAD OUR COUNSEL'S
WORK WITH CSU'S COUNSEL'S TO
PRESENT WHAT WE THINK KIND OF
PROVIDED THOSE ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATIONS THAT WOULD
RESOLVE OUR REMAINING KIND OF
TECHNICAL CONCERNS FOR
IMPLEMENTATION PURPOSES. FOR
EXAMPLE, WE HAVE REQUESTED
CONSISTENT USE OF AFFILIATED
STUDENT ORGANIZATIONS INSTEAD OF
JUST REFERENCING STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS. WE'VE ALSO ASKED
FOR MINOR AMENDMENTS TO SECTION
SIX SIX, 308, SUBSECTION B, WHEN
IT TALKS ABOUT MAINTAINING RULES,
REGULATIONS, AND PROCEDURES
REGARDING HAZING REPORTING, WE
IT TALKS ABOUT UPDATING AND
MAINTAINING. AND FOR EXAMPLE, WE
WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAKE THAT,
MINOR CHANGES TO SAY THAT WE'RE
MAINTAINING THOSE BECAUSE OUR
COUNCILS INTERPRET, WHEN WE'RE
SAYING UPDATE AND MAINTAIN THAT
IT COULD PUT FORWARD THE
ASSUMPTION THAT OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
TO UPDATE POLICIES EVERY YEAR,
EVEN IF THERE'S NO CHANGE IN
BEST PRACTICES OR WHATNOT. THAT
WOULD WARRANT THOSE CHANGES. AND
SO, AGAIN, IT'S IN OUR VIEW,
MINOR THINGS LIKE THAT THAT WE'D
LIKE TO JUST WORK OUT IN THE
REMAINING TIME WE HAVE HERE WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
SUPPORTERS, TO GET US TO A PLACE
WHERE WE ALL FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH, WITH THE GOALS OF THE
BILL, WHICH WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT. AGAIN, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, OUR INSTITUTIONS WANT
TO PREVENT AS MANY INSTANCES OF
HAZING AS POSSIBLE. WE BELIEVE
THAT HAZING ENDANGERS STUDENTS
AND IS DETRIMENTAL TO THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PURSUIT. AND SO I
THINK WE SHARE THE GOALS OF THE
AUTHORS AND SUPPORTERS AND HOPE
THAT WE CAN RESOLVE THESE
REMAINING ISSUES IN THE TIME WE
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU, ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
GOOD MORNING, KYLE HYLAND, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS, IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION, THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, EVERYONE. ON BEHALF OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION DUE TO THE INCLUSION
OF CðC COLLEGES IN THE BILL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE SEEING NONE? LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES,
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS? SENATOR
BORG, SO WITH REGARDS TO THE
TECHNICAL, CLARITY AND
SPECIFICITY OF ACTIONS, ARE YOU
CONSIDERING MOVING FORWARD IN
TRYING TO NARROW WHAT THAT WOULD
LOOK LIKE FOR, FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD? YEAH, I MEAN, WE'RE
ALWAYS AND I THINK WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT WE'RE PREPARED
TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AND FIGURE OUT
HOW, IF AND HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO GET THERE. I'LL JUST, JUST AS
AN EXAMPLE, UPDATING, I THINK WE
HAVE THAT IN THE, IN THE, IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL BECAUSE
THINGS CHANGE. IT'S NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE TO SAY YOU HAVE TO
DO IT EVERY YEAR OR EVERY SIX
MONTHS. IT'S JUST THAT IT'S A
IT'S THERE TO REMIND THOSE WHO
ARE IN POLICY DECISION MAKING
THAT WE NEED TO COME BACK AND
TAKE A LOOK AND SEE IF WE NEED
TO UPDATE. IT DOESN'T. SO MAYBE
WE CAN HAVE SOME CONVERSATIONS
OF HOW TO BETTER DEFINE
UPDATING. BUT I THINK THE IDEA
IS TO RECOGNIZE, AS THIS
INSTITUTION DOES, THAT THINGS
ARE STATIC AND THERE MAY BE,
APPROPRIATELY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COME BACK AND SAY THAT, WOW,
HERE'S A REAL LIFE SITUATION. WE
CAN MAYBE DO A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO MEET THAT. SO YOU WOULD
UPDATE. SO WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND HOW TO
BETTER THREAD THAT NEEDLE IF WE
NEED TO. AND THE REASON I HAVE
CONCERNS, WITH ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE LITERALLY CLARITY ON AND
SPECIFICS AS TO WHAT THE
EXPECTATIONS ARE, FOR AND BY THE
UNIVERSITIES IS THAT ULTIMATELY
OUR COLLEGES ARE HOME TO ADULTS,
YOUNG ADULTS, OR OLDER ADULTS,
DEPENDING ON THE AGE AND SO
FORTH. AND SO, YOU KNOW, AS
PARENTS, YOU KNOW, I HAVE A 24
OR 22 AND, AND AN 18 YEAR OLD
SON, I CAN'T IMAGINE, CANNOT
IMAGINE YOUR LOSS. I CANNOT, AND
YOU HOPE THAT STUDENTS WOULD BE
VERY CAUTIOUS IN WHAT THEY DO.
BUT, YOU KNOW, WHEN IT COMES,
EVEN WITH MY 18 YEAR OLD RIGHT
NOW, IT YOU KNOW, I DON'T HAVE
CONTROL OVER HIS ACTIONS. ONCE
HE LEAVES THE HOME. AND WHAT HE.
YOU KNOW, SOMETIMES I'M GOING,
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING, AND WE
HAVE CONVERSATIONS, BUT
ULTIMATELY, YOU KNOW, IT'S
REALLY TOUGH TO HAVE AN
INSTITUTION IN A COLLEGE. AND
THINK THAT YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
ABSOLUTE CONTROL OVER THE
BEHAVIOR OF YOUNG ADULTS,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE UNDER
THE AGE OF 26. AS WE KNOW, WITH
THE FRONTAL LOBE. SO I DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF WE MOVE
FORWARD OR WHEN WE MOVE FORWARD,
AS WE MOVE FORWARD, THAT WE DO
HAVE SPECIFIC GUIDELINES AS TO
WHAT THE EXPECTATIONS ARE, THE
CLARITY AND THE SPECIFICITY OF
THOSE TECHNICAL, ADJUSTMENTS
THAT WE NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT, YOU KNOW,
UNIVERSITIES. IT'S MY OPINION,
NOT MY OPINION. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT COLLEGES ARE
ALREADY DOING THEIR PART IN
TRAINING EVERY STUDENT AS THEY
ENTER THE GREEK SYSTEM THAT THEY
HAVE TO HAVE TRAINING AS TO WHAT
IS PERMISSIBLE AND NOT
PERMISSIBLE. AND SO, WHAT THE
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES ARE,
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
CLARITY ON THAT END, AND ENSURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
PROTECTED, TO A CERTAIN DEGREE
AGAINST THE ACTIONS OF STUDENTS
WHO MAY NOT BE ACTING WITHIN,
YOU KNOW, WE KNOW WE AS A
SOCIETY, WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL
OVER ANYBODY ELSE'S ACTIONS, BUT
WE HAVE CONSEQUENCES FOR THEIR
OWN PERSONAL ACTIONS. SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THOSE
CLARITIES I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY, BUT I DO RESERVE
THE RIGHT TO CHANGE MY VOTE ONCE
IT COMES BACK TO THE SENATE, OR
WHEN IT COMES TO THE SENATE, OR
WAIT, DOES IT CHANGE? WE DON'T
HAVE TIME TO CHANGE HOW
APPROPRIATIONS GOES TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SO I WILL
RESERVE MY RIGHT TO CHANGE MY
VOTE. ONCE I REVIEW IT WHEN IT
COMES BACK TO THE SENATE. BUT I
DO HOPE THAT THE CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUE, BECAUSE WE DO, WE HOPE
TO HAVE A SYSTEM THAT REALLY
DOES PROTECT OUR STUDENTS
BECAUSE WHEN WE SEND THEM TO
SCHOOL, I HAVE A MY SENIOR RIGHT
NOW IS HEADING TO COLLEGE. I
UNDERSTAND THOSE FEARS, BUT BY
THE SAME TOKEN, THEY'RE YOUNG
ADULTS AND THE SYSTEM. YOU KNOW,
AS LONG AS THEY'RE DOING THEIR
DUE DILIGENCE OF WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE, YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD TO
SAY, HEY, YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
YOUR YOUNG ADULT'S ACTIONS
WITHIN THE SCHOOL. SO THERE'S A
BALANCE THAT WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE. SO, I'LL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY, AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING MORE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE AS WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS. ALL RIGHT. WELL, I
APPRECIATE THAT, SENATOR. AND
LET ME LET ME JUST SAY THAT THIS
IS BEEN A LONG JOURNEY, RIGHT.
THIS IS A TWO YEAR OR MORE
PROCESS OF JUST TRYING TO GET
THIS ACTION MOVING FORWARD, SO
YOU CAN IMAGINE THAT WE'VE DONE
A LOT OF ENGAGING AND REFINING
TO NOW JUST BE DOWN TO
TECHNICAL. SO WE CERTAINLY ARE
NOT GOING TO IGNORE WHAT IS
REASONABLE AND APPROPRIATE TO
TRY TO CONTINUE TO MAKE THE
RIGHT KIND OF STRIDES THAT
STRIKE THE BALANCE. BUT HAZING
HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME. ANY MEMBER OF THIS,
THIS BODY WHO HAS PLEDGED TO A
FRATERNITY OR SORORITY OR EVEN
SOME ATHLETIC, NOT ME. EVEN
THOUGH I PLAYED SPORTS, I WASN'T
CROSSING THOSE KIND OF LINES.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT, MY
CONTEMPORARIES WILL TELL YOU
SOME STORIES AND WHEN THE
INSTITUTION THAT HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY, A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE AFFILIATE, CAN'T JUST
TAKE THAT IN A CASUAL WAY. AND
I'M NOT SAYING THAT THAT IS THE
CASE. BUT WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO
ENFORCEMENT AND LIABILITY AND
WAS WAS SPOKEN OUT THAT IN LIFE
AS A PARENT, WE HAVE TO HAVE A
HAMMER OVER OUR KID'S HEAD IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO LISTEN TO US
AND FOLLOW US. GUIDANCE
DISCIPLINE. AND IN THIS SOCIETY,
SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH
IT THROUGH THE LAW BECAUSE IT'S
CLEAR THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME PARAMETERS THAT CAN BE SET
THAT IN THIS CASE, PROTECT THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO, AS PARENTS,
WERE RELEASING THEM. THIS IS
THAT RELEASE DATE, AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT IF THEY CHOOSE,
WHETHER IT'S BECAUSE A PARENT
JOINED OR A HISTORICAL IDOL THAT
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO BE PUT IN A
SITUATION WHERE THEIR LIFE COULD
BE ON THE LINE. AND SO ALL THAT
TO SAY, YES, WE'LL CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS, BUT WE'VE
COME A LONG WAY AND IT'S BEEN
RESPECTFUL TO THE OPPOSITION'S
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS. SO IT'S
NOT LIKE WE HAVE NOT PAID
ATTENTION TO WHAT THAT
REPRESENTS. AND THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN TAKEN TO THE BILL.
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
TIME AND CONTINUED EFFORT TO
HELP MAKE THE BILL BETTER. GOOD.
ONE MORE QUESTION. PLEASE. GO
AHEAD. SO I'M CURIOUS, IS THERE
I UNDERSTAND YOU SAID IN YOUR
TESTIMONY, MA'AM, THAT THE GREEK
SYSTEM WAS OR THE FRATERNITY
COULD NOT BE HELD LIABLE. I SAID
THAT THEY WERE THEY DON'T WANT
TO HOLD ANY KIND OF
RESPONSIBILITY, BUT AGAIN, IT'S
NOT THE FRATERNITY, IT'S THE
INSTITUTION. IT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. IT'S BOTH THE
INSTITUTION UNDERSTOOD WHERE THE
BILL IS FOCUSING ON THE
INSTITUTION, I APPRECIATE THAT.
SO HAS THERE BEEN ANY. SO MY
QUESTION LIES INTO WHERE WE'RE
HOLDING THE, THE UNIVERSITIES,
WE'RE ADDRESSING THE
UNIVERSITY'S EXPECTATION. IS
THERE ANYTHING IN THE WORKS TO
ADDRESS THE EXPECTATIONS ON THE
GREEK SYSTEM WITH THAT? IS THAT
I'M NOT SURE WHAT. I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK LIKE, BUT
IS THERE ANYTHING IN PLACE THAT
HOLDS THE GREEK SYSTEM IN
ACCOUNTABLE FOR WHAT IS WHAT
HAPPENS IN THERE? I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE CULTURE IS. I'M SORRY.
NO, THAT'S FINE. AND YES, THEY
THEY CAN BE HELD FOR ORDINARY
NEGLIGENCE. AND SO WHEN THEY'RE
AND THEY AND THEY ALL ARE
INSURED AND THEN THE NATIONALS
ARE INSURED, SOMETIMES GETTING
TO THE NATIONAL IS DIFFICULT.
AND MOST OF THE TIME THE
CHAPTERS DO NOT ARE WOEFULLY
UNDERINSURED. TO, BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE KINDS OF
LOSS THAT THEY ARE INFLICTING ON
THEIR MEMBERS. AND, AND WHAT,
YOU KNOW, THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
DO IS TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
PARTY THAT'S RESPONSIBLE IN SOME
MANNER IS HELD ACCOUNTABLE. SO
IT DOESN'T IT LEAVING SOMEONE
OFF THAT VERDICT FORM AT THE END
OF THE DAY MEANS THAT THERE IS
SOMEONE THAT DID SOMETHING
WRONG, THAT WASN'T HELD
RESPONSIBLE. AND WHAT WHAT THIS
IS TRYING TO DO IN THIS
PARTICULAR INSTANCE WITH AB 2193
IS TO LOOK AT YOU KNOW, WHAT DID
THE UNIVERSITY DO THAT WAS A
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR. AND IN
ORDER FOR IT TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT, THERE HAS
TO BE A SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR IN
THE CONNECTION TO WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY DID OR DID NOT DO.
AND THE HARM THAT WAS CAUSED. SO
ASSUMING THAT A PLAINTIFF THAT
HAS LOST SOMEONE GETS PAST THAT
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION, YOU
STILL HAVE TO SHOW THAT CAUSAL
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE ACTION OR
INACTION OF THE UNIVERSITY AND
THE HARM THAT WAS CAUSED TO THE
STUDENT. SO IT'S NOT A STRICT
LIABILITY IF YOU DON'T DO THESE
THINGS. YOU'RE ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE STILL HAS TO BE THAT
CONNECTION. AND LET ME ADD, I
MEAN, THE GOAL HERE, I THINK I
SPEAK FOR THE AUTHOR ISN'T
SIMPLY ACCOUNTABILITY. IT'S
PREVENTION. YES, RIGHT. IT'S
PREVENTION THROUGH THE
IMPOSITION OF A LEVEL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT THAT, YOU
KNOW, INCENTIVIZES THE
INSTITUTION TO EXERT GREATER
CONTROL IN GREEK LIFE AND
PREVENT TRAGEDIES LIKE THE
HILLIARD'S, AND SO ANYTHING
ELSE? WELL, JUST FOR CLARITY, I
UNDERSTAND THE PURPOSE OF THE,
OF THE BILL WITH REGARDS TO THE
SCHOOLS, I WAS JUST GOING TO
CURIOUS AS TO THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF PREVENTION BY THE GREEK
SYSTEM AND WHAT THAT WHAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN PLACE AND WE
DO THROUGH ORDINARY NEGLIGENCE.
WE CAN IF THEY ARE DOING
SOMETHING THAT CAUSES THAT HARM,
THEN THEY CAN THEY ARE AND CAN
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT
HARM. CURRENTLY, UNDER CURRENT
LAW, THERE'S NOTHING PREVENTING,
THERE'S NOT A ROADBLOCK TO
LIABILITY THERE IN TERMS OF
PREVENTION AND HOLDING, AND THAT
LIKE THE POLICY CHANGES THAT
YOU'RE SEEING IN, IN AB 2193 TO
HELP MAKE FRATERNITY SAFER.
THAT'S NOT SPECIFICALLY BEING
ADDRESSED IN THAT BILL, BUT I
THINK OR IN THIS BILL, BUT I
THINK IT ACTUALLY DOES BY WAY OF
HAVING THE UNIVERSITIES DO THESE
THINGS. IF THE SCHOOL IF, YOU
KNOW, IF THE IF THE FRATERNITY,
SORORITY, ATHLETIC, YOU KNOW,
TEAM, WHATEVER IT IS DOESN'T DO
IT, THEN THE SCHOOL HAS, YOU
KNOW, CAN DISAFFILIATE WITH IT.
THE SCHOOL HAS A HAMMER TO IN
ORDER TO PROTECT ITSELF. THEY
CAN YOU KNOW, STEP AWAY FROM IT.
BUT THEY'RE TRYING TO YOU KNOW,
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE THEM
EDUCATED AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
POLICIES ARE THERE AND THAT THE
FRATERNITIES, THE ATHLETIC
INSTITUTIONS, ANY OTHER
AFFILIATED ORGANIZATION IS
FOLLOWING THOSE POLICIES. OKAY.
IS THAT A BETTER I THINK SO
BETTER CLARITY FOR YOU JUST BUT
BUT TO RE-ARTICULATE THIS BILL
IS REALLY ABOUT INSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY. THANK YOU FOR I
THINK THE INSIGHT AS IT RELATES
TO THE INDIVIDUAL FRATERNITIES.
AND LET ME SAY, I MEAN, YOU
KNOW, SO TO THAT POINT, THERE'S
NOBODY IN A FRATERNITY AFTER ONE
OF THESE TRAGIC EVENTS THAT THAT
DOESN'T THINK, WOW, THAT WAS
AWFUL. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS TO CREATE A REGIME THAT
ACTUALLY PREVENTS THESE
TRAGEDIES AND THE KINDS OF LAWS
THAT THE HILLIARDS EXPERIENCED.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THAT. I ALSO
WANT TO SAY THIS WOULD BE THE
LAST TIME I PROBABLY SEE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE, THIS IS LESLIE IN THE
HALLWAY AS WE'RE GOING. THAT'S
WHAT I'M AFRAID OF. THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT I'M AFRAID OF. BUT
BUT I WANT TO COMMEND YOU RIGHT
FIRST FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL. YOU KNOW, NOT JUST TWO
YEARS, BUT MANY YEARS. BUT THIS
YEAR IS ABOUT ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES THAT LED TO THE VETO OF
THE BILL LAST YEAR. AND I
APPRECIATE YOU DOING THAT. AND I
DO HAVE ONE QUESTION, AND I'LL
GET TO IT. BUT BUT THAT SORT OF
PURSUIT OF JUSTICE IS A HALLMARK
OF YOUR LEGISLATIVE CAREER. AND
I COMMEND YOU FOR ESPECIALLY IN
THIS CASE, A QUICK QUESTION TO
MR. BALKI'S POINT ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, SORT OF THE PROBLEMATIC
PROSPECT OF, YOU KNOW, THIS THIS
NOTION OF A RANGE AND A RANGE
NOT BEING SUFFICIENT. SO FOR MR.
RAMEY, YOU KNOW, HOW TO THINK
ABOUT THAT AND IS THAT IS THAT A
SOLVABLE PROBLEM FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE? WELL PRACTICING IN
COURTS EVERY DAY AS A TRIAL
LAWYER, I CAN TELL YOU THAT,
WHEN THERE ARE, INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO PLACED IN THINGS,
THOSE ARE MEANT TO BE EXAMPLES.
THAT'S HOW JUDGES VIEW THEM.
THAT'S HOW JURIES VIEW THEM, AND
YES, THEY COULD SAY, OH, WELL,
YOU COULD HAVE DONE SOMETHING
ELSE. I THINK THAT THAT WOULD
ONLY ARISE IF THAT SOMETHING
ELSE COULD HAVE BEEN THE CAUSE
OF THE HARM THAT WAS THAT, THAT
CAUSED THE HARM TO THE STUDENT.
SO I DON'T I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. AND I YOU KNOW, I
THINK THAT, IN REALITY, IT JUST
DOESN'T IT DOESN'T COME UP THAT
FREQUENTLY IN TERMS OF, OF THAT.
AND, AND WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION,
AS YOU DO HAVE HERE, JUDGES WILL
LOOK AT WHAT THE UNIVERSITY DOES
IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAN A LAY
JURY MEMBER WILL. AND IT I WILL
TELL YOU FROM EXPERIENCE THAT
SUMMARY JUDGMENTS GET GRANTED ON
THOSE REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTIONS
WHEN THERE ARE INCLUDING NOT
LIMITED TO'S. AND I'VE TRIED TO
ARGUE SOMETHING FURTHER THAT THE
SCHOOL COULD HAVE DONE BECAUSE
THE SCHOOL HAS ALREADY DONE SO
MUCH. AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE A
STRICT ADHERENCE AND YOU'RE
DOING ALL OF THE THINGS, IN
REALITY A JUDGE JUST DOESN'T GO
THAT EXTRA WELL, YOU COULD HAVE
DONE THIS MUCH MORE BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY SET
FORTH WHAT THEY EXPECT AND YOU
FOLLOWED IT. AND SO I THINK THAT
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING TO
REINTERPRET OR REWRITE WHAT THIS
BODY HAS ALREADY GONE THROUGH
AND DONE. SO I THAT'S KIND OF MY
REALITY. QUICK RESPONSE I
APPRECIATE THAT. I APPRECIATE
THE ANSWER. I JUST OBVIOUSLY NOT
AN ATTORNEY, BUT TALKING WITH
OUR GENERAL COUNSEL, OUR
EXPERIENCE HAS NOT BEEN
GENERALLY AS SIMPLE AS THAT. WE
HAVE FOUND QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
AND WHICH IS WHY WE'RE ASKING
FOR THE CLARIFICATION, THE
SPECIFICITY. SO WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE DIALOG. I THINK WE ARE
REALLY CLOSE. AND I THINK TO
ASSEMBLYMAN HOLMAN'S EARLIER
POINT, WE HAVE COME A LONG WAY,
AND WE WILL CERTAINLY BE THE
FIRST TO ADMIT THAT. AND SO I
THINK WE'RE REALLY CLOSE. WE
JUST WANT TO PUT SOME OF THE
FINISHING TOUCHES THAT WOULD
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
INSTRUCTIONS FOR THE COURTS IN
THE WE ACTUALLY GET TO THAT
STAGE, AND THAT'S ALL WE'RE
SEEKING. BUT WE DO NOT WANT TO
UNDERMINE ANY OF THE PRIOR
AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
AT THIS POINT. BUT OUR
EXPERIENCE WOULD SUGGEST
OTHERWISE. AND I APPRECIATE
THAT. AND I KNOW THAT. I KNOW
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN IS
ENDEAVORING TO GET THIS BILL IN
A FORM TO THE GOVERNOR THAT
DOESN'T GET VETOED. RIGHT. SO
YOU HAVE SORT OF A NATIONAL
INCENTIVE TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION. I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMITMENT TO DOING THAT, LET ME
JUST SAY, YOU KNOW, IN SORT OF
BEFORE I ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE,
THERE'S NOTHING MORE TRAGIC THAN
THESE DEATHS PRECISELY BECAUSE
THEY ARE SO PREVENTABLE. THEY
SHOULD NEVER HAPPEN. AND SO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE, I THINK, IS
REALLY IMPORTANT, TO INCREASE
THE CHANCES THAT INSTITUTIONS
WILL EXERCISE THAT CONTROL,
WHICH CONVEYS TO FRATERNITIES
AND THE YOUNG PEOPLE WITHIN THEM
THE COMMON SENSE NOT TO DO THESE
THINGS RIGHT. AND IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO SORT OF ALIGN
EVERYBODY'S INTERESTS TO DO
THAT, KNOWING THAT THAT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A PROBLEM. AND I
THINK THIS IS A GOOD AND USEFUL
STEP TOWARD HOPEFULLY SOLVING
THIS PROBLEM. AND I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. IF YOU'D LIKE
TO CLOSE, I THANK ALL OF YOU
HAVE MADE MY CLOTHES FOR ME. I
JUST LIKE TO THANK THE FAMILY
BECAUSE DOING THIS ONCE IS HARD.
DOING IT 5 OR 6 TIMES. THAT WAS
ASKING A LOT FOR YOU, SO I
APOLOGIZE THAT IT HAS TAKEN US
TO THIS POINT, TO GET YOU CLOSER
AND OTHER FAMILIES WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED WHAT YOU HAVE HAD TO
EXPERIENCE, TO START TO SEE THE
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
AND, MR. CHAIRMAN, I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US, AND I APPRECIATE THE
UNIVERSITIES AND THE SYSTEM
COMING FORWARD. AND BEING
WILLING TO MOVE OFF OF WHAT WAS
A POINT, A TOUGH PLACE FOR THEM
TO MOVE FROM. AND SO WHAT I SEE
AS A PROCESS WORKING, I WILL
NEVER LET THE PERFECT BE THE
ENEMY OF THE GOOD. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T COMPROMISE IN
GETTING WHAT WE'RE DESIGNED TO
DO IS BE ADVOCATES FOR THOSE WHO
NEED THEM TO MAKE SYSTEMS THAT
SOMETIMES ARE VERY
DYSFUNCTIONAL, WORK MORE
FAVORABLY FOR THOSE WHO ARE
VICTIMS. FOR THAT DYSFUNCTION.
SO AGAIN, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. AND SO
AGAIN, IN THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE UP, A MOTION
AND VOTE ON THE BILL. I HAVE
EVERY ASSURANCE YOU WILL GET
SEVEN VOTES ON THIS. SO THANK
YOU. AND TO THE HILLIARDS AGAIN,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COURAGE. NEXT
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN. SINCERELY, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. OH, NO. IS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SORRY YOU WERE
BLOCKED BY THE LARGE FORM OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. HOLDEN. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONNER IS, IN
THE CHAIR, SO, IT'LL BE FAST.
WELCOME, AND AGAIN, OUT OF
ORDER, BUT I'M SURE IT'LL ALL
WORK OUT. AB 2381, PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AND
THANK YOU. TODAY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 2381, WHICH WOULD
ALLOW OUR STATE'S PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE TO BE
FUNDED BASED ON ENROLLMENT
RATHER THAN ATTENDANCE. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM PROVIDES EDUCATIONAL
EXPERIENCES TO LOW INCOME,
DISADVANTAGED CHILDREN, AGES 3
TO 5 DURING THE COVID PANDEMIC.
THESE PROGRAMS WERE REIMBURSED
BASED ON ENROLLMENT RATHER THAN
ATTENDANCE, USING A FORMULA THAT
ENSURED THAT THEY HAD THE
ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES. HOWEVER, THIS
PROVISION IS SET TO EXPIRE ON
JUNE 30TH, 2025. UNFORTUNATELY,
PAYMENTS BASED ON ATTENDANCE ARE
UNPREDICTABLE. IF PROVIDERS ARE
UNABLE TO ANTICIPATE WHICH
CHILDREN WILL BE PRESENT ON ANY
GIVEN DAY, THEY CANNOT
ANTICIPATE HOW MANY STAFF THEY
WILL NEED. THIS CAN LEAD TO
COSTS THAT EXCEED THE STATE'S
REIMBURSEMENT AMOUNT. CONTINUED
FUNDING BASED ON ENROLLMENT WILL
PROVIDE OUR STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS WITH A STABLE FUNDING
SOURCE, ENABLING THEM TO FOCUS
MORE ON THE SUSTAINABILITY AND
QUALITY OF THEIR PROGRAMS. NOW
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO VIRGINIA
EARLEY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION, AND
AMANDA DICKEY FROM THE SANTA
CLARA OFFICE OF EDUCATION, TO
SPEAK MORE ON THIS SUBJECT. MR.
EARLEY, WELCOME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, HAPPY TO BE WITH YOU ALL,
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND, A
PROUD SPONSOR OF 28, 30, 23, 81.
MY NAME IS VIRGINIA EARLEY, AND
I'M A POLICY ADMINISTRATOR AT
THE EARLY EDUCATION DIVISION AT
CDE. SO AS THE AS THE MEMBER
MENTIONED, SINCE APRIL 2020,
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS HAVE BENEFITED FROM A
COVID ERA POLICY THAT FUNDS
PROGRAMS AT THE LESSER OF THEIR
COSTS OR THEIR CONTRACT AMOUNT,
REGARDLESS OF THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN ATTENDING OR ENROLLED.
WHEN THESE PROTECTIONS EXPIRE ON
JULY FIRST, 2025, PROGRAMS WILL
GO BACK TO BEING FUNDED ON
ATTENDANCE A FEW MONTHS LATER IN
FALL 2025, WE'LL REACH IN A
REALLY EXCITING MILESTONE IN THE
UNIVERSAL PRE-KINDERGARTEN
EXPANSION. THE FIRST YEAR OF
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN, WHICH PRESENTS A
HISTORIC OPPORTUNITY FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL TO SERVE MORE THREE
YEAR OLD CHILDREN FROM FAMILIES
WHO NEED IT MOST. AND WE KNOW WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO THERE. IN
2023, CALIFORNIA WAS SERVING 13%
OF THE NEARLY 300,003 YEAR OLDS
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PROGRAM. AB
2831 WILL STRENGTHEN SORRY, 2381
WILL STRENGTHEN THE EARLY
EDUCATION SYSTEM BY ALLOWING
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS TO
BETTER UTILIZE THEIR EXISTING
CONTRACT FUNDS WITHOUT
INCREASING COSTS IN A WAY THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES THEIR FIXED COSTS
FOR SERVING ALL CHILDREN
ENROLLED ALIGNS WITH FEDERAL
HEAD START AND THE PRIVATE PAY
MARKET, AND PROVIDES AN
IMPORTANT PROTECTION FOR
CONTRACTORS AS THEY RECOVER FROM
THE PANDEMIC'S IMPACTS ON
ATTENDANCE AND REEXAMINE A
BUSINESS MODEL THAT HAS
HISTORICALLY RELIED HEAVILY ON
FOUR YEAR OLDS WHILE THEY
TRANSITION TO SERVING MORE A
THREE YEAR OLDS. THE BILL IS
ALSO IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE
AUGUST 2022 RATE AND QUALITY
WORKGROUP RECOMMENDATIONS,
REFLECTING THE CRITICAL NEED TO
STABILIZE PROGRAMS BY
ACKNOWLEDGING FIXED COSTS AND
ADDRESSING THE TRUE COST OF
CARE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU, MISS DICKEY. WELCOME. THANK
YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS AMANDA
DICKEY, AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
FOR THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. WE ARE VERY
PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR THIS BILL
AND WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER AND SUPERINTENDENT
THURMOND FOR MOVING FORWARD THIS
IMPORTANT, COST NEUTRAL
LEGISLATION, WHICH WOULD DO SO
MUCH TO HELP THE PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS WHO SPEND EIGHT OR
MORE HOURS A DAY CARING FOR OUR
CHILDREN, BUT ARE LIVING ON THE
MARGINS, BARELY MAKING ENDS
MEET. AS YOU MAY KNOW, 40% OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS RECEIVE
FOOD ASSISTANCE FROM CALFRESH
AND ABOUT A THIRD LIVE UNDER THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE, AS ONE OF
THE LARGEST EARLY LEARNING
PROVIDERS IN OUR REGION, THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HAS THE BENEFIT OF AN
ECONOMY OF SCALE, WHICH HELPS TO
INSULATE OUR PROGRAMS FROM
UNFORESEEN CONTINGENCIES. BUT
EVEN WE OPERATE IN THE RED SOME
YEARS DUE TO UNPREDICTABLE
ATTENDANCE RATES, DROP OUTS AND
FAMILY EMERGENCIES. ALTHOUGH OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SCALE PUT US
IN THE BEST POSSIBLE POSITION AS
A PROVIDER, THERE IS NOT MUCH
THAT WE CAN DO TO MITIGATE LOST
ATTENDANCE REVENUES, AND THE
COST TO OPERATE A PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM IS LARGELY STATIC, SO
THERE'S RENT, SALARIES AND
OVERHEAD COSTS LIKE ELECTRICITY,
GARBAGE, WATER, SEWAGE,
JANITORIAL SERVICES. AND THOSE
CHANGE WHETHER OR NOT STUDENTS
SHOW UP FOR THE PROGRAM, IF THE
STATE HADN'T PROVIDED A HOLD
HARMLESS REIMBURSEMENT DURING
THE PANDEMIC, OUR PROGRAMS WOULD
HAVE OPERATED AT SUCH A DEFICIT
THAT THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION MAY HAVE BEEN FORCED
TO TERMINATE OUR CONTRACTS,
WHICH WOULD HAVE EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATED 4000 HIGH QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING SLOTS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY, AB 2381 WILL HELP
CREATE GREATER FISCAL STABILITY
FOR PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS, WHICH
MEANS MORE HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING OPTIONS AND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES. THANK YOU, AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MALIK BIDEN
WITH UAW LOCAL 3930 ON BEHALF OF
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS, UNITED CPU
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MISS GIBBS. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, PAMELA GIBBS,
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR, AND SENATORS. ROSANNA
CARVACHO ELLIOTT HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CONSORTIUM, ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, ASHLEY LUGO, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS AND SUPPORT,
THANK YOU. MELISSA MORENO,
TRUSTEE OF YOLO COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION, IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
ANY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE,
COME BACK TO THE DAIS. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS, MEMBERS. GREAT. BILL
AND I WILL SUPPORT IT WHENEVER
WE GET A QUORUM. I SEE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE. SO I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT IT AS WELL. AND
NOT ONLY I THINK IS THIS USEFUL,
BUT IT GETS AT ONE OF THE
UNINTENTIONAL CONSEQUENCES OF
EXPANDING UNIVERSAL PRE-K, AND
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT IF WE'RE
SERIOUS ABOUT ENSURING THAT WE
DON'T CROWD OUT FUNDING FOR
PRESCHOOL. SO THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL. GLAD TO SUPPORT IT AS
WELL. WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM AND
WHEN WE CAN TAKE A MOTION, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST QUICKLY?
I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
CHAIR, ABOUT THE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MITIGATING CONCERNS OR
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
WE'VE CREATED WITH UNIVERSAL
PRE-K. AND THIS BILL CERTAINLY
DOES THAT BY ENSURING THAT WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
SOME STABILITY FOR OUR PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU TO
THE WITNESSES. WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND I DARE SAY PASS THIS
BILL WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM, LET
US NOW MOVE ON TO MR. WALLACE. I
AM SO SORRY NOT TO HAVE SEEN YOU.
AND YOU'LL BE PRESENTING AB
2277. AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY, SIR. WELL, GOOD MORNING,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
2277, SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA PART TIME FACULTY
ASSOCIATION, WHO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AB 2277
RAISES THE CAP THAT PART TIME
FACULTY ARE ALLOWED TO TEACH
FROM 67% TO 85% OF A FULL TIME
FACULTY ASSIGNMENT PER TERM. I'M
PROUD TO SAY THIS BILL IS ALSO
SUPPORTED BY THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES, WHOSE
MEMBERS ARE FULL TIME FACULTY.
THIS BILL WILL INCREASE THE
MAXIMUM NUMBER OF INSTRUCTIONAL
HOURS BY TWO UNITS THAT A PART
TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY
MEMBER MAY TEACH AT ANY ONE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT,
ALLOWING FACULTY TO BETTER
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
DISTRICT AND BETTER SUPPORT
THEIR STUDENTS. AB 2277 STILL
REQUIRES AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND THEIR PART TIME
FACULTY. WE HAVE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL TO AVOID INADVERTENTLY
CONVERTING PART TIME FACULTY TO
FULL TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SERVE A CRITICAL ROLE IN
EDUCATING CALIFORNIANS, AND AB
2277 PROVIDES A TOOL TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS. I HAVE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT, JOHN MARTIN,
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA PART
TIME FACULTY ASSOCIATION. MR.
MARTIN, WELCOME. YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU, GOOD MORNING, AND THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TO YOU
TODAY. MY NAME IS JOHN MARTIN. I
TEACH AT I TEACH AT TWO
DIFFERENT RURAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT, BUTTE COLLEGE
AND SHASTA COLLEGE, COLLECTIVELY
FOR OVER 25 YEARS. I'M ALSO
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA PART
TIME FACULTY ASSOCIATION, OR
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CPFA. WE ARE
A LEADER FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE
FACULTY WHO TEACH ACROSS THE
STATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM,
WHICH IS THE LARGEST IN THE
WORLD. AB 2277 IS AN ATTEMPT TO
BRING INCREMENTAL STEPS TO
IMPROVE THE LIVELIHOOD FOR PART
TIME FACULTY AND QUALITY OF
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS. IF
PASSED, PART TIME FACULTY MAY
HAVE A CHANCE TO TEACH UP TO
8,085% OF THE FULL TIME LOAD.
BECAUSE THIS IS NOT A MANDATE,
EACH DISTRICT WILL RETAIN THE
RIGHT OF ASSIGNMENT AND PART
TIME FACULTY WILL RETAIN THEIR
RIGHT OF REFUSAL. FIRST REFUSAL.
THIS IS TRUE WHEN AB 591 PASSED
IN 2008, AND WHEN THE CAP WAS
RAISED TO 67, WHICH IS THE
CURRENT LAW. THIS BILL REQUIRED
DISTRICTS AND THE EXCLUSIVE
BARGAINING UNIT TO NEGOTIATE HOW
DETERMINE HOW THIS WOULD WORK.
AND THIS BILL WILL STILL
MAINTAIN ITS LOCAL CONTROL,
WHICH IS THE FOUNDATION FOR
EVERY DISTRICT. I KNOW THE
OPPOSITION IS CONCERNED THAT
INCREASING THE CAP TO 8,085%
WOULD NEGATIVELY IMPACT
DIVERSITY. IT IS UP TO THE
DISTRICT TO CREATE A DIVERSE
FACULTY TO MEET THEIR COMMUNITY
STANDARDS, AND THIS BILL WILL
NOT HAMPER THEIR EFFORTS TO BE
MORE INCLUSIVE IN THEIR HIRING
OF NEW EMPLOYEES. DISTRICTS ARE
EMPOWERED TO HIRE WHO THEY WANT,
AND THEY SHOULD NOT BLAME ANY
NEW CAPS. THIS BILL WILL OFFER
MORE SECTION FOR STUDENTS TO BE
TAUGHT BY EXISTING PART TIME
FACULTY, SO THE DISTRICT WILL
NOT HAVE TO GO OUT TO ADVERTISE,
RECRUIT, HIRE, EVALUATE NEW
FACULTY, NEW PART TIME FACULTY
BY KEEPING THE EXISTING FACULTY
TO ALLOW THE FLEXIBILITY AND
MAINTAIN THEIR LOCAL CONTROL.
BOTH FULL TIME AND PART TIME
FACULTY ARE CRITICAL TO
INCREASING THE AND CREATING AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT FOSTERS
STUDENTS SUCCESS, INCREASING THE
MODEST WORKLOAD. FOR PART TIME
PROFESSORS WILL HELP ENSURE
STUDENTS WILL HAVE A BETTER
ACCESS TO THEIR PROFESSORS AND
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR PART
TIME FACULTY. IT IS A WIN WIN
PROPOSITION FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHER SUPPORT, MISS
MARK, WELCOME. THANK YOU.
TIFFANY. MARK, IN, ON BEHALF OF
CFT, A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU
ANNA MATTHEWS, ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES,
REPRESENTING BOTH FULL TIME AND
PART TIME FACULTY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? GOOD MORNING, ANDREW
MARTINEZ, COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO
THANK, THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR FOR MEETING WITH ME,
JOHN MARTIN, FOR MEETING WITH ME
TO DISCUSS THE BILL AND THE
INTENT OF IT, REGRETFULLY, WE
MUST BE OPPOSED. WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACT ON
LOCAL CONTROL. WE REALIZE THAT,
IT IS REQUIRES US TO NEGOTIATE
IT. BUT IT WILL PUT PRESSURE ON
OUR BOARDS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
NEGOTIATE UP TO 85. AND THAT IS
A SIGNIFICANT CONCERN FOR US, WE
ALSO WANTED TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FACT THAT
THERE IS A LANGUAGE ON THERE
CAPPING IT TO 30 HOURS, BUT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF THERE COULD
BE SOME AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THAT IT INCLUDES OFFICE HOURS AS
WELL, BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT SOME
OF THE CONTRACTS THAT ARE
CRAFTED INCLUDE OFFICE HOURS,
SOME DON'T. AND SO HAVING THAT
CLARITY WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATIVE TO US AS WE MOVE
FORWARD, LOOKING FORWARD TO
HAVING ENGAGING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE SPONSOR IN THE COMING
MONTH. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
NEXT, PLEASE. HI. KYLE HYLAND,
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS, I'D LIKE TO
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE LEAGUE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO AB
2277. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE,
WE'LL COME BACK TO THE DAIS. OH,
SORRY. I'M NOT GIVING YOU NEARLY
ENOUGH TIME. SORRY. IT'S OKAY.
KASHA HUNT WITH NOSSAMAN ON
BEHALF OF CITRUS COLLEGE AND
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE, ARE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, SEEING NO ONE ELSE.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE, SENATOR
CHOBO, WELCOME, MEMBER WALLACE,
SO WITH REGARDS TO THE CONCERNS,
I THINK IT'S I ACTUALLY AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE BILL AS I'M
READING THE LANGUAGE, I THINK
IT'S A GREAT IDEA, ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A COST OF LIVING, ISSUES
HERE IN THE STATE. AND ANYTHING
WE CAN DO TO HELP, OUR
PROFESSORS BE ABLE TO, EXTEND
THOSE HOURS, MAKE A LITTLE MORE
MONEY, ESPECIALLY AS PART TIME
WITH AN OPTION, I THINK IS
COMMENDABLE. SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD. I
DO HAVE A QUESTION. QUESTION
WITH REGARDS TO THE OPPOSITION,
WITH REGARDS TO CLARITY IN,
OFFICE HOURS IS WHAT I HEARD.
ONE OF THE, ONE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THEY HAD ARE YOU STILL
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION IN ORDER TO KIND
OF MITIGATE THOSE CONCERNS?
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM ON
THAT, AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
TO SOMETHING THAT'S ACCEPTABLE
THERE. OKAY. I'LL BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THOSE
CLARIFICATIONS, YOU KNOW, WHERE
THEY MAY BE HOPEFULLY, FINDING
THAT COMPROMISE WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND HOPEFULLY GAINING
THEIR SUPPORT. SO THANK YOU,
SENATOR. OKAY. FOR MY PART, GLAD
TO SUPPORT THE BILL. BUT, YOU
KNOW, WITH RESPECT TO OFFICE
HOURS, IN SYMPATHY WITH PART
TIME INSTRUCTORS, WE OFTEN,
WHICH IS TO SAY THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES LET YOU DO THAT FOR
FREE. AND WE SHOULD NOT. AND
ISN'T THAT ISN'T THAT PARKING
DON'T SOME SOME DO, SOME DON'T.
BUT MANY PART TIME INSTRUCTORS,
BECAUSE OF THEIR COMMITMENT TO
THEIR STUDENTS, ACTUALLY WIND UP
DOING IT ON THEIR OWN TIME,
WHICH I THINK IS REGRETTABLE. SO
I'M FROM MY PART. GLAD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL. WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM, SO LET US ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WHAT? I'M SORRY. AND
THEN YOU CAN CLOSE. OKAY. NEWMAN
HERE. NEWMAN HERE. OKOBOJI HERE.
OKOBOJI HERE. CORTEZ. CORTEZ
HERE. GLAZIER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. PRESENT.
WILK PRESENT. ALL RIGHT, A
QUORUM HAVING NOW BEEN
ESTABLISHED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST, AND I
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. LOOKING FOR A
MOTION. SO MOVED. MOVED BY
SENATOR WILK. MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLE FILE ITEM
NINE AB 2277. WALLACE. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN I OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ CORTEZ I. GLAESER.
GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK
I WILK I. THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES. FOUR VOTES. AND WE'LL
HOLD IT OPEN. THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU, MR.
MARTIN. ALL RIGHT. MOVING ON.
WITH A QUORUM IN PLACE, I SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHIAVO. I THINK
YOUR COLLEAGUE IS GOING TO GRANT
YOU THAT COURTESY. WELCOME, MR.
CHAIR. WELL, SHE'S COMING UP.
CAN WE DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR?
I DON'T SEE WHY NOT. SHADOW
CHAIR. LET US NOW CALL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WHITE SHADOW
CHAIR ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
NEWMAN I NEWMAN I OKOBOJI
CONSENT I OCHOA I CORTEZ. CORTEZ
I GLAZER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK. HI WILK I. ALL
RIGHT. CONSENT CALENDAR HAS FOUR
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS, AND NOW WE WILL
TAKE UP, MEASURE AB 2999 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO.
WELCOME. HOMEWORK. THANK YOU.
HOMEWORK YES, SO THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, VERY HAPPY
TO PRESENT AB 2999 TODAY, WHICH
I'M HOPING IS REALLY GOING TO
START WHAT COULD BE A GREATLY
IMPACTFUL CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOMEWORK AND ITS IMPACTS ON
STUDENTS, AND REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENTS.
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THEM ALL. THE AB
20, 99 2999, THE HEALTHY
HOMEWORK ACT IS REALLY BROUGHT
FORWARD WITH THE INTENTION OF
STARTING THIS NEW CONVERSATION
AROUND HOMEWORK. THE BILL WAS
ACTUALLY SPURRED BY MY DAUGHTER,
SOPHIA, WHO'S HERE TO TESTIFY
TODAY, WHEN I STARTED RUNNING
FOR OFFICE, SHE WAS IN THE BACK
SEAT OF THE CAR AFTER I PICKED
HER UP FROM SCHOOL, AND SHE WAS
ASKING, WHAT WOULD I BE ABLE TO
DO IF I GOT ELECTED? AND I SAID,
WELL, I GET TO MAKE LAWS. AND
SHE SAID, OH, CAN YOU BAN
HOMEWORK? AND, YOU KNOW, EVERY
FOURTH GRADERS DREAM, PROBABLY.
BUT WHILE THIS BILL DEFINITELY
DOES NOT BAN HOMEWORK, I THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, IT STARTED ME
THINKING AND IT WAS NOT THE
FIRST TIME THAT I STARTED
THINKING ABOUT HOMEWORK WHEN SHE
WAS IN KINDERGARTEN. I WAS
REALLY SHOCKED TO HAVE HER COME
HOME ON MONDAYS WITH A REALLY
THICK PACKET OF HOMEWORK. THAT
WAS DUE ON FRIDAYS, AND MY FIRST
JOB OUT OF COLLEGE WAS ACTUALLY
WORKING IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION FOR A TRIBAL HEAD
START PROGRAM, AND AT THAT TIME
I LEARNED A LOT ABOUT EARLY
CHILDHOOD BRAIN DEVELOPMENT AND
HOW PLAY AND FREE TIME IS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT PART OF CHILD'S
DEVELOPMENT, AS YOU'LL HEAR FROM
DOCTOR POPE, WHO'S A PROFESSOR
AT STANFORD, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF RESEARCH THAT SHOWS
THAT IT'S ACTUALLY BENEFICIAL TO
HAVE HOMEWORK OR IMPACTS
STUDENTS GRADES, ESPECIALLY IN
LOWER GRADES, SO, YOU KNOW, THIS
REALLY SPARKED KIND OF A
RESEARCH ON MY PART, LOOKING AT
OTHER COUNTRIES AND WHAT THEY
WERE DOING. AND, AND REALLY
THINKING ABOUT HOW COULD WE DO
THINGS DIFFERENTLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THEN AS SHE, YOU
KNOW, PROGRESSED THROUGH THE
YEARS AND GRADE LEVELS AND AS A
SINGLE MOM, A WORKING MOM WITH A
VERY DEMANDING JOB, ALL THE
TIME, I'VE HAD TONS OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH PARENTS ABOUT
THE STRUGGLES AND STRESS THAT
THIS PUTS ON PARENTS. I THINK
EVERYONE HAS A STORY ABOUT NEW
MATH AND HAS EXPERIENCED THAT.
IF YOU HAVE KIDS AND, YOU KNOW,
AND WHEN KIDS ARE COMING HOME
WITH THINGS THAT THEY'RE
CONFUSED BY, WE KNOW THAT THE
IN-PERSON INSTRUCTION IN CLASSES
IS REALLY WHAT MAKES SUCH A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF STUDENT
LEARNING. YOU KNOW, MY
EXPERIENCE IN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION REALLY LED ME TO DO MY
OWN RESEARCH AND FIND DOCTOR
POPE AND ACTUALLY TALK TO AS
MANY TEACHERS AS I POSSIBLY
COULD, I WANTED TO DO THIS BILL
LAST YEAR, BUT I KNEW THAT IT
WAS GOING TO TAKE TIME. AND A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS. AND SO
OVER THE PAST YEAR AND A HALF,
EVERY TEACHER I'VE TALKED TO,
EVERY, EDUCATOR, UNION AND
ORGANIZATION THAT WE COULD MEET
WITH, WE TALKED TO AND HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS. AND I'VE BEEN
REALLY HARD PRESSED TO FIND
PEOPLE WHO LOVE HOMEWORK, WHO
WORK IN EDUCATION, AND IT
SURPRISED ME. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I FOUND IN TALKING
TO TEACHERS IS THAT THEY'RE NOT
ACTUALLY TAUGHT ABOUT HOMEWORK
IN THEIR CERTIFICATE PROGRAMS,
IN THEIR TEACHING CERTIFICATE
PROGRAMS. THIS IS IT SEEMS LIKE
IT'S ACTUALLY KIND OF AN
AFTERTHOUGHT. SO YOU KNOW WHAT A
LOT OF TIMES HAPPENS IS TEACHERS
WILL ADOPT WHATEVER THEIR MENTOR
IS DOING, WHATEVER THEY
EXPERIENCED GROWING UP, WHATEVER,
YOU KNOW, THEY IS ASSIGNED IN
THE END OF THE TEACHING MANUAL
THAT THEY'RE READING AND IT
SAYS, ASSIGN THIS HOMEWORK. AND
SO YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S TIME
THAT WE REALLY GET INTENTIONAL
ABOUT HOMEWORK. WE LOOK AT THE
CURRENT RESEARCH ON HOMEWORK. WE
LOOK AT THE IMPACTS TO MENTAL
HEALTH. WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. WE
KNOW THAT HOMEWORK IS ONE OF THE
TOP STRESSORS IN KIDS LIVES.
THIS IS A WAY THAT WE COULD
OVERNIGHT REDUCE STRESS IN KIDS
LIVES AND IMPACT THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH IN A POSITIVE WAY. AND WE
ARE DOING SO MUCH WORK AS A
STATE TO SEND MONEY AND SET UP
PROGRAMS AND TRAIN THERAPISTS
AND DO ALL OF THESE THINGS. AND
THIS IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
BIGGEST STRESSORS IN KIDS LIVES
THAT WE CAN EASILY IMPACT, AND
SO, YOU KNOW, THIS BILL SIMPLY
ASKS FOR SCHOOL BOARDS TO
DEVELOP A POLICY, SO IT
PRESERVES LOCAL CONTROL, IT
PRESERVES LOCAL INPUT. IT
REQUIRES INPUT FROM PARENTS,
FROM TEACHERS AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHERS, AS WELL FROM
SCHOOL COUNSELORS AND
THERAPISTS, FROM STUDENTS WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING THIS ALL THE
TIME AND REALLY MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE FINDING HOMEWORK POLICIES
THAT MAKE SENSE, THAT TRULY
IMPACT EDUCATION IN A POSITIVE
WAY AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
KIDS EDUCATION AND ARE NOT UNDUE
BURDENS AND EXTRA STRESS AND,
YOU KNOW, AND I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO HAVE
CONNECTION RIGHT NOW WITH OUR
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. AND, YOU
KNOW, MY DAUGHTER COMES HOME,
SHE GOES INTO HER ROOM AND
CLOSES THE DOOR AND IS DOING
HOMEWORK ALL NIGHT. A LOT OF
TIMES WE DON'T EVEN HAVE FAMILY
MEAL TIMES TOGETHER ANYMORE.
BECAUSE OF HER STRESS AROUND
HOMEWORK. AND SHE DOESN'T WANT
TO, YOU KNOW, SHE DOESN'T WANT
TO MISS IT, AND SHE NEEDS TO GET
TO BED AT A REASONABLE TIME.
IT'S IMPACTING KIDS SLEEP
BECAUSE THEY'RE STAYING UP. I,
I'VE BEEN TALKING TO SIXTH AND
SEVENTH GRADERS WHO ARE UP UNTIL
MIDNIGHT DOING HOMEWORK, SO, YOU
KNOW, I FEEL LIKE WE REALLY NEED
TO TAKE A MINUTE TO DO A
REEVALUATION OF HOW WE'RE DOING
HOMEWORK, HOW IT'S REALLY
IMPACTING PEOPLE, AND IS IT
REALLY HELPING, AND SO THAT'S
WHAT AB 2999 REALLY INTENDS TO
DO, AND WOULD LOVE TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY DAUGHTER TO TESTIFY,
SOPHIA. AND ALSO DOCTOR POPE.
HELLO, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MY
NAME IS SOPHIA AND I JUST
FINISHED SIXTH GRADE. I'M HERE
TO SUPPORT OUR HEALTHY HOMEWORK
ACT AB 2999. I HOPE IT MEANS
THAT SCHOOL BOARDS WILL REALLY
LOOK AT THE IMPACT HOMEWORK IS
HAVING ON THE ON STUDENTS LIKE
ME AND MY FRIENDS. I LOVE TO
READ AND LEARN, BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO HOMEWORK, I ABSOLUTELY
DREAD IT. IT CAUSES SO MUCH
STRESS AND WORRY AND IT TAKES UP
ALL OF MY TIME AFTER SCHOOL. I
DON'T HAVE TIME TO HAVE DINNER
WITH MY MOM AND FAMILY, TO PLAY
WITH MY LITTLE COUSIN, OR JUST
HAVE TIME TO RELAX AND RECOVER
FROM THE STRESS OF THE DAY. I
DON'T HAVE TIME. I HAVE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS FOUR DAYS A
WEEK. THAT MEANS I DON'T GET
HOME UNTIL AROUND 6 P.M. OR
LATER. MOST DAYS AS A SIXTH
GRADER, I USUALLY HAVE ABOUT 1.5
HOURS OF HOMEWORK OR MORE EACH
NIGHT. I OFTEN EAT DINNER WHILE
I DO HOMEWORK IN MY ROOM ALONE.
I HARDLY HAVE ANY TIME TO
CONNECT WITH FRIENDS BECAUSE I
HAVE TOO MUCH HOMEWORK AND NEED
TO SHOWER OR GET READY FOR BED
AS SOON AS I'M DONE. HOMEWORK
CAUSES A LOT OF STRESS IN MY
LIFE. I'VE HAD A LOT OF NIGHTS
WHERE I END UP CRYING BECAUSE I
JUST CAN'T FINISH THE HOMEWORK
BEFORE BEDTIME, AND I'M SCARED
THAT I WILL BE KEPT IN FROM
RECESS, GET IN TROUBLE OR IT'LL
HURT MY GRADES. I DON'T WANT MY
TEACHER TO BE DISAPPOINTED IN
ME, SO SOMETIMES I JUST STAY UP
VERY LATE SO THAT I CAN FINISH.
AND IT'S NOT JUST ME I'VE HEARD
THIS FROM ALL OF MY FRIENDS,
EVEN THE SMARTEST KID IN MY
CLASS. HOMEWORK IS EXHAUSTING.
IT'S OVERWHELMING, AND IT'S
DEPRESSING, THAT MY WHOLE THAT
MY WHOLE DAY FROM WHEN I WAKE UP
UNTIL WHEN I GO TO BED EARLY IS
NEARLY ALL TAKEN UP WITH
SCHOOLWORK, WITH ALMOST ALL OF
MY TIME SCHEDULED FOR ME. IT'S
MAKING ME NOT LIKE SCHOOL AT
ALL. I KNOW THE WORK WE DO IN
SCHOOL IS IMPORTANT, BUT I THINK
THAT THAT SUPPORT THAT. BUT I
THINK THAT THINGS THAT SUPPORT
MENTAL AND PHYSICAL HEALTH, LIKE
CONNECTING WITH FRIENDS, HAVING
DOWNTIME TO RECHARGE, AND TIME
TO DO THE THINGS THAT MAKE ME
HAPPY, LIKE ART AND LEARNING.
LANGUAGES ARE ALSO REALLY
IMPORTANT, AND THAT SHOULD BE
ALSO CONSIDERED. THAT'S WHY I
ASKED YOU TO SUPPORT OUR HEALTHY
HOMEWORK ACT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND WELL PRESENTED. DOCTOR
POPE, THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR DENISE POPE.
I'M A SENIOR LECTURER AT THE
STANFORD GRADUATE SCHOOL OF
EDUCATION AND CO-FOUNDER OF
CHALLENGE SUCCESS, A NONPROFIT
THAT PARTNERS WITH K-12 SCHOOLS
NATIONWIDE TO IMPROVE STUDENT
WELL-BEING. ENGAGING ENGAGEMENT
AND BELONGING. I'M PLEASED TO BE
HERE TODAY TO SHARE INSIGHTS
FROM DATA COLLECTED THROUGH THE
CHALLENGE SUCCESS STANFORD
SURVEY OF SCHOOL EXPERIENCES,
WHICH HAS BEEN COMPLETED BY OVER
300,000 MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BRING STUDENT
VOICES INTO CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
POLICIES THAT AFFECT THEIR
WELL-BEING. THANK YOU. SOPHIA
AND TODAY'S DATA REFLECTS THE
VOICES OF MORE THAN 13,000
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
DURING THE 2223 SCHOOL YEAR.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT MAJOR SOURCES
OF STRESS IN THEIR LIVES, 45% OF
STUDENTS REPORTED OVERALL
WORKLOAD AND HOMEWORK AS A TOP
SOURCE OF STRESS. THIS WAS
SELECTED OVER SEVERAL OTHER
STRESSORS, INCLUDING FUTURE
PLANS, COLLEGE, AND
RELATIONSHIPS. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY CHAMPIONED STUDENT
WELL-BEING BY RECOGNIZING THE
NEED FOR STUDENTS TO GET MORE
SLEEP, AND WE COMMEND THE RECENT
IMPLEMENTATION OF A LATER SCHOOL
START TIME. NOW, WE ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THE REST OF THE
STUDENT'S DAY IN OUR SAMPLE.
AFTER STUDENTS SPEND 7 TO 8
HOURS AT SCHOOL, THEN COMPLETE
AN AVERAGE OF TWO TO 2.5 HOURS
OF HOMEWORK, PLUS
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES, PAID
WORK, AND FAMILY COMMITMENTS.
THERE'S SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH HOURS
IN THE DAY FOR TEENS TO GET THE
NINE HOURS OF SLEEP THEY NEED
PER NIGHT, AND YOUNGER STUDENTS
NEED EVEN MORE UP TO TEN HOURS.
IN FACT, 57% OF STUDENTS
REPORTED THAT HOMEWORK OFTEN ARE
ALWAYS PREVENTED THEM FROM
GETTING ENOUGH SLEEP. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT MORE THAN HALF OF
STUDENTS SURVEYED REPORTED THAT
HOMEWORK HAS PREVENTED THEM FROM
HAVING TIME FOR FAMILY, FRIENDS,
AND OTHER IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES.
WE KNOW FROM EXTENSIVE RESEARCH
THAT PLAYTIME, DOWNTIME, AND
FAMILY TIME ARE CONSIDERED
PROTECTIVE FACTORS AND ARE
FUNDAMENTAL TO HEALTHY CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT DEVELOPMENT.
IMPORTANTLY, REVIEWS OF RESEARCH
ON HOMEWORK AT THE YOUNGER GRADE
LEVELS SHOW ALMOST NO
CORRELATION BETWEEN TIME SPENT
ON HOMEWORK AND ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT. WITH THE NOTABLE
EXCEPTION OF READING FOR
PLEASURE. FINALLY, WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INHERENT
INEQUITIES PRESENTED BY
HOMEWORK. WE KNOW THAT AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL, 1 IN 5 STUDENTS
DO NOT HAVE ADEQUATE TECHNOLOGY,
RESOURCES OR SUPPORT AT HOME TO
COMPLETE THE HOMEWORK THEY'VE
BEEN ASSIGNED. THE HEALTHY
HOMEWORK BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
EDUCATORS USE EVIDENCE BASED
HOMEWORK PRACTICES FOR
CONSISTENCY, CLARITY, AND
EQUITY. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE WELL-BEING OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND THE
CRITICAL NEED FOR SLEEP, PLAY,
AND FAMILY TIME. AS YOU REVIEW
THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. I'M SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO THIS
BILL? ALSO SEEING NONE. LET'S
COME BACK TO THE DAIS BEFORE WE
START TO SOPHIA AGAIN. WELL
DONE. BUT GOOD NEWS. WE PASSED A
BILL. IT WAS MY BILL LAST YEAR
ABOUT RECESS THAT PROHIBITS THE
DENIAL OF RECESS FOR ANYTHING
OTHER THAN MAJOR DISCIPLINARY
REASONS. SO IF ANY TEACHER TRIES
TO DENY YOUR RECESS, SEND THEM
MY WAY. I DID SEE THAT BILL.
ACTUALLY OKAY, GOOD TO HEAR.
WELL, YOU'RE WAITING FOR THAT.
YOU ARE FOLLOWING LEGISLATION
BETTER THAN MY COLLEAGUES. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GOOD WORK.
CAN YOU NAME NAMES? WE WILL NOT.
WE WILL NOT. WE WILL NOT NAME
NAMES, QUESTION OR COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES. SENATOR. SENATOR
WILK. SORRY, SORRY, SORRY. COME
ON. IT'S A SHADOW CHAIR. OKAY.
YEAH, GREAT. BILL, I THINK I
THINK IT'S LONG OVERDUE.
FANTASTIC TESTIMONY. AND I'M SO
GLAD THAT YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU
WANT TO HAVE TIME FOR YOUR ART
BECAUSE YOU ARE A FANTASTIC
ARTIST. SO IMPRESSED WITH ALL
THE WORK I'VE SEEN FROM YOU. I
JUST REMEMBER MY SON WASN'T
YOUNG. HE WAS, JUNIOR JUNIOR IN
HIGH SCHOOL, AP HISTORY AND HE'S
UP LIKE EVERY NIGHT TILL ONE AND
I FINALLY GO, WHAT'S GOING ON?
HE SAID. AND IT'S ALL WROTE
STUFF THAT IT'S JUST WASTING THE
KIDS TIME. AND I SAID, WE'RE
GOING TO GET YOU OUT OF THAT
CLASS. I WANT YOU TO BE A KID.
AND HE'S DONE. HE JUST BOUGHT A
HOUSE I CAN'T AFFORD, SO I DON'T
THINK NOT DOING ENOUGH HOMEWORK,
HASN'T HASN'T HURT HIM. AND I
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR MENTIONING
THE LATE SCHOOL START, THAT IS
LAW. BECAUSE I WAS THE DECIDING
VOTE GETTING OUT OF SENATE, AND
IT WAS A PORTANTINO BILL. AND I
THINK THAT SAVED LIVES. SO THIS
IS JUST JUST A KUMBAYA MOMENT.
SO HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL. AND
IT'S GOING TO BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY. OBVIOUSLY WE APPRECIATE
THAT. SENATOR CHUBBUCK. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR THIS, BILL. I
THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT, YOU
KNOW, INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH, MY
CHILDREN STARTED WITH
MONTESSORI. AND IN MONTESSORI,
WE DON'T HAVE HOMEWORK. AS A
MATTER OF FACT, THE FIRST THING
THAT MY KIDS ASK FOR WHEN THEY
DID, ENTRANCE WAS LIKE, THEY
WANTED HOMEWORK. AND I THOUGHT,
WAIT. AND NOW? AND THEN
AFTERWARDS, THE MIND, THE
MINDSET CHANGED. BUT MONTESSORI
DOES NOT HAVE HOMEWORK. THEY DO
HAVE ALL THE WORK INSIDE THE
CLASSROOM DURING THE DAY, BUT
IT'S A DIFFERENT FORMAT. IT'S A
DIFFERENT, DIFFERENT, JUST
DIFFERENT FORMAT OF, OF
IMPLEMENTING EDUCATIONAL
PRACTICES. BUT I ALSO, I WISH IT
HAD BEEN DONE SOONER, ONLY
BECAUSE I HAVE AN 18 YEAR OLD
THAT JUST GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL, AND HE WOULD DO
INCREDIBLY WELL IN EVERYTHING
EXCEPT FOR THE HOMEWORK. JUST
FOR HIM, IT WAS JUST A HARD
THING FOR TO DO. SO I UNDERSTAND
THAT MANY, MANY KIDS JUST. I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS. MAYBE THE
FOR WHAT VARIETY OF FACTORS.
IT'S VERY HARD FOR A LOT OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE INCREDIBLY
BRILLIANT, BUT JUST WHEN THEY
CAN DO EVERYTHING IN THE
CLASSROOM, BUT AS SOON AS THEY
GO OUTSIDE AND OR. YEAH, OUTSIDE
OF THE CLASSROOM, OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL HOMEWORK BECOMES A HUGE
IMPEDIMENT FOR THEIR CONTINUED
WELL-BEING. SO, THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY, CHRIS.
AND, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
BILL. I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY ANY
OTHER COMMENTS? SEEING NONE, I'M
GLAD TO SUPPORT IT, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YEAH THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS. I THINK EVERY
PARENT HAS SEEN THEIR KIDS
REALLY STRUGGLE WITH THIS. AND
IT'S NOT ONLY IMPACTED THE
STUDENTS IMPACTS THE WHOLE
FAMILY, YOU KNOW, WE ONE OF THE
THINGS WHEN I FIRST SPOKE WITH
DOCTOR POPE THAT REALLY WAS
IMPACTFUL TO ME IS THAT STUDENTS
ARE THE ONLY ONES WE ASKED TO DO
THREE SHIFTS. YOU KNOW, THEY GO
TO SCHOOL ALL DAY. MANY OF THEM
GO TO AFTER SCHOOL OR AFTER
SCHOOL ACTIVITIES, AND THEN THEY
COME HOME AND THEY HAVE TO SIT
DOWN AND DO HOMEWORK ALL NIGHT,
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THE REST OF US
APPRECIATE I MEAN, WE DON'T HAVE
EIGHT HOUR DAYS, BUT IF WE DID,
IT'D BE NICE. BUT WE'VE
CERTAINLY FOUGHT FOR THAT FOR
WORKERS. WE'VE FOUGHT FOR
WEEKENDS OFF, AND STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE THOSE WEEKENDS OFF OR, OR,
EIGHT HOUR DAYS, SO THIS IS A
WAY FOR US TO GET BACK TO SOME
KIND OF BALANCE. I THINK FOR
THEM, WE'RE REALLY HAPPY TO HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA SUPPORT
GENERATION UP AND CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES, AMONG
OTHERS, SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOT A
MOTION FROM SENATOR WILK, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON ITEM 19, AB 2999 SHIAVO
MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ
I. GLAZIER. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK I. WILK I. THAT
BILL CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES.
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU, MISS JOHNSON.
WELL DONE. THANK YOU, DOCTOR
POPE, MOVING ON. I SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ WAITING
PATIENTLY. YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING AB 2586, YOU AND YOUR
WITNESS CAN GET SET, AND YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY. WITNESSES.
PLURAL. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2586. THE,
ENERGY YOU FEEL, BY WAY OF SOME
OF THE NOISE IN THE OUTSIDE
HALLS. YOU'LL GET TO HEAR A LOT
OF TESTIMONY IN ADDITION TO THE
WITNESSES IS A LOT OF EMOTION
FOR A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
HERE ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL. I
FEEL THE SAME SENSE OF
EXCITEMENT AND EMOTION ABOUT
BEING IN OUR, ALMOST TO THE END
OF THIS PROCESS, THIS
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO INTRODUCE
A LAW IN CALIFORNIA THAT WILL BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL FOR A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO, ARE LOOKING
FOR HOPE, ARE TRYING TO FIND
HOPE IN CALIFORNIA. AND I HOPE
WE OFFER THAT, THIS BILL IS
INSPIRED BY MY PERSONAL STORY AS
A SON OF IMMIGRANT PARENTS WHO
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY
UNDOCUMENTED TO FIND THE BETTER
OPPORTUNITIES, THAT AMERICAN
DREAM THAT HAS MADE OUR COUNTRY
SUCH A WONDERFUL PLACE FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE THE FAMILY, MY
FAMILY AND MY SIBLINGS CERTAINLY
WERE THE FIRST DREAMERS THAT I
KNEW IN MY CHILDHOOD WHEN I WAS
GROWING UP. I KNOW THE STRUGGLES
THAT MANY MIXED STATUS FAMILIES
AND NON-CITIZENS GO THROUGH.
IT'S NOT EASY. EVEN WHEN YOU ARE
WORKING AS HARD AS YOU CAN TO
GIVE IT ALL. CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT, THOUGH, TO HIGHER
EDUCATION MEANS INVESTING IN
ACCESS, AFFORDABILITY, EQUITY,
SUCCESS FOR ALL STUDENTS AND WE
HAVE DONE A LOT OF THAT WORK,
AND YOU HAVE DONE A LOT OF THAT
WORK. YET THOUSANDS FACE UNJUST
BARRIERS, UNABLE TO SECURE ON
CAMPUS JOBS DUE TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS, WHICH
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTS THEIR
ABILITY TO MAKE PAYMENTS TOWARDS
THEIR TUITION, SUPPLIES, HOUSING
AND OTHER BASIC NEEDS THAT
STUDENTS HAVE. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
CONGRESS, TIME AFTER TIME, HAS
FAILED OUR IMMIGRANTS AND HAS
FAILED OUR DREAMERS, OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR. CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO ABOUT 83,000
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS, JUST
STUDENTS. HOWEVER, THE NUMBER OF
DACA ELIGIBLE STUDENTS ON
CAMPUSES HAS CONSISTENTLY
DECREASED AS COURT RESTRICTIONS
ON ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA HAVE
NARROWED THE ACCESS TO THAT
PROTECTION OF THAT PROGRAM TO
YOUNG PEOPLE. THAT IS WHY THE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT LED
NETWORKS BRAVERY TO FIGHT. THIS
CHANGE HAS INSPIRED ME TO BE
BEFORE YOU TODAY, AND YOU WILL
HEAR FROM LEADERS FROM THAT
STUDENT LED MOVEMENT. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2586 IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL BILL, WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
EQUAL ACCESS TO CAMPUS
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
STUDENTS WHILE THEY'RE EARNING
THEIR DEGREES, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS. ON THE
CAMPUSES OF THE UC, THE CSU AND
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS. THE BILL ALLOWS
STUDENTS TO BE IN THE APPLICANT
POOL AND LEVELS THE PLAYING
FIELD FOR EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE ACCESS TO EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ON CAMPUS.
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO AUTHORIZE THE
HIRING OF UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
AND GRADUATES. LEGAL EXPERTS AT
THE CENTER FOR IMMIGRATION LAW
POLICY AT UCLA SCHOOL OF LAW
HAVE IDENTIFIED THAT THE FEDERAL
PROHIBITION ON HIRING
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY
DOES NOT INCLUDE STATE ENTITIES,
SUCH AS THE UC, THE CSU, OR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES. A
SYSTEM AN ARGUMENT THAT IS
SUPPORTED BY DOZENS OF THE
NATION'S LEADING LEGAL SCHOLARS.
AND I'M SURE YOU'VE SEEN THAT
LEGAL, SCHOLAR SCHOLARLY WORK IN
YOUR BACKUP, BECAUSE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE ARMS OF
THE STATE, THEY FACE NO LEGAL
RESTRICTION IN HIRING
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS,
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ARE
REALLY CONTINUE TO BE THE
BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
HOWEVER, THEY OFTEN ARE FACED
WITHOUT HAVING ACCESS TO THE
BENEFITS THAT OTHERS HAVE. THE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN VETTED BY
OUR ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS ARE
SOME OF THE BEST AND BRIGHTEST
IN OUR STATE. THESE ARE THE
STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN PROMISED
THAT IF THEY WORK HARD ENOUGH AS
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING ALL THEIR
LIFE, THAT THEY WILL HAVE A
FUTURE IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE
INVESTED IN THEM AND NOW WE NEED
TO ALLOW THEM TO HAVE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. THESE STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD TO ENTER
OUR COLLEGES. CALIFORNIA HAS
INVESTED IN THEM AND NOW IS THE
TIME FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
REMOVING THESE BARRIERS OF
EMPLOYMENT IN CALIFORNIA NOT
ONLY ENSURES EQUAL OPPORTUNITY,
BUT ALSO STRENGTHENS OUR
ECONOMY. IT IS TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO EMPOWER
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TO
CONTRIBUTE AND TO THRIVE THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE WORKING HARD TO DO
SO. WITH THAT, THERE ARE NO
BETTER WITNESSES TO SPEAK TO
THIS, BUT TWO STUDENTS WHO ARE
AT OUR INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
LEARNING TO PROVIDE THEIR
TESTIMONY, YOU WILL NOT HEAR
FROM OUR THIRD WITNESS, BUT HE'S
AVAILABLE HERE FOR QUESTIONS,
KENT WONG, DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERSHIPS AT THE UCLA LABOR
CENTER, CAN HELP ANSWER SOME
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, BUT FIRST,
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO VANESSA
CRUZ GRANADOS. WELCOME. HI. GOOD
MORNING. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME. MY NAME
IS VANESSA CRUZ. I'M AN
UNDOCUMENTED DACA STUDENT GOING
INTO HER SENIOR YEAR AT UC
IRVINE. I'M CURRENTLY PURSUING
MY BACHELORS OF SCIENCE IN
PSYCHOLOGY, AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PASSING OF BILL AB
2586, KNOWN AS OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL, ON JULY 15TH. IT WILL BE 18
YEARS SINCE I'VE CALLED
CALIFORNIA HOME, SPECIFICALLY
SAN BERNARDINO. AND I JUST
TURNED 21 THREE DAYS AGO AS A
YOUNG UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN, WE
ARE TOLD THAT HARD WORK IS
ENOUGH TO OVERCOME ANY BARRIER.
AND AT SEVEN YEARS OLD, I KNEW I
WAS UNDOCUMENTED, BUT I SAW MY
FATHER WORKING HARD, AND HE SAID
THAT THIS COUNTRY, THE STATE,
WAS THE LAND OF OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN I WAS 14, DACA WAS IN
COURT. BUT WE HAD CALIFORNIA,
AND CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS HAD
OUR BACKS. SO I WASN'T SCARED.
WHEN I WAS 20. UC PRESIDENT
DRAKE TOLD ME AND THREE OTHER
STUDENTS THAT THEY WERE
PREPARING TO, TO IMPLEMENT A
PLAN TO REMOVE HIRING
RESTRICTIONS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS. BUT HE LIED TO US. AND
FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER,
CALIFORNIA FAILED US. NEXT YEAR,
I WON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY FOR
HOUSING OR FOR FOOD, AND I'LL
HAVE TO LOOK AT ALTERNATIVE
METHODS. AS SOMEONE WHO HAS
EXPERIMENTED WITH PROGRAMS LIKE
COLLEGE CORPSE, IT IS NOT
ENOUGH. I'VE DONE IT FOR TWO
YEARS AND I'VE VOLUNTEERED OVER
900 PLUS HOURS. AND IT JUST IT
COMES WITH FINANCIAL BARRIERS
AND LIMITED CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES. THE UNFORTUNATE
TRUTH IS THAT STUDENTS LIKE,
LIKE I, WHO CANNOT RELY ON OUR
PARENTS FOR SUPPORT, WILL FIND
OTHER WAYS OF WORK. WE WILL BE
EXPLOITED, WE WILL BE
OVERWORKED, AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE HIDDEN IN THE SHADOWS.
WE'RE NOT BEING ASKED TO BE
TREATED DIFFERENTLY. WE ONLY
WANT THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AS
OUR PEERS. WE WANT SOMETHING
THAT IS RECOGNIZED AS A HUMAN
RIGHT UNDER INTERNATIONAL LAW,
SOMETHING ALL HUMANS HAVE AT
BIRTH. I NEED EQUAL ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT I CAN
SAFELY CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
SCHOOLS, FAMILIES, AND
COMMUNITIES. TODAY, YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE THAT AND
STAND ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY BY ALLOWING ME AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHER STUDENTS TO
PURSUE OUR EDUCATIONAL AND
CAREER ASPIRATIONS UNHINDERED BY
OUR IMMIGRATION STATUS, THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW ME TO FINISH UP
MY SENIOR YEAR, AND I NEED A
SENATE EDUCATION TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
WELCOME SIR. HELLO. GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. TWO MINUTES.
HI. MY NAME IS DAVID. I'M A
STUDENT AT FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE,
AND I'M HERE TO SHARE MY
TESTIMONY IN HOPES THAT THE AB
2586 BILL SHALL PASS. I'M AN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT WITHOUT
DACA, AND I HAVE BEEN GOING TO
SCHOOL SINCE I WAS FIVE. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M CURRENTLY
PURSUING A BA IN STUDIO ART, AND
I WOULD LIKE TO BE A TEACHER
SOMEDAY. EVER SINCE I WAS A
LITTLE KID, I ALWAYS WANTED TO
BE SOMEBODY. MY PARENTS WERE
PROUD OF AND STARTING COLLEGE.
STARTING A COLLEGE EDUCATION
WOULD HELP ME, WOULD HELP THAT
DREAM BECOME A REALITY. I
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL IN 2017
AND ENROLLED MYSELF IN COLLEGE.
THAT SAME YEAR. AFTER MY FIRST
SEMESTER, I CAME TO REALIZE THAT
I DID NOT HAVE THE SAME
FINANCIAL RESOURCES, FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE MY
EDUCATION DUE TO MY UNDOCUMENTED
STATUS, I DID NOT HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES AS MY PEERS TO GET
EMPLOYED ON CAMPUS, AND AS A
RESULT, I HAD TO DROP OUT OF
COLLEGE. THAT SAME YEAR. IN
2021, I APPLIED FOR DACA ONLY TO
BE LED DOWN BECAUSE A FEDERAL
JUDGE HAD COME TO PAUSE ANY NEW
APPLICATIONS PROCESS. THIS SENSE
OF REJECTION HINDERED MY
ASPIRATIONS TO GO BACK TO
COLLEGE. NEVERTHELESS, AFTER
FOUR YEARS OF NOT BEING IN
SCHOOL, I CAME TO THE
DETERMINATION THAT I WAS GOING
TO CONTINUE COLLEGE NO MATTER
THE OBSTACLES THAT I WOULD FACE.
AS I CAME BACK TO COLLEGE, I
ALSO CAME BACK TO THE REALITY
THAT I AM STILL NOT ABLE TO WORK
OR GET ANY PAID INTERNSHIPS
SIMPLY BECAUSE OF MY IMMIGRATION
STATUS. THIS HAD LED MANY DOORS
OF OPPORTUNITIES TO BE CLOSE TO
ME, MY BROTHER, AND THOUSANDS OF
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I WILL BE
TURNING 26 THIS YEAR, AND I
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT THAT BY NOW,
ALL STUDENTS, REGARDLESS OF
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS, WOULD
HAVE HAD THE RIGHT TO EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT WITHIN THE SAME
SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT HAS
ENCOURAGED US SINCE WE WERE
LITTLE TO EARN AN EDUCATION AND
FOLLOW OUR DREAMS. I HOPE
EVERYONE HERE TODAY UNDERSTANDS
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL, AND
I URGE ALL MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
OF EDUCATION, SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE AB 2586
BILL. PASSING THIS BILL IS
CRUCIAL TO PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS
TO EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES TO
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS. IT WILL
ALLOW US TO EXPAND OUR SKILLS,
SHARE OUR UNIQUE IDEAS AND LEARN
FROM EACH OTHER, ENSURING
CALIFORNIA REMAINS A LAND OF
OPPORTUNITIES. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND CONTRIBUTING
TO CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE. STATE YOUR NAME,
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL, PLEASE,
CAROLINE NGUYEN, ON BEHALF OF
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION, WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. HI. GOOD MORNING,
CAROL GONZALEZ. ON BEHALF OF
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE,
CALIFORNIA STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION, AND ON BEHALF OF MY
FRIENDS WHO COULDN'T BE HERE,
GOT US IN THE CENTRAL AMERICAN
RESOURCE CENTER. AND YOU ASPIRE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING, FAITH LEE,
WITH ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE. SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
WE'RE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING.
KIMBERLY SANCHEZ WITH ACTION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING,
CHRIS MYERS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. MARSHALL
NAKATANI WITH UAW 4811,
REPRESENTING 48,000 ACADEMIC
WORKERS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI
THERE, RYAN ENRIQUEZ, I'M A
MASTER OF PUBLIC POLICY STUDENT
AT UC BERKELEY'S GOLDMAN SCHOOL
OF PUBLIC POLICY, AND I SERVE AS
PRESIDENT FOR THE UC GRADUATE
AND PROFESSIONAL COUNCIL,
ADVOCATING FOR OVER 60,000
STUDENTS IN THE UC SYSTEM. WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND
GOOD TO SEE YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
ALMA LOZADA, WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING,
CARMEN NICOLE COX, ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING, JEFFREY MUNOZ. I'M
A RECENT GRADUATE OF UCLA AND
INCOMING UNDOCUMENTED GRADUATE
STUDENT AT CAL STATE, LA FROM
SAN BERNARDINO, CALIFORNIA, IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI. I'M
CARLY AMAYA RIOS. I'M A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT UCLA STUDYING PUBLIC
POLICY, UNDOCUMENTED WITHOUT
WITHOUT DACA. AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT BECAUSE IT CHANGED MY
LIFE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS JASMINE. I'M AN
UNDERGRADUATE AT UC IRVINE. I'M
WITH THE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
NETWORK AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT BECAUSE THIS BILL WOULD
GREATLY IMPACT ME. AND FOR THE
BETTER, AND YEAH, I'M
UNDOCUMENTED. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HI. MY NAME IS NELSON
GUARDADO. I'M A STUDENT AT UC
IRVINE AND AN ALLY TO
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS. I CARE
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
HI, I'M YESENIA JIMENEZ WITH
GRACE AND CHILD POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA, ALSO A FORMER UAW 20
865 MEMBER AND A DAUGHTER OF TWO
UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS, ONE OF
WHOM WAS DEPORTED FOR WORKING
WHILE UNDOCUMENTED. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. MY NAME IS FATIMA
ZEFERINO, UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
AT CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
LONG BEACH. I HOPE TO BECOME A
LAWYER ONE DAY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS TANYA
FIGUEROA IN THE COMMUNITY UNIONS
AT CAL STATE LONG BEACH. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL CHANGE MY LIFE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HELLO, I'M ANNA, I STUDY
MATH AND LIBRARY STUDIES. I'M
DOCUMENTED. I GO TO UCLA AND I
AM HUNGRY FOR FOOD AND JUSTICE.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS LORENA CARRANZA. I'M AN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT AND ALSO
SERVING AS A SENATOR FOR THE
COLLEGE OF SCIENCE AND
MATHEMATICS AT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY, NORTHRIDGE. AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB 2586. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD MORNING,
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT CAL
STATE LONG BEACH, CURRENTLY
PURSUING MY TEACHING
CREDENTIALS. SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS THIS BILL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING. DOLORES HUERTA DE
LA HUERTA FOUNDATION FOR
COMMUNITY EMPOWERMENT AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MISS FORTE. GOOD TO
SEE YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO. MY
NAME IS LEO RODRIGUEZ. I AM A
ALUMNI OF UC BERKELEY AND
OUTGOING PRESIDENT OF UC
BERKELEY IDEAS, AS WELL AS A
MEMBER OF THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY COUNCIL UNDER UC
BERKELEY DIVISION OF DIVERSITY
AND EQUITY. HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI. MY
NAME IS DIANA ORTIZ AND I'M
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT WITHOUT
DACA AT RECENT UC BERKELEY
GRADUATE. AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. HI
I'M ESMERALDA MARTINEZ. I'M A
RISING SENIOR AT UC BERKELEY
STUDYING POLITICAL SCIENCE AND
DATA SCIENCE. AND I'M IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HI. MY NAME IS ERIC
CAMPOS GONZALEZ. I'M
UNDOCUMENTED. I'M A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT UCLA PURSUING MY
MASTER'S IN SOCIAL WORK, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. HI. MY
NAME IS LEONELA DE LA CRUZ, 60
ALUMNI. I'M UNDOCUMENTED, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO,
I AM JACOB OAKTON. I AM A
STUDENT AT UC MERCED AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. HELLO.
MY NAME IS SYLVIA RODRIGUEZ, A
UC DAVIS STUDENT AND
UNDOCUMENTED. I AM A STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT. HI, MY NAME IS ABRAHAM.
I'VE BEEN AN UNDOCUMENTED
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT UCLA. I
WANT TO CONTINUE MY EDUCATION
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
HELLO. MY NAME IS JANETH. I'M A
RECENT GRADUATE FROM UC MERCED.
STUDY COGNITIVE SCIENCE AND I'M
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL NOT
ONLY FOR MYSELF BUT MY YOUNGER
SIBLINGS WHO ARE ALSO
UNDOCUMENTED. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HI, MY NAME
IS VIRIDIANA. I'M AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT UC
MERCED STUDYING COMPUTER SCIENCE
AND ENGINEERING. I MYSELF AM
UNDOCUMENTED, SO I'M
REPRESENTING AND OCCUPIED THE
UNITED WAY DREAM ACTION AND
UNITED WE DREAM NETWORK. THANK
YOU. AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
HELLO, MY NAME IS YAEL. I ATTEND
AMHERST COLLEGE AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND SO WOULD
MY FRIENDS WHO ARE ALSO
UNDOCUMENTED IN MERCED COLLEGE.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING, DOCTOR CALVIN MUNRO,
DEAN OF STUDENT SERVICES
REPRESENTING LOS RIOS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT, STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO. MY NAME IS
ANGELICA PEREZ MARTINEZ FROM
FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO.
MY NAME IS JAIME VEGA AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. HELLO.
MY NAME IS ALBINSKI EL. I'M FROM
FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE AND I
SUPPORT. YEAH. THANK YOU. NEXT.
HELLO, MY NAME IS JAMES LAY. I'M
A STUDENT SUPPORT ANALYST
ASSISTANT AT FOLSOM LAKE
COLLEGE, AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. HI, I'M MELISSA
CAPDEVILLA, AND I WORK WITH
FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE, AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. I
WORK FOR FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. HELLO. MY NAME IS
THEO KNEE FROM FOLSOM LAKE
COLLEGE, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
THERESA SOETOMO, AND I HAVE THE
HONOR OF SERVING AS FOLSOM LAKE
COLLEGE'S DIRECTOR OF NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENT SUPPORT AND
SUCCESS PROGRAM. AND ON BEHALF
OF OUR PROGRAM, WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. EVA
JIMENEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO,
GUADALUPE MENDEZ, I WORK FOR THE
UNDOCU FALCON'S CENTER AT FOLSOM
LAKE COLLEGE AND IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT. HELLO ELI
SMITH, LGBTQ PLUS PROGRAM
COORDINATOR AT FOLSOM LAKE
COLLEGE, AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
HI, EVERYONE. MY NAME IS ODETTE
AVENDANO. I AM A PROSPECTIVE
GRAD STUDENT AT UCLA. I'M
GETTING A MASTER'S IN PUBLIC
POLICY AND I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
BELLA KERN, ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE, JANINE
COHEN, I'M A GRADUATE STUDENT
AND A CITIZEN. AND, I LIVE IN
BERKELEY, CALIFORNIA OF
CALIFORNIA. OH MY GOD. SORRY.
NERVOUS, I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
THANK YOU. MARK MCDONALD, ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHWESTERN AND
RANCHO SANTIAGO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. KASHA HUNT WITH NOSSAMAN
HERE ON BEHALF OF CITRUS COLLEGE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. CANDACE YOUNGBLOOD,
BERKELEY HIGH TEACHER AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. ANN WOLF, I'M A
COLLEGE EDUCATOR, I HAVE TAUGHT
AT CAL STATE EAST BAY AND UC
DAVIS, I'M ALSO A UC BERKELEY
ALUM, AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. CHRIS TAYLOR, BERKELEY
HIGH TEACHER, STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. TIFFANY
MOCK, PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR THE
BILL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING STEVEN. FILLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORTING THIS. THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT PLEASE JESSICA WITH FOLSOM
LAKE COLLEGE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
KARLA HERNANDEZ WITH FOLSOM LAKE
COLLEGE AND STRONGLY SUPPORT AS
WELL. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
HELLO. MY NAME IS VIOLETA
MURILLO. I'M A SECOND YEAR
GRADUATE STUDENT AT CAL STATE LA
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, NEXT, PLEASE.
SORRY, I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY
TIFFANY MOCK ON BEHALF OF CFT
SUPPORT. I APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION. NEXT, PLEASE.
HELLO EVA. A MOTHER OF TWO
STUDENTS IN BERKELEY. I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK YOU. AND
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND SEEING
NONE. LET'S NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION. WELCOME AND YOU CAN
COME TO THE TABLE. SURE AND WE
WILL MAKE SPACE. CAN WE GET
ANOTHER CHAIR? NO. IT'S OKAY.
YOU'RE OKAY. OKAY GOOD. IS IT
AFTERNOON? IT'S NOT YET. JUST
YET. GOOD AFTERNOON, GOOD
MORNING, MARIO GUERRERO, ON
BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. FIRST I WANT TO SAY
THAT WE ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION,
IT I AM LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
AND KNOWING THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
AND LOOKING AT WHAT THE STUDENTS
ARE ASKING FOR. IT WOULD BE HARD
PRESSED TO SEE ANY OPPOSITION.
SO I'M PERSONALLY GLAD THAT
THERE IS AN OPPOSITION. AND I
WOULD SAY THAT THERE ISN'T WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF ONE ITEM, THERE
ARE NO DISAGREEMENTS IN TERMS OF
WHAT HAS BEEN SHARED BY THE
STUDENTS, BY THE AUTHOR. WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT STUDENTS,
ALL STUDENTS, UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS, SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY, SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO JOBS. WE ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT THEY ARE SOME OF THE
BRIGHTEST, YOU KNOW, MINDS OF
OUR STATE, OUR COUNTRY, OUR
WORLD. THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THEM
IN OUR UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. ALL OF
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY, 100% TRUE.
AND I'M GOING OFF SCRIPT BECAUSE
I FEEL THIS PERSONALLY, WHICH
YOU NORMALLY PROFESSIONALLY
DON'T DO, THE ONE DISAGREEMENT
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE IS
WHETHER THE UNIVERSITY CAN
LEGALLY DO WHAT WE'RE WHAT THIS
BILL ASKS US TO DO. AND
UNFORTUNATELY, THE UNIVERSITY
BELIEVES WE CAN'T. AND I AGAIN,
GOING OFF SCRIPT JUST BECAUSE I
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM SHOULD
FEEL WHAT THESE STUDENTS ARE
GOING THROUGH. ABSOLUTELY
EVERYONE. NO ONE SHOULD GO
HUNGRY. EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE
OPPORTUNITY. AND IT'S HARD TO
COME TO THESE HEARINGS DAY IN
AND DAY OUT AND HEAR THAT AND
UNDERSTAND THAT AND FEEL LIKE
THE UNIVERSITY HAS ITS HANDS
TIED, THAT'S THAT PART OF WHAT I
WANTED TO SHARE. ON THE
INFORMATIONAL SIDE, I DO WANT TO
SHARE THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS COME UP WITH WHAT
IT BELIEVES IS THE BEST
ALTERNATIVE IT CAN PUT FORWARD,
WHICH IS EXPERIENTIAL
FELLOWSHIPS. I'VE MENTIONED THIS
IN OTHER HEARINGS PREVIOUSLY,
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT,
ESPECIALLY AS WE HAVE,
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS HERE WITH
US THAT THEY KNOW ABOUT THAT,
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN GET
MORE INFORMATION THROUGH THEIR
DREAM RESOURCE CENTERS THAT WILL
OFFER WORK EXPERIENCE AND,
PAYMENT, WE KNOW THIS IS NOT
WORK, BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT
IS AVAILABLE. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO SHARE HERE. I WILL FINISH UP
BY JUST SAYING WE LOOK FORWARD
TO, YOU KNOW, THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION ON THIS TOPIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATE
THAT. MR. BACH. ERIC BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY,
WE TOO ALSO DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL. WE JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR SINCERE
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. WE
RESPECT HIS MOTIVATIONS, WE ALSO
RESPECT THE STUDENTS THAT CAME
BEFORE US TODAY TO SPEAK, WE
ENCOURAGE EVERY STUDENT TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY. THERE SHOULDN'T
BE ANY RESTRICTIONS OR BARRIERS.
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT. HOWEVER AS
SIMILAR TO WHAT THE èC HAS
NOTED, WE DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LEGALITY ABOUT THE PROPOSAL.
THE THEORY THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL, AND WE'LL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN THIS
DISCUSSION. BUT FOR THE TIME
BEING, WE REMAIN CONCERNED. AND,
DULY NOTED. APPRECIATE THAT
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY. SEEING NONE, LET'S COME
BACK, TO THE DAIS, COMMENTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES. I GUESS I HAVE
THEM, BUT GO AHEAD. HI. I ECHO
THE SENTIMENTS OF THE, OF THE
WITNESSES TODAY WITH REGARDS TO,
THE NEED OF, OF HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY WHICH BRINGS DIGNITY
TO BE ABLE TO WORK AT FOR
ANYONE, ON THAT END. AS A
DAUGHTER OF IMMIGRANT PARENTS,
I, I SHARE THE SENTIMENT OF
WANTING TO MAKE THE AMERICAN
DREAM A REALITY. ABSOLUTELY.
WITHOUT A DOUBT. AND LET ME
PREFACE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
FACT THAT, FOR THE RECORD, AND I
THINK EVERYBODY IS IN IN 100%
AGREEMENT, WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
100, IMMIGRATION REFORM, IN THIS
COUNTRY. AND IT'S INCREDIBLY
DISAPPOINTING FOR ME THAT
NEITHER, YOU KNOW, AND I DON'T
WANT TO MAKE THIS A POLITICAL
THING, BUT NEITHER PARTY
DEMOCRATS OR REPUBLICANS WHO
HAVE HAD FULL CONTROL OF
CONGRESS HAS TAKEN THE
INITIATIVE TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
IN THE UNITED STATES. NEITHER
HAVING SAID THAT, WITH WITH THE
PARTICULARS OF THIS PARTICULAR
BILL OR THE SPECIFICS OF THIS
PARTICULAR BILL, IT'S BEEN
NOTED, SO, FIRST OF ALL, WELL,
LET ME LET ME BEGIN WITH THIS
PART FIRST, AND THEN WE'LL
CONTINUE WITH MY OTHER QUESTION.
SO, ACCORDING TO THE AUTHOR,
THIS MEASURE ATTEMPTS TO, TO
DEFINE BY LEGAL DEFINITION THAT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
NOT CONSIDERED A PERSON, BUT IN
THE FEDERAL CODE. AND I'M NOT A
LEGAL EXPERT. I'M JUST READING
WHAT I'VE BEEN GIVEN HERE. BUT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS
NOT A PERSON, AND THEREFORE THE
NOT SUBJECT TO THE MEASURE, BUT
THE FEDERAL CODE OF REGULATIONS
FURTHER DEFINES AN EMPLOYER FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THIS STATUTE, AS
A PERSON OR ENTITY, INCLUDING AN
AGENT OR ANYONE ACTING DIRECTLY
OR INDIRECTLY IN THE INTERESTS
THEREOF, WHO ENGAGES THE
SERVICES OF LABOR OF AN EMPLOYEE
TO BE PERFORMED IN THE UNITED
STATES FOR WAGES OR OR
ENUMERATION. SO THE CONCERN THAT
I THAT I UNDERSTAND IS HAPPENING
HERE IS THAT, THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE EMPLOYEES INVOLVED IN
THE HIRING PROCESS, THE FACULTY,
THE HUMAN RESOURCES AND LEGAL
PROFESSIONALS, COULD BE SUBJECT
TO CRIMINAL OR CIVIL PROSECUTION
IF THEY KNOWINGLY PARTICIPATE IN
PRACTICES DEEMED IMPERMISSIBLE
UNDER FEDERAL LAW, I THINK
THAT'S THE CONCERN IN THE LEGAL
LANGUAGE THAT BRINGS CONCERN TO
THIS PARTICULAR, POLICY. AND I'M
NOT A LEGAL EXPERT. THIS IS JUST
WHAT THE NOTES THAT I HAVE HERE,
ON THE PRACTICAL SIDE OF THE OF
THE MEASURE, I UNDERSTAND THAT
FOR BUSINESS OWNERS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED, THEY HAVE AN ITIN
NUMBER THAT THEY CAN UTILIZE TO
FILE TAXES, WHICH ACTUALLY HELPS
THEM IN THE PROCESS OF MOVING
FORWARD IN THEIR IMMIGRATION
APPLICATION. WITH REGARDS TO THE
STUDENTS, WHAT WOULD THERE BE AN
EQUIVALENT TO FOR THE STUDENTS
TO BE ABLE TO PAY FEDERAL TAXES?
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE WORKING, HOW
WOULD YOU GO ABOUT PAYING TAXES
AND HAVING THAT IDENTIFICATION
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL? THANK YOU.
SO THIS IS A QUESTION THAT'S
BEEN ANALYZED. I'M GOING TO ASK
KENT TO CHIME IN, BECAUSE TO
GIVE A LITTLE TINY BIT OF
BACKGROUND, ONE OF THE STUDENTS
MENTIONED THAT THIS PROPOSAL WAS
MOVING FORWARD THROUGH THE UC
REGENTS. WE'RE GOING TO
POTENTIALLY IMPLEMENT THIS AT
THE UC LEVEL. AND IN PREPARATION
OF THAT, THE UCLA LAW CENTER AND
THE LABOR CENTER ARE WORKING
WITH THE STUDENT LED NETWORK,
ACTUALLY STARTED TO TALK ABOUT
HOW DOES THIS GET IMPLEMENTED.
SO THAT'S WHY I'D LIKE THE
WITNESS TO RESPOND. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS KENT WONG
WITH THE UCLA LABOR CENTER. I'VE
BEEN PART OF THE UCLA FACULTY
WHERE I HAVE BEEN TEACHING LABOR
STUDIES AND ETHNIC STUDIES FOR
MORE THAN 30 YEARS. SOME OF THE
FINEST STUDENTS IN MY CAREER
HAVE BEEN UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS.
IF I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TODAY,
I WOULD HIRE THEM AS MY TEACHING
ASSISTANTS, AS MY RESEARCHERS,
THEY WOULD MAKE VAST
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE UNIVERSITY
AS WELL AS ENABLE THEM TO OBTAIN
THE CAREER EXPERIENCE THAT THEY
NEED IN ORDER TO SUCCESSFULLY
PURSUE THEIR LONG TERM CAREERS.
SOME OF THE FINEST IMMIGRATION
ATTORNEYS IN THE COUNTRY,
THROUGH THE UCLA LAW SCHOOL,
HAVE CONDUCTED EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH AND HAVE DETERMINED
THAT THE 1986 IMMIGRATION REFORM
AND CONTROL ACT WAS NEVER
WRITTEN TO REQUIRE THE STATES
AND STATE ENTITIES TO IMPLEMENT
EMPLOYER SANCTIONS. IT
SPECIFICALLY CALLED ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO REQUIRE
EMPLOYER SANCTIONS AS WELL AS
PRIVATE BUSINESSES. IT WAS
SILENT WITH REGARD TO THE STATE.
THIS HAS BEEN VETTED AND
SUPPORTED BY LAW SCHOOL DEANS
WITHIN THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, AND DOZENS OF LEGAL
AND CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLARS
AROUND THE COUNTRY. WE HAD A TWO
YEAR PROCESS OF CONVERSATION
WITH THE UCOP AND THE UC GENERAL
COUNSEL. AT NO POINT DID THEY
QUESTION THE FUNDAMENTAL LEGAL
ARGUMENTS AND PREMISE THAT IS
PRESENTED TO THEM. SO THIS IS
INTERESTING THAT ALTHOUGH THE UC
ALRP CLAIMS THAT THEY ARE NOT
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION, THIS IS
THE FIRST TIME THAT THEY ARE
CHALLENGING THE LEGALITY THAT
HAS NEVER BEEN BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION, THAT THEY ARE
DISPUTING THE LEGALITY OF AB
2586, AND WE HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE GENERAL
COUNSEL, AND WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE UC OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. IT IS OUR
CONTENTION THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN THE
CORRECT POSITION IN SUPPORT OF
AB 540 TO ALLOW UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS TO ATTEND WITHOUT
PAYING OUT OF STATE TUITION HAS
TAKEN THE CORRECT STEP WITH
REGARD TO ALLOWING DRIVER'S
LICENSES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS, HAS TAKEN THE RIGHT
STEPS IN PROVIDING HEALTH CARE
ACCESS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS, AND THROUGH THE
EFFORTS OF MANY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN SECURING DACA
DEFERRED ACTION FOR CHILDHOOD
ARRIVALS THAT HAS PROVIDED
EMPLOYMENT RIGHTS FOR MANY,
YOUNG PEOPLE. SO WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB 2586. IT IS CLEARLY
WITHIN LEGAL GROUNDS. I
APPRECIATE THAT. SO I'D ASK YOU
TO FOCUS ON THE SENATOR'S
QUESTION IF YOU WANT TO REPHRASE
IT. YEAH. HOPEFUL. THAT WAS I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS. I JUST
THE QUESTION WAS I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GARNER AN ITIN NUMBER
IN ORDER TO PURSUE AND PAY
TAXES, WHICH IT SHOWS AFTER A
COUPLE OF YEARS. IT SHOWS
ACTUALLY THAT THEY'RE HERE IN
GOOD FAITH AND ARE WANTING TO BE
PART OF THE SYSTEM. AND IT HELPS
THEM WITH THE IMMIGRATION
APPLICATION MOVING FORWARD. YES.
WITH THESE PARTICULAR STUDENTS,
HOW WHAT WOULD THEY WHAT WOULD
THEY UTILIZE IN ORDER TO PAY
THEIR FEDERAL TAXES AND BE IN,
IN, IN, I GUESS, IN WHAT INCOME?
YES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH, WITH,
WITH THEIR, THEIR WAGES. YES.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. SO
THE REALITY IS THAT UNDER DACA
DEFERRED ACTION FOR CHILDHOOD
ARRIVALS, MANY UNDOCUMENTED
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
GAIN LEGAL WORK AUTHORIZATION
THROUGH USE OF ITINS. THESE ARE
NOT SOCIAL SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS. DACA, EMPLOYEES DO NOT
HAVE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS.
HOWEVER, THROUGH ITIN THEY CAN
LEGALLY WORK AND THEY CONTRIBUTE
THROUGH THEIR TAXES THAT ARE
DOCUMENTED THROUGH THEIR ITIN.
SO THAT'S THE ANSWER. THE ANSWER
IS THEY WOULD THEY WOULD HAVE
THE SAME ITIN REPORTING
REQUIREMENT AS ANY OTHER WORKER,
IS IT NOT? NO. YES I AGREE, I
TI¾N WOULD PROVIDE THAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE EMPLOYER TO,
THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES AND
COLLEGES TO DOCUMENT THEIR WORK
AND THEIR PAYMENT. OKAY. SO THE
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO DO THAT,
BUT WHAT HAPPENS TO STUDENTS
LIKE OUR WITNESSES WHO ARE NOT
PART OF THE DACA, THEY DON'T
HAVE THAT ARE NOT PART OF THE
DACA. THAT'S CORRECT. SO THE
UNFORTUNATE REALITY IS THAT
GIVEN THE LEGAL RESTRICTIONS
PREVENTING NEW YOUNG PEOPLE TO
APPLY FOR DACA, WE HAVE
INCREASING NUMBERS OF
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IN ALL
THREE LEVELS OF HIGHER EDUCATION
WHO NO LONGER CAN ACCESS DACA.
AND WE HAVE MANY DACA RECIPIENTS
WHO CANNOT REAPPLY BECAUSE OF
THESE RESTRICTIONS. HOWEVER, IF
AB 2586 IS PASSED INTO LAW, IT
WOULD ENABLE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AT ALL THREE LEVELS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION TO WORK WITHIN
THE PUBLIC COLLEGE SYSTEM
THROUGH USE OF ITINS. SO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING THAT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL WOULD ACTUALLY
ENABLE, STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT
PART OF THE DACA PROGRAM TO
RECEIVE AN IT NUMBER. MANY HAVE
ITIN NUMBERS ALREADY, BUT YES,
IT WOULD ENABLE THEM TO LEGALLY
WORK WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE QUESTION YES,
PLEASE. I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU CLARIFY ON RECORD THAT
THE STUDENTS WHO DO NOT BELONG
OR ARE NOT PART OR DO NOT, ARE
NOT ACCEPTED WITHIN THE DACA
PROGRAM OUTSIDE OF THE DACA, WHO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED, ARE ABLE TO
PROCURE AN ITIN NUMBER AND
THEREFORE PARTICIPATE IN PAYING
THEIR AND WHO ASSIGNS THE ITIN
NUMBER. THE PROCESS OF APPLYING
FOR ITIN IS SEPARATE FROM THE
IMMIGRATION PROCESS, AN ITIN
PROVIDES INDIVIDUALS TO REGISTER
AND SHORT ANSWER IS THE IRS
PROVIDES THE ITIN THE IRS SO THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. YES. SO THE
FEDERAL ENTITY GIVES THE EYE TO
NUMBERS. AND THEY ARE IT'S CLEAR
THAT ACCORDING TO WHAT YOU JUST
STATED, THAT THEY WILL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL GIVE THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE NOT PART OF
THE CURRENTLY PART OF THE DACA,
THAT ARE UNDOCUMENTED IN ITIN
NUMBER. THERE ARE MANY
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
ITIN NUMBERS TODAY WHO ARE NOT
DACA. SO YES. THIS ACTUALLY
ISN'T SUPER USEFUL AT THIS POINT.
BUT BUT PLEASE DO GET
CLARIFICATION BECAUSE THERE ARE
I ANSWERED THE QUESTION. I THINK
YOU DID. THERE'S A NUMBER OF,
YOU KNOW, SORT OF DETAILS THAT
NATURALLY PROCEED FROM THE
EMPLOYMENT. THE QUESTION HERE IS
IT LEGAL? BUT BUT GO AHEAD. YEAH
AGAIN, PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA AND
ACTUALLY NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA,
IN THE COUNTRY WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED TODAY CAN HAVE ITIN
NUMBERS AND DO HAVE ITIN NUMBERS
AND THEY ARE NOT DACA. SO
INTERESTING ENOUGH, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL GIVE YOU AN ID
NUMBER EVEN IF YOU DON'T BELONG
TO. THAT'S CORRECT. OKAY. ALL
RIGHT. YOU GOOD. YEAH OKAY. YES,
SIR. SENATOR CORTEZ. I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR. YOU KNOW,
CHALLENGING US, REALLY AS A
STATE TO BE BOLD, YOU KNOW, IN
THIS AREA AND REALLY, I THINK
KIND OF FORCE THE ISSUE. IT'S
THE WAY I WOULD PUT IT. I DON'T
WANT TO. APPLY, YOU KNOW, OR
ATTRIBUTE SOMETHING TO THE
AUTHOR THAT HE'S NOT TRYING TO
SAY. BUT THAT'S JUST MY VIEW OF
IT IS SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO
FORCE THE ISSUE, THE CONCERN IS,
YOU KNOW, DOWNSTREAM AND I
RESPECT THIS ON THE UC SIDE, IS
THAT WHEN YOU FORCE THE ISSUE,
YOU DON'T ALWAYS WIN. AND, YOU
KNOW, IN 2016, AFTER, THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS,
IMMEDIATELY UPON INAUGURATION,
WITHIN 24 HOURS, THE THEN
PRESIDENT ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER WHICH COMPLETELY CHANGED
THE IMMIGRATION LAWS AND
BASICALLY SAID THAT THE PENALTY
FOR NOT COMPLYING WITH THOSE
IMMIGRATION LAWS WOULD BE THAT
IF YOU'RE RECEIVING FEDERAL
FUNDING FOR YOUR MEDICAL
PROGRAMS, THAT THAT WOULD ALL BE
CLAWED BACK. I HAPPEN TO BE AT
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA AT
THAT TIME, AS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS, WE
FILED SUIT, WHICH WAS ALSO
ULTIMATELY PREVAILED AT THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
OVERTURNING THAT. BUT THAT'S THE
KIND OF CONSEQUENCES YOU GET
WHEN SOMETIMES WHEN YOU'RE BOLD.
AND I GUESS I JUST WANT TO SAY I
RESPECT AND UNDERSTAND
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
INSTITUTIONAL POSITION, WHICH IS
BOB PARAPHRASE, IT. LOOK, YOU
KNOW, WE HATE TO MAKE THE REST
OF THE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM
VULNERABLE, IF WE GET, YOU KNOW,
THE WRONG INDIVIDUAL. YOU KNOW,
IN THAT OFFICE OR THAT KIND OF
QUICK ACTION BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THAT IMMEDIATELY
TRIES TO COME IN AND USE THE
PURSE STRINGS, YOU KNOW, TO, TO
PENALIZE AND PUNISH, NOT US AS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA, BUT IN
EFFECT, THAT THE SYSTEMS THAT
ARE, YOU KNOW, TRYING TO
IMPLEMENT THIS AND THEN
ULTIMATELY THAT HAS AN IMPACT ON
THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES BECAUSE,
THAT USUALLY COMES HAND IN HAND
WITH POLICIES THAT, NOT TO BE
SCARY, BUT, I MEAN, THIS HAS
HAPPENED. WE JUST LIVE THIS
HISTORY, YOU KNOW, OVER THE
LAST, 8 TO 10 YEARS. YOU GET YOU
GET CORRESPONDING ACTIONS, YOU
KNOW, ICE ACTIONS AND OTHER
ACTIONS THAT, THAT COME IN AND
TRY TO FURTHER PUNISH PEOPLE FOR
GOING DOWN THIS PATH. ALL THAT
SAID, I THINK IT'S I THINK IT'S
WORTH IT. BUT IT'S EASY FOR ME
TO SAY BECAUSE I'M NOT ONE OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE IN THIS
SITUATION. I'M A STATE SENATOR.
I'M PRETTY MUCH INSULATED, YOU
KNOW, FROM A LOT OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
MIGHT COME. BUT I THINK IT'S
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT'S UNSUSTAINABLE WHERE WE'RE
AT RIGHT NOW. AND I THINK THE
STATISTICS ABOUT, YOU KNOW, HOW
MANY FOLKS WE HAVE WHO ARE STUCK
IN THE MIDDLE. I HAVE A DACA
EMPLOYEE NOW, THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I HAD TWO AS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR. THEY WEREN'T
ALWAYS ABLE TO MAINTAIN THAT
STATUS, CONTINUOUSLY DURING THE
PROCESS. AND THAT CREATES A
PROBLEM TOO, WHERE ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU HAVE A GAP IN THE
EMPLOYER SAYS, SORRY, YOU'RE
BASICALLY GOING TO HAVE TO GO ON
UNPAID LEAVE OF ABSENCE. THAT'S
THAT'S TOUGH WHEN YOU'RE A KID
OR YOU'RE A STUDENT, KIND OF THE
STARVING STUDENT PERSON. AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN NOW YOU CAN'T WORK
FOR A FEW WEEKS WHILE YOU'RE
WAITING, WAITING FOR, YOU KNOW,
A FEDERAL, RE-APPROVAL OF YOUR
STATUS. YOU KNOW, THIS WOULD
SOLVE THAT, YOU KNOW, IF IT CAN
BE SUSTAINED. SO, AGAIN, THAT'S
THAT'S WHY I'M SUPPORTING IT.
OTHER MEMBERS KNOW, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ, LET ME ASK A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THAT RELATE
TO THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE
èC AS TO THE LEGALITY, AND, YOU
KNOW, YOUR BILL IS BASED ON A
THEORY, I GUESS AN
INTERPRETATION LAW THAT SAYS THE
IMMIGRATION REFORM CONTROL ACT
DOES NOT APPLY TO STATE
GOVERNMENTS. AND I THINK AND I
DO THINK LOOKING AT THE
JUDICIARY ANALYSIS, YOU KNOW,
THEY VALIDATED AT LEAST WITHIN
OUR KIND OF SPHERE THAT THEORY.
BUT BUT CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH
HOW THIS THEORY COULD OR WILL BE
TESTED? SURE. AND YOU REFERENCED
THE IT'S A 27 PAGE LEGAL
MEMORANDUM ON, THE ANALYSIS OF
THE 1986 IMMIGRATION REFORM AND
CONTROL ACT, WHICH THIS, THIS IS
BASED OFF OF, WHICH IS, WHAT IS
SILENT ON THE ISSUE OF STATES,
EXPLICITLY AND BASED ON CASE
LAW, INCLUDING SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENTS, THAT FEDERAL LAW,
WHEN FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT
MENTION STATES EXPLICITLY THAT
FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT BIND STATE
GOVERNMENTS AND THEIR ENTITIES.
AND THAT IS REALLY THE SUMMARY
OF THE 1986 LAW, OF WHICH THIS
IS BASED OFF OF, SENATOR CORTESE
MENTIONED CONSEQUENCES, WHICH,
YOU KNOW, I THINK ARE,
EVERYBODY'S VERY COGNIZANT OF
THAT. I'M COGNIZANT OF THAT.
CERTAINLY THE STUDENTS WHO
WITHOUT THEM, WE WOULDN'T BE
HERE TODAY, THEY'RE COGNIZANT OF
THAT. THEY'VE BEEN, BRAVELY
ATTENDING, AND, AND SPEAKING UP
AND IDENTIFYING THEMSELVES IN A
VERY VULNERABLE WAY TO AT THIS
POINT HAS GOT TO BE, YOU KNOW,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THROUGH
THESE HEARINGS, THROUGH THE èC
PROCESS. AND, THEY THEY
UNDERSTAND THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. I THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOUR QUESTION IS ABOUT. AND
YOU KNOW, THE REAL QUESTION IS
HOW WILL THIS BE TESTED? AND
SENATOR CORTEZ'S POINT IN SOME
AFFIRMATIVE WAY BEFORE WE GET
INTO, YOU KNOW, PROSPECTIVELY, A
POLITICAL SITUATION WHERE IT
GETS VERY CONCERNING, IT COULD
BE TESTED AT ANY TIME, JUST LIKE
ANY OTHER LAW THAT WE INTRODUCE.
IT COULD BE CHALLENGED. AND THAT
IS A VERY REAL REALITY THAT WE
FACE WITH EVERY LAW THAT WE
INTRODUCE. BUT THIS ONE THAT
UNFORTUNATELY, SEEMS TO
ENCOURAGE, DIFFERENT
PERSONALITIES TO, TO TRY AND WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT COULD
HAPPEN, WE COULD BE CHALLENGED
IN, IN, IN COURT. THIS COULD BE
A CASE THAT, YOU KNOW, GOES
THROUGH THE APPELLATE PROCESS,
POTENTIALLY GOES TO THE SUPREME
COURT PROCESS. WE CANNOT
DETERMINE WHETHER THAT WILL
HAPPEN OR NOT. BUT, THE CASE,
LAW THAT'S CITED AS TO WHY WE
THINK THIS WOULD EVEN NGUYEN AT
THE SUPREME COURT LEVEL, IS WHY
WE EVEN HAVE THIS BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY, WE WOULD NOT BE
INTRODUCING A BILL THAT WE THINK
HAD ABSOLUTELY NO CHANCE OF
BEING LEGALLY PROVEN CORRECT.
CLEARLY. AND SO, I GUESS SENATOR
CHUBBUCK TOUCHED ON SOME OF
THIS. SO TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
YOUR INTERPRETATION OR THE
INTERPRETATION HERE IS THAT THAT
THE STATE IS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
PROVISIONS OF RCA, COULD THE
LEGISLATURE, AS AN EXAMPLE, HIRE
A NON DACA UNDOCUMENTED PERSON?
AND HAVE WE. SO IT IS THE
OPINION OF LEGAL SCHOLARS, WHICH
I WAS NOT ONE OF THE ONES WHO
DRAFTED THIS, BUT I HAVE READ
THIS OPINION. IF IT'S BEEN AT
LEAST FIVE TIMES, AND I HIGHLY
SUGGEST EVERYBODY WHO'S
INTERESTED SHOULD READ IT
BECAUSE THERE'S IT WAS, SHOCKING
TO SEE HOW CLEARLY THIS IS
DEFINITELY POSSIBLE, THE, THIS
COULD BE APPLIED IN MY, IN MY
OPINION, IN THEIR OPINION TO
STATE ENTITY, ANYTHING THAT'S A
STATE ENTITY. Ã. WE DECIDED AND
WE THOUGHT THAT IT MADE THE MOST
SENSE, GIVEN THE WORK THAT THE
STUDENT LED NETWORK HAS BEEN
LEADING FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS,
THROUGH THE èC, THEY WENT
THROUGH A PROCESS OF HOW THIS
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED FROM AN HR
PERSPECTIVE THAT WE COULD MUCH
MORE SIMPLY AND QUICKLY APPLY
THIS TO WHERE STUDENTS ARE,
WHICH IS ON CAMPUSES. THAT'S THE
NATURAL PLACE WHERE THESE
STUDENTS ARE. AND THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS LIMITED JUST TO
THAT, I APPRECIATE THAT. SO, SO
KIND OF UNDER THAT THEORY, WHAT
YOU KNOW, WHAT PROVISIONS ARE
CONTAINED OR WHAT'S YOUR
THINKING, WHAT IF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM, THE CSU, BUT
PARTICULARLY UC, IF THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY MAY NOT BE LEGALLY
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL,
PARTICULARLY, YOU SEE TO WHOM WE
AFFORD SUBSTANTIAL KIND OF
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTONOMY, WHAT
WHAT, IF ANY, REMEDY MIGHT THEY
HAVE? AND BY BY EXTENSION, YOU
KNOW, WHAT WOULD COMPEL THEM TO
DO? SO SO, AS YOU KNOW, WITH
EVERY BILL RELATED TO THE UC,
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY
IS WHAT IT IS. AND WE CANNOT
MANDATE THROUGH A LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THEM TO DO ANYTHING. SO
THIS IS REQUESTING THAT THEY
PARTICIPATE. AND WE WOULD
ACTUALLY HOPE THAT THEY WOULD
JOIN IN ANY POTENTIAL, LEGAL
ACTION THAT NEEDS TO BE TAKEN TO
COMMIT TO JOINING WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN IN DEFENDING
THIS LAW ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, ON BEHALF OF THE CSU
SYSTEM, AND IN THEIR CASE, ON
BEHALF OF THE UC SYSTEM. SO
THAT'S IN EFFECT THE ANSWER THAT
AT SOME POINT IT WOULD BE NEEDED
TO BE TESTED IN A COURT, AT
WHATEVER LEVEL IT COULD BE
TESTED. YOU'RE CORRECT. OKAY. I
APPRECIATE THAT. MR. SEGURA. ANY
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO RESPOND TO
THAT? BUT I THINK THESE ARE
YOU'VE RAISED SOME IMPORTANT
CONCERNS, AND I THINK THEY ARE
WORTH CONSIDERING. I WOULD JUST
REITERATE WHAT THE AUTHOR SAID,
WHICH IS THAT AT SOME POINT,
THIS MIGHT INCLUDE THE COURTS
WEIGHING IN ON WHETHER AB 2586
IS A POLICY THAT THE UC CAN
IMPLEMENT. I APPRECIATE THAT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS,
COLLEAGUES? WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR CORTESE, I YOU
KNOW, I SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS. I THINK THEY WILL PLAY
OUT. I PARTICULARLY SHARE,
SENATOR CORTEZ'S CONCERNS ABOUT
POLITICAL ENVIRONMENTS AND HOW
THEY MIGHT CHANGE AND AFFECT
STUDENTS, ESPECIALLY, STUDENTS
WHO HAVE OTHERWISE BEEN, IN JUST
INCREDIBLE BY WAY OF YOUR BELIEF
IN OUR SYSTEM AND YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO KEEP PUSHING
FORWARD. SO I COMMEND BOTH THE
STUDENT WITNESSES FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR.
GIVEN THAT THIS IS THE LAST,
COMMITTEE THAT I THINK WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY, I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK
THE STUDENTS WHO, WITHOUT THEIR
SUPPORT, WITHOUT THEIR HARD
WORK, WITHOUT THEIR DEDICATION
AND THEIR PASSION, WE WOULD NOT
BE HERE TODAY, YOU HEARD FROM
TWO STUDENTS TODAY, BUT
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE PROCESS,
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS, WE HAVE
HEARD FROM MULTIPLE STUDENTS AT
EVERY HEARING. AND I CONTINUE TO
BE INSPIRED. I HOPE YOU'RE ALSO
INSPIRED BY WHAT'S BEFORE US.
THIS IS THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL IS ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA. I WANT
TO TELL DAVID BECAUSE I HAD NOT
HAD A CHANCE TO MEET HIM BEFORE,
BUT HE SAID HE HE HOPES THAT HIS
PARENTS WOULD BE PROUD OF HIM. I
WANT TO TELL YOU, THEY ARE
THEY'RE DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
PROUD OF YOU. AND I'M REALLY
PROUD OF ALL THE STUDENTS FOR
BEING A PART OF THIS. IT IS NOT
DIFFICULT. THEY ARE IN A VERY
IT'S AMAZING HOW FROM VULNERABLE
YOU CAN GO FROM VULNERABLE TO
BEING STRONG. I THINK THERE'S
SOME OF THE MOST STRONG AND
COURAGEOUS PEOPLE TODAY IN HOPES
THAT CALIFORNIA RESPONDS IN KIND
TO THEIR DEDICATION, TO THEIR
COMMITMENTS, TO DO WHAT WE ASK
OF ALL OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE,
WHICH IS TO STAY IN SCHOOL AND
DO WELL, AND THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY WILL BE FOR THEM. ON
THE OTHER END. FOR THESE
STUDENTS, THAT OPPORTUNITY DOES
NOT EXIST, WE CAN SIT HERE AND
TRY AND TRY AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
WHAT HAPPENED UNDER ONE
ADMINISTRATION AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL VERSUS ANOTHER. WE HAVE
HEARD WHAT ONE OF THE CANDIDATES
HAS SAID ABOUT, UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS. PROJECT 2025 SAYS
THAT THEY IMMIGRANTS WILL ALL BE
DEPORTED. ALL ALL THE MILLIONS
OF IMMIGRANTS THROUGHOUT OUR
COUNTRY. THAT IS A REALITY THAT
IS FACING US NO MATTER WHAT WE
DO WITH THIS BILL. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE SOME
HOPE. AS I MENTIONED EARLIER, TO
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE GIVING US
HOPE WITH THEIR TESTIMONY, WITH
THEIR WORK AND WHAT THEY'VE DONE
TO GET US TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I HOPE
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN PROVIDING
THAT HOPE FOR OPPORTUNITY FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT CALIFORNIA
ONCE AGAIN LEADS OUR NATION IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
ADDRESSING SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE, BUT ALSO SOME OF OUR
MOST HARDEST WORKING AND THE
FUTURE OF OUR STATE AND OUR
COUNTRY. I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR CORTESE. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WELL, ITEM 15 AB 2586
ALVAREZ. MOTION IS DUE. PASSES
AND AN APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE. OTTO BORG.
CORTESE CORTESE. AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WILK THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS THREE VOTES. WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND THANK YOU TO OUR WITNESSES,
PARTICULARLY OUR STUDENT
WITNESSES. THANK YOU TO ALL THE
STUDENTS AS WELL. TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALVAREZ'S POINT, NOT JUST
FOR BEING HERE TODAY, BUT FOR
BEING PART OF THIS PROCESS ALL
THE WAY UP TO NOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND NEXT, WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI.
THANK YOU FOR WAITING SO
PATIENTLY. MY COUNTERPART, THE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION. I'M SURE YOU'VE
ENJOYED WATCHING HOW WE DO OUR
BUSINESS FOR LONGER THAN YOU
THOUGHT YOU WOULD HAVE TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
SENATORS, I AM HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL 2473, WHICH IS Ã
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
BILL THAT HAS PROVIDED THE
LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE FOR US TO
REVIEW A PROPOSAL AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET RELATED TO
TEACHER CREDENTIALING IN THE
ARTS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WILL
HAVE ENOUGH TEACHERS FOR THE
ROLLOUT OF PROPOSITION 28. ART
AND MUSIC PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. THIS BILL IS THE
PRODUCT OF NEGOTIATIONS,
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION, THE BILL
SUPPORTS OUR WORKFORCE NEEDS IN
ARTS EDUCATION BY STREAMLINING
THE PROCESS FOR EXISTING
TEACHERS TO EARN A SUPPLEMENTAL
AUTHORIZATION IN A NEW SUBJECT,
SUCH AS ART, MUSIC, THEATER AND
DANCE. AND ADDITIONALLY, THIS
BILL WILL EXPAND OPTIONS FOR
TEACHERS TO EARN A SUPPLEMENTAL
AUTHORIZATION IN CALIFORNIA
USING AUTHORIZATIONS THEY EARNED
IN OTHER STATES. FINALLY, THIS
BILL CONTAINS CLEANUP LANGUAGE
RELATED TO ANOTHER SUBJECT, A
BILL ENACTED LAST YEAR ON
NEWCOMER STUDENTS. WITH ME. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL, WE HAVE
CHAD ZULLINGER, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION AND MELISSA BRAMHAM,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DANCE EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU. SO, GOOD MORNING.
COMMITTEE CHAIRPERSON NEWMAN,
WHEREVER YOU MIGHT BE, AND THE
MEMBERS, I'M CHAD ZELINGER,
REPRESENTING THE 1700 MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION. I HAVE BEEN A MUSIC
TEACHER, GOING ON ON MY 25TH
YEAR. AND I CURRENTLY AM
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR FOR MUSIC
EDUCATION AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY. I AM HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 2473,
AMENDED JUNE 24TH. MUCH WORK AND
DISCUSSION HAS TAKEN PLACE ON
THIS BILL, AS AMENDED. CMEA
BELIEVES THIS VERSION OF THE
BILL BENEFITS ALL EDUCATORS IN
ADDITION TO ART, DANCE, MUSIC
AND THEATER, AS AMENDED. AB 2473
WOULD DO THE FOLLOWING. ALLOW A
SINGLE MULTIPLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIAL HOLDER TO ADD A
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION IN
ART, THEATER, MUSIC, DANCE,
SCIENCE, MATH, ETC. OUT OF
STATE. SINGLE AND MULTIPLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIAL HOLDERS WOULD
BE AVAILABLE, WOULD ABLE TO
RECEIVE EQUIVALENT SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATIONS THAT RECOGNIZE
THEIR OUT OF STATE CREDENTIALS.
THIS INCLUDES ALL MULTIPLE AND
SINGLE SUBJECT AREAS, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF SPECIAL EDUCATION.
LASTLY, AS AMENDED, A
CREDENTIALED TEACHER WOULD BE
ABLE TO DEMONSTRATE SUBJECT
MATTER COMPETENCY FOR A
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION
THROUGH ANY OF THE EXISTING
METHODS AVAILABLE TO SINGLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
EXISTING LAW ONLY AUTHORIZES
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATIONS
THROUGH COURSEWORK OR A MAJOR IN
THE SUBJECT. THIS WILL ALLOW
CSET COURSEWORK AND TRANSCRIPT
REVIEW AS VIABLE OPTIONS FOR
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATIONS. AS
AMENDED. CMA BELIEVES THAT AB
2473 CLARIFIES AND STRENGTHENS
EXISTING CREDENTIALING
REQUIREMENTS SPECIFIC TO
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATIONS FOR
SINGLE SUBJECT, MULTIPLE
SUBJECT, AND OUT OF STATE
CREDENTIAL HOLDERS. THE TEACHER
SHORTAGE WOULD BE ADDRESSED WITH
THESE CLARIFICATIONS, AND
STUDENT STUDENTS WOULD BENEFIT
FROM INSTRUCTION BY QUALIFIED
TEACHERS IN ALL SUBJECTS. IT IS
FOR THESE REASONS CMA FULLY
SUPPORTS AB 2473, AS AMENDED.
JUNE 24TH, 2024. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEES AND STAFF
FOR ALL OF THEIR TIME AND EFFORT
ON THIS BILL. PLEASE VOTE YES ON
AB 2473 AS AMENDED. GO ON WITH
WELCOME, MISS BERMAN. HI,
WELCOME. THANK YOU, GOOD DAY TO
CHAIR NEWMAN. AND MEMBERS. I'M
DOCTOR MELISSA BRAMHAM, AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DANCE EDUCATION ASSOCIATION.
CDVA, WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
2473, AS AMENDED ON JUNE 24TH,
THIS BILL MARKS A CRUCIAL STEP
FORWARD FOR EDUCATORS, INCLUDING
THOSE IN ART, DANCE, MUSIC AND
THEATER. AB 2473, IN ITS CURRENT
FORM, ACHIEVES SEVERAL KEY
GOALS. IT EMPOWERS SINGLE AND
MULTIPLE SUBJECT CREDENTIAL
HOLDERS TO ADD SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATIONS AND DIVERSE
FIELDS LIKE DANCE, THEATER,
MUSIC, ART, SCIENCE, MATH. IT
ENSURES THAT OUT-OF-STATE,
SINGLE AND MULTIPLE SUBJECT
CREDENTIAL HOLDERS CAN SWIFTLY
OBTAIN EQUIVALENT SUPPLEMENTARY
AUTHORIZATIONS, RECOGNIZING
THEIR STATE CREDENTIALS, AND IT
ALLOWS CREDENTIAL TEACHERS TO
DEMONSTRATE SUBJECT MATTER
COMPETENCIES THROUGH VARIOUS
METHODS, ENHANCING FLEXIBILITY
AND ACCESSIBILITY. THESE CHANGES
IN AB 2473 WILL HELP ALLEVIATE
TEACHER SHORTAGES AND ENSURE
STUDENTS RECEIVE QUALITY
INSTRUCTION. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO DETAIL ADDRESSING
THESE TEACHER SHORTAGES AND
RATHER THAN CREATING BARRIERS,
HAVE STRENGTHENED EQUITABLE
ACCESS IN ALL SUBJECTS. SO WE
SINCERELY THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND BUDGET STAFF FOR THEIR
DILIGENT WORK ON THIS BILL. AND
CDVA URGES A YES VOTE ON AB
2473. THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU,
MISS BURNHAM. SORRY, SORRY.
THAT'S GOOD. THANK YOU. I'M
BACK. SORRY. AND I LEFT. HAVE
YOU. HAVE YOU TESTIFIED YET? YOU
DID. WAS IT GOOD? WERE YOU GOOD?
YOU'RE VERY PERSUASIVE. ALL
RIGHT. AND ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD, SEEING NONE. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
CLEARLY, IT WAS PERSUASIVE, SO
SEEING NO OPPOSITION, LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES. I
AM GLAD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
ANYTHING FROM ANYBODY? SO DO WE
HAVE A MOTION? HIS MOTION FOR
SENATOR, SENATOR COURTESY MAKES
THE MOTION, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE. ITEM 14 AB 2473, ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
A NEWMAN. AYE. OKOBOJI OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER.
AYE GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WILK. HI WILK. AYE. ALL RIGHT,
THEN. MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS FIVE
VOTES. WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU TO
THE WITNESSES. THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUE. WHICH NOW BRINGS US
TO. AND IS HE HERE, AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER 18. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. BR
WELCOME, YOU WILL BE PRESENTING
ON AB 2918, YOU AND YOUR
WITNESSES ARE WELCOME. AND SO TO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO COME, YOU SURE?
OKAY YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS. I AM PROUD TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 2918, WHICH IS A KEY
PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS
ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE AND JOINT
AUTHOR OF THE BILL, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, ADDIS AB 2918 IS
SPONSORED BY THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, TONY THURMOND, AND
THE JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF
FOR THEIR ENGAGEMENT AND THEIR
EXPERTISE. THE ANALYSIS
DESCRIBES SOME HELPFUL
AMENDMENTS WHICH WE ACCEPT, AND
AS THE COMMITTEE STAFF IS AWARE,
WE ARE STILL IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
MANY OF THE STAKEHOLDERS AND
EXPECT TO CONTINUE TO FINE TUNE
THIS BILL, WHICH WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
ON, ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES,
INCLUDING CERTAIN CRITERIA THAT
NEED TO BE INCLUDED, SUCH AS
WHICH STAKEHOLDERS MUST BE
INCLUDED IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
WORKING GROUPS. THE SECTION
RELATED TO WRITTEN NOTICE, AND
SOME TRANSPARENCY DETAILS THE
THRESHOLD FOR WHAT COUNTS AS A
REVISION AND WHAT COUNTS AS AN
EXISTING COURSE AND RE-ADDING
SOME REFERENCES TO TITLE OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT, SOME
BACKGROUND ON THIS ONGOING WORK.
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING THE BILL
WITH CTA, CFT, ACSA AND KSBA AND
OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS. WE'VE
HAD MULTIPLE CONVERSATIONS, BOTH
WITH THE GROUPS INDIVIDUALLY AND
TOGETHER. THEY'VE EXPRESSED
SUPPORT FOR THE OVERALL GOALS OF
THE BILL AND HAVE PROVIDED
IMPORTANT FEEDBACK THAT IS NOT
YET BEEN FLESHED OUT. SO WE'VE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
ON THEIR SUGGESTIONS OVER THE
SUMMER RECESS. OF COURSE, IN
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH THIS
COMMITTEE. THAT'S WHY, WITH YOUR
BLESSING, MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, WE WOULD LIKE
TO CONTINUE ENGAGING WITH THE
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF TO FURTHER
REFINE THE BILL LANGUAGE. AS I
LAID OUT, JUST A BIT AGO NOW,
RETURNING TO THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE BILL IN CALIFORNIA, WE
CELEBRATE OUR DIVERSITY,
RECOGNIZING IT AS A CORNERSTONE
OF OUR VALUES AND STRENGTH AS A
COMMUNITY, AS SUCH, IT'S CRUCIAL
THAT WHAT IS TAUGHT IN OUR
SCHOOLS REFLECT THIS DIVERSITY.
FOSTERING UNDERSTANDING,
RESPECT, AND APPRECIATION FOR
THE MULTITUDE OF CULTURAL
PERSPECTIVES AND EXPERIENCES
THAT ENRICH OUR SOCIETY. ETHNIC
STUDIES OFFERS AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS TO BOTH
LEARN ABOUT COMMUNITIES OTHER
THAN THEIR OWN, AND TO SEE
THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN THE
STORIES THEY HEAR AT SCHOOLS.
THE GOAL OF ETHNIC STUDIES HAVE
BEEN, AND CONTINUE TO BE
SUPPORTED AND PRIORITIZED BY THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND OTHER
DIVERSITY CAUCUSES. MEMBERS OF
THE JEWISH CAUCUS ARE PROUD THAT
EVERY MEMBER SUPPORTED THE
ETHNIC STUDIES BILL WHEN IT WAS
ADOPTED. AND NOW FOR THE REASONS
FOR THE BILL. AS THE BILL
STARTED TO BE IMPLEMENTED, THE
ORIGINAL ETHNIC STUDIES BILL
STARTED TO BE IMPLEMENTED. THE
2019 DRAFT ON THE ETHNIC STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM WAS WIDELY
CRITICIZED NOT ONLY BY THE
GOVERNOR AND OTHER STATE LEADERS
IN CALIFORNIA, BUT BY MANY OF
THE COMMUNITIES IT AIMED TO
UPLIFT BECAUSE OF CERTAIN
MISLEADING FAULTS AND SOME
BIASED CONTENT IN THE DRAFT.
AFTER A SUBSEQUENT LENGTHY,
TRANSPARENT AND PUBLIC PROCESS,
THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION REPLACED THE FIRST
DRAFT IN 2021 WITH AN ETHNIC
STUDIES MODEL CURRICULUM THAT
WAS SUPPORTED BY THE GOVERNOR,
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT, AND
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE COMMUNITIES.
DISTRICTS RETAINED THE
FLEXIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT THIS
MODEL CURRICULUM OR ADOPT
LOCALLY DEVELOPED CURRICULA TO,
FOR EXAMPLE, TAILOR THEIR
CLASSES TO THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND HERITAGE. IN
2021, ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
ADVANCED AB 101, WHICH CONTAINED
IMPORTANT GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE
THAT CURRICULUMS BEING ADOPTED
WOULD ALIGN WITH THE STATE GOALS
AND NOT PROMOTE BIAS, BIGOTRY,
OR DISCRIMINATION. AND THIS AND
THAT COURSEWORK WAS APPROPRIATE
FOR MEMBERS OF ALL COMMUNITIES.
DESPITE THESE CRITICAL
GUARDRAILS, THERE ARE ETHNIC
STUDIES, INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
THAT CONTINUE TO BE USED THAT DO
NOT PASS THROUGH THE SAME
STANDARDIZED STATE. LEVEL
APPROVAL PROCESSES AS OTHER
MATERIALS AS AS MOST OTHER
CURRICULUM AND INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS THAT ARE OFFERED IN
OUR SCHOOLS. IN ADDITION,
BECAUSE, THE FRAMEWORK AND
STANDARDS AND INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS HAVE NEVER BEEN
DEVELOPED AT THE STATE LEVEL,
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS MUST
EITHER DEVELOP INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS ON THEIR OWN OR TURN
TO OUTSIDE SOURCES. AS A RESULT,
SOME SCHOOLS HAVE ADOPTED AND
BEGUN UTILIZING CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS THAT ARE
PROBLEMATIC, AND MANY TIMES
FAMILIES FOUND OUT ABOUT IT ONLY
AFTER THE OBJECTIONABLE MATERIAL
WAS ALREADY BEING TAUGHT IN
CLASSROOMS. WITHOUT THE
TRANSPARENT REVIEW PROCESS. IN
THIS BILL, PARENTS AND MEMBERS
OF THE LOCAL COMMUNITY WILL BE
LEFT UNCERTAIN AS TO WHAT
LESSONS WILL BE TAUGHT TO THE
STUDENTS. AB 2918 EMBODIES A
COMMITMENT TO INCLUSIVE
EDUCATION FOR ALL STUDENTS BY
IMPLEMENTING COMMON SENSE
TRANSPARENCY TO THE ADOPTION
PROCESS OF K THROUGH 12 ETHNIC
STUDIES, MATERIALS, AND BY
STRENGTHENING EXISTING
EDUCATIONAL GUARDRAILS TO
PREVENT DISCRIMINATORY AND
BIASED INSTRUCTION, WHICH WILL
BENEFIT ALL STUDENTS IN ALL
COMMUNITIES. THE BILL BENEFITS
ALL COMMUNITIES WHO ARE SUBJECT
TO BIAS AND DISCRIMINATION, AND
PROVIDES ESSENTIAL TOOLS TO
ENSURE OUR CLASSROOMS ARE SAFE
AND SUPPORTIVE FOR ALL STUDENTS.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, AND I NOW
WOULD LIKE TO YIELD THE
REMAINDER OF MY TIME TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADDIS FOR REMARKS.
WELCOME, MR. MEMBER, PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M PROUD TO BE HERE, TO BE HERE
TO CO-PRESENT AB 2918 AS A
COAUTHOR. I'M ALSO A FORMER
CLASSROOM TEACHER AND FORMER CTA
MEMBER, AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL IN MY EXPERIENCE, THAT
STUDENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN ABOUT THEIR OWN HISTORIES
AND TO SEE THEMSELVES REFLECTED
IN THE CURRICULUM THAT THEY ARE
BEING TAUGHT. WE KNOW THAT IT IS
VITAL FOR CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION TO BE INCLUSIVE AND
AFFIRMATIVE, REFLECTING THE
IDENTITIES AND DIVERSITY OF OUR
STUDENTS. AND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ZABIR MENTIONED, AB 2918
STRENGTHENS TRANSPARENCY
POLICIES IN THE LOCAL ADOPTION
PROCESSES FOR K-12 ETHNIC
STUDIES CURRICULA TO ENSURE THAT
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE ENGAGED IN
THE PROCESS OF ADOPTING
CURRICULA AND TO PROTECT AGAINST
BIAS AND BIGOTRY FROM BEING
INSERTED. I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT
AB 2019 DOES ALL OF THIS WHILE
RESPECTING AND VALUING STANDARD
EDUCATIONAL PRACTICES AND
PROCESSES AND CURRENT ED CODE.
THIS BILL REALLY HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENTS THAT ARE FREE FROM
DISCRIMINATION, FREE FROM BIAS,
FREE FROM STIGMATIZATION AND HAS
THE UNDERSTANDING AND FOCUS THAT
ALL STUDENTS DESERVE TO BE IN.
WELCOMING AND AFFIRMING
ENVIRONMENTS WHEN THEY ARE
LEARNING, ESPECIALLY ON
IMPORTANT TOPICS LIKE ETHNIC
STUDIES. SO I WOULD LIKE TO END
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR DILIGENCE IN ASSISTING
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DESERVES, ZUBIR
DESCRIBED, AND THAT WILL ACCEPT
AND WITH YOUR PERMISSION, AS
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED, WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE ENGAGING IN
THIS CONVERSATION BECAUSE IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT. SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE, VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND WITH US AS
MENTIONED IS CHERYL COTTON FROM
THE, DEPARTMENT SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION, ON BEHALF
OF THE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION, TONY THURMOND, AS
WELL AS ADRIANA LOMBARD FROM THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY RELATIONS
COUNCIL. WELCOME. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME AGAIN IS
CHERYL COTTON. I'M DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND IN SUPPORT OF AB 2918.
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND IS A
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL. AS YOU
KNOW, ETHNIC STUDIES PROVIDES A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS
OF COLOR TO LEARN ABOUT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THEIR ANCESTORS,
SPECIFICALLY BY FOCUSING ON THE
FOUR FOUNDATIONAL DISCIPLINES OF
ETHNIC STUDIES AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDIES, ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES,
CHICANO LATINO, LATINX STUDIES,
AND NATIVE AMERICAN STUDIES. IN
FACT, RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
STUDENTS FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS DO
BETTER ACADEMICALLY WHEN THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO ETHNIC STUDIES.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DEVELOPED A MODEL
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM GUIDE
TO HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN DEVELOPING
THEIR OWN ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULA AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
THE MODEL ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM GUIDE WAS APPROVED BY
THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION AND STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND FOCUSES ON THE
EXPERIENCES OF THESE FOUR
FOUNDATIONAL GROUPS THAT HAVE
BEEN THE CENTER OF ETHNIC
STUDIES SINCE ITS FOUNDING
AROUND 1968 AT PLACES LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO STATE AND SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITIES. WHILE THE
MODEL ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM
GUIDE PRIMARILY FOCUSES ON THESE
FOUR GROUPS, IT ALSO MAKES A
BRIDGE TO INTERSECTIONALITY AND
THUS INCLUDES SOME LESSON PLANS
AND INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS THAT
INCLUDES SOME OF THE VOICES OF
IDENTITIES INTERSECTING WITH
ETHNIC STUDIES, SUCH AS ARAB
AMERICANS, ARMENIAN AMERICANS,
JEWISH AMERICANS, AND SIKH
AMERICANS. THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAVE ENCOURAGED
DISTRICTS AND CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
FOCUS ON THE FOUR GROUPS AND TO
FOLLOW THE MODEL ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM GUIDE WHEN CREATING
THEIR LOCAL CURRICULA. IT IS FOR
THOSE REASONS THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION SUPPORTS THE GOALS
AND DIRECTION OF THIS BILL, AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB 2918. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS. WELCOME
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
ADRIANA LOMBARD. I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY RELATIONS
COUNCIL IN THE BAY AREA. I WORK
WITH JEWISH STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES IN OVER 120 DISTRICTS,
ACROSS NINE COUNTIES. AND WE
SUPPORT AB 2918 AS A NECESSARY
SET OF CHECKS AND BALANCES FOR
ENSURING THAT ALL ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULA IS FREE OF BIAS AND
ACCURATELY REPRESENTS THE
COMMUNITIES OF CALIFORNIA AS THE
LARGEST REPRESENTATIVE VOICE OF
BAY AREA JEWS, WE HAVE MORE THAN
70 MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS AND WORK
ACROSS THE STATE. WE SUPPORT THE
TEACHING OF ETHNIC STUDIES AND
BELIEVE THAT IT IS ALSO AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO TEACH
BOTH ABOUT JEWISH AMERICAN
HISTORY AND TO EDUCATE ABOUT
ANTI-SEMITISM, A PERVASIVE ISSUE
WHICH HAS BEEN STEADILY ON THE
RISE SINCE 2017 AND LONG BEFORE
THAT, AS WELL. WE SEE THIS BILL
AS NECESSARY FOR TWO REASONS.
ONE IS THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS IN ETHNIC
STUDIES CURRICULUM, AND
SECONDLY, THE PRESENCE OF
ANTI-SEMITIC CONTENT BOTH IN
ETHNIC STUDIES CLASSROOMS. AND
THAT HAS EXISTED IN K-12
EDUCATION SPACES LONG BEFORE
THAT. IN MANY DISTRICTS. WE ARE
SEEING THIS COURSE USED AS A
PLACE TO COVER WHAT'S HAPPENED
SINCE OCTOBER 7TH AND TALK ABOUT
THE CONFLICT, AND THEY'RE
GETTING IT VERY WRONG, TEACHING
VERY ONE SIDED CONTENT AND AT
TIMES USING PROVIDERS WHO HAVE A
HISTORY OF DISPARAGING THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY. TEACHERS ARE
GOING BEYOND THE SCOPE OF THE
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM TO
INCLUDE CLASSIC TROPES THAT ARE
HARMFUL TO THE JEWISH COMMUNITY.
PARENTS ARE REQUESTING MATERIALS
AND BEING IGNORED, AND IN SOME
CASES, THIS HAS LED TO ONGOING
LAWSUITS. IN A SURVEY WE
RECENTLY CONDUCTED OF JEWS IN
THE BAY AREA, 56% OF PEOPLE
SURVEYED SHARED THAT THEY ARE
DISSATISFIED WITH THE WAY THAT
ANTI-SEMITISM IS BEING HANDLED
IN K-12 EDUCATION SETTINGS. AS I
SAID BEFORE, ANTI-SEMITISM HAS
ALREADY EXISTED. SO NOT ONLY IS
ETHNIC STUDIES A CHANCE TO TEACH
ABOUT THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE,
AND THIS VERY UNIQUE FORM OF
HATE THAT WE ARE SEEING, BUT IT
IS ALSO A CHANCE TO ENSURE THAT
THE CURRICULUM THAT COMES UP TO
TEACH ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES DOES
NOT ITSELF CONTAIN ANTI-SEMITIC
CONTENT. AGAIN, AS I SAID,
ANTI-SEMITISM IS A PERVASIVE
ISSUE THAT HAS EXISTED FOR A
VERY LONG TIME, AND WITHOUT
CAREFUL REVIEW OF THE
CURRICULUM, WE ARE SEEING IT IN
ETHNIC STUDIES CLASSROOMS. THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY IS BEING
DISCUSSED WITHOUT BEING
INCLUDED, AND THIS IS CREATING A
HARMFUL ENVIRONMENT WHERE
STUDENTS DO NOT FEEL SAFE
EXPRESSING THEIR IDENTITIES IN
THEIR OWN CLASSROOMS. WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL, AS AMENDED, WILL
CREATE NECESSARY PROCESS FOR
DISTRICTS TO REVIEW NEW AND
EXISTING CURRICULUM, AND WE
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OTHER
WITNESSES. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
MR. CHAIRMAN, CLIFF BURG ON
BEHALF OF JPAC, THE JEWISH
PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE,
REPRESENTING THE LARGEST
COALITION OF JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE NATION, IS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL, AS IS
THE AMERICAN JEWISH COMMITTEE.
THE ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE,
HADASSAH, JCRC, L.A. FEDERATION,
L.A. HOLOCAUST MUSEUM, AND ON
AND ON, THIS BILL HAS THE BROAD
SUPPORT OF EVERY MAJOR JEWISH
ORGANIZATION IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SIR. NEXT,
PLEASE, MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS,
DON GILBERT ON BEHALF OF MYSELF,
AS A RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND, SOMEONE INVOLVED IN
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY HERE,
APPRECIATE YOUR. AYE. VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE, HENRY STERN HERE FROM
LOS ANGELES, SENATOR, WITH YOUR
CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL. AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY, THE HOPE
HERE IS TO NOT POLITICIZE THIS
CURRICULUM AND TO GET SCHOOL,
GIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
ABILITY TO GET PAST THIS VERY
DIFFICULT MOMENT, WE PUT A LOT
OF EFFORT IN THIS MODEL
CURRICULUM, AND WE THINK THAT
THAT'S THE FOUNDATION OF A WAY
THROUGH THIS VERY DIFFICULT TIME
THAT WE CAN TEACH PAST BEING
STRANGERS WITH EACH OTHER. AND
SO I HOPE YOU ALL CONSIDER THIS
AND KEEP GIVING THIS A CHANCE TO
KEEP MOVING FORWARD,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN, ANY
OTHER, WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I
UNDERSTAND, CANDACE YOUNGBLOOD.
PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. CHARISSE
TAYLOR, PUBLIC EDUCATOR AT
BERKELEY. HI. STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, ANNE WOLF, BERKELEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT, JEWISH
PARENTS FOR COLLECTIVE
LIBERATION AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE, MY NAME IS JANINE COHEN.
I'M A BERKELEY RESIDENT, AND I'M
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. I'M ALSO A JEWISH PARENT
FOR COLLECTIVE LIBERATION. THANK
YOU. LISA STUBENRAUCH, ETHNIC
STUDIES TEACHER, SACRAMENTO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
OCTAVIO SOLORIO, RESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO. AND I OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS BELÉN MORENO,
AND I'M A DOCTORAL STUDENT IN
EDUCATION WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ABADIYEV. I AM A PARENT OF TWO
STUDENTS IN BERKELEY, AND I'M
STRONGLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
HELLO. MY NAME IS DOCTOR TAMARA
CHESHER. I'M A NATIVE AMERICAN
STUDIES PROFESSOR AND ETHNIC
STUDIES DEPARTMENT CHAIR AT
FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE, AND I AM
THE CO-CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ETHNIC STUDIES
FACULTY COUNCIL. ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNCIL, WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST, A NO VOTE. WE OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ETHNIC STUDIES FACULTY. WE TEACH
DUAL ENROLLED CLASSES AND THE
PROCESS OUTLINED IN THIS BILL
DOES NOT INCLUDE US AS SCHOLARS
AND EXPERTS IN OUR FOUR CORE
DISCIPLINES. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME
IS MARISSA CASTRO. AS A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND PARENTS
REPRESENTING MY SON, THIS BILL
DOES NOT ALIGN WITH THE
INTERESTS OF PARENTS AND
STUDENTS WHO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A LOCALLY BASED
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM.
THEREFORE, I OPPOSE. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. I SPEAK I BELIEVE
THERE'S SOMEBODY AT THE TABLE
THERE WHO WANTED. WE'RE GOING TO
GET TO HER. WE GOT OUR ORDERS TO
BE VERY CLEAR. WE'RE GOING TO DO
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY. WHAT'S
THAT? THAT IS. THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE, BUT I'M GOING TO
MAKE THE ACCOMMODATION HERE. SO
WE WILL HEAR FROM HER. NO, SIR.
YOU'RE NO, SIR. YOU WEREN'T ON
THE LIST AS AS OPPOSITION
WITNESS. SO GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DAVID MANDEL. I'M A MEMBER OF
JEWISH VOICE FOR PEACE, WITH
100,000 ACTIVE MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL. WE
DON'T ALLOW PEOPLE TO ADD TO
SMALL GROUPS OF PEOPLE TO
ADVOCATE IN FAVOR OF BOOK
BANNING. YOUR POSITION IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. I'M DOCTOR MELISSA
MORENO, AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LATINO SCHOOL
BOARD ASSOCIATION. WE REPRESENT
54% OF THE STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S OUT OF THE 6
MILLION WE HAVE NOT BEEN INVITED
TO THE DISCUSSION WITH THE
LEGISLATORS OF THIS BILL. AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS FOR SEVERAL
REASONS, BECAUSE IT'S A GUIDED
BILL. WE WERE NOT. THANK YOU.
DULY NOTED. THANK YOU. YES, SIR.
SIR STEPHEN FILLING CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND
ANTI-RACIST AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
CENTERED ORGANIZATION, SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN, APOLOGIES AND APOLOGIES
TO THE WITNESS. I DID NOT, I
GUESS, GIVE YOU ENOUGH TIME TO
GET UP HERE. SO YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES
AB 2918, WHICH IS CENTERED ON
COMPLIANCE AND CONTAINMENT AND
DOES NOTHING TO ADVANCE ETHNIC
STUDIES BUT ADD AN ADDITIONAL
LAYER OF STATE OVERSIGHT THAT
SHIFTS CRITICAL DECISION MAKING
FROM LOCAL EDUCATION AUTHORITIES
TO THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
NOT A SINGLE DISTRICT HAS CHOSEN
NOT TO COMPLY WITH THE MODEL
CURRICULUM FOR AN ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSE TO BE APPROVED. LET'S BE
CLEAR NOT ONE, BUT TWO LOCAL
HEARINGS MUST BE HELD.
ADDITIONALLY, ANY CONTRACT AND
THE FINAL CURRICULUM IS ALWAYS
PUBLICLY VETTED AND APPROVED.
LET'S BE CLEAR CHILDREN WHO
ENTER A K-12 CLASSROOMS ARE
SITTING IN THEIR SEATS FOR
12,840 HOURS. ETHNIC STUDIES IS
90 HOURS. OF THAT 12,840 HOURS,
IT'S SEVEN HUNDREDTHS OF THE
CURRICULUM. YET AB 2918 SUGGESTS
THAT THE STUDYING OF FOUR
DISTINCT, DIVERSE,
INTERSECTIONAL AND RACIALIZED
COMMUNITIES AND DISCIPLINES MUST
THEN ADD AN ADDITIONAL HURDLE
TOWARDS IMPLEMENTATION. THE
PROVISION TO POST ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM ONLINE WILL EXPOSE
DISTRICTS TO INCREASE HARASSMENT
AND LITIGATION. THE LACK OF
CLARITY IN DEFINING WHAT
CURRICULUM AND INSTRUCTION
MATERIALS ARE WILL LEAVE OUR
TEACHERS VULNERABLE TO
UNWARRANTED SCRUTINY. HOW MANY
MORE LAWSUITS? HOW MANY MORE
DISTRICT PARAS? HOW MANY MORE
RUINED REPUTATIONS AND LOSS OF
JOBS DO WE NEED TO HAVE BEFORE
WE STOP THE BILL'S VAGUE
LANGUAGE ON FACTUAL ACCURACY
ADDS AN ADDITIONAL LEVEL OF
CONCERN. WHO GETS TO DETERMINE
WHAT'S FACTUAL AND ACCURATE? AND
ISN'T THAT WHAT ETHNIC STUDIES
WAS PURPORTING TO DO TO CORRECT
THE ERASURE AND THE INVISIBILITY
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR IN OUR
CURRICULUM, ASK YOU TO FINISH.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO FIX PROBLEMS
NOT IN ETHNIC STUDIES, BUT IN
THE CURRICULAR AND INSTRUCTIONAL
ISSUES EMBEDDED THROUGHOUT OUR
CURRICULUM. IF IT IS EXTREMISM,
IF IT IS DIVERSITY AND EQUITY
THAT WE ARE PURPORTING TO
ADDRESS THIS BILL, IS NOT IT
SINGLING OUT ETHNIC STUDIES
EDUCATORS DOES NOT ENHANCE OUR
EDUCATIONAL CLIMATE. THAT'S WHAT
WE WANT TO DO. AND LET'S BRING
ALL PARTIES TO THE TABLE. LET'S
ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES. LET'S BEGIN
TO ADDRESS THE EXTREMISM IN OUR
SCHOOLS. PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB
2918. THANK YOU. AND PLEASE DO
STAY AT THE TABLE FOR THE
CONVERSATION, OTHER. LET'S JUST
LAST CHANCE TO ANY OTHER
WITNESSES. ME TWO WITNESSES
REPORT AND I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
TWO WIENER WITNESSES. SO
TWEENERS HERE. WELCOME, SIR.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. SETH BRAMBLE, SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. CTA IS A
SOCIAL JUSTICE ORGANIZATION. AND
TO US, THAT MEANS WE'RE IN AN
ORGANIZATION THAT'S COMMITTED TO
EQUITY AND FAIRNESS IN TREATMENT
AND ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITIES AND
RESOURCES FOR EVERYONE. WE
SPONSORED ASSEMBLY BILL 101 IN
2021 TO ESTABLISH A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT IN ETHNIC
STUDIES, IN PART BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA HAS PERHAPS THE MOST
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATION IN
THE NATION, AND WE SUPPORTED
RELATED ETHNIC STUDIES
LEGISLATION PRIOR, WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE BEEN LEFT
OUT IN THE STORIES OF HOW OUR
COUNTRY HAS BEEN GOVERNED. WE
WANT TO CULTIVATE A CLASSROOM
ENVIRONMENT THAT CELEBRATES OUR
DIVERSITY BY TEACHING AN
INCLUSIVE CURRICULUM OF ALL OUR
CULTURES AND BACKGROUNDS,
ENABLING STUDENTS TO BE MORE
ENGAGED AND INFORMED. MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES, ESPECIALLY IN
THE FIGHT FOR RACIAL JUSTICE AND
EQUITY. WHEN KIDS TAKE ETHNIC
STUDIES, IT HAS POSITIVE EFFECTS
ON OVERALL ACHIEVEMENT. ETHNIC
STUDIES FACILITATES ENGAGEMENT
AND ACADEMIC SKILLS RELATED TO
THE STUDY OF RACE AND EQUITY,
WIDENING CULTURAL AWARENESS AND
STRENGTHENING KNOWLEDGE OF THE
FOUNDATIONAL IDEALS OF EQUALITY
UPON WHICH OUR DEMOCRACY IS
BUILT. CTA BELIEVES THAT WE HAVE
A DUTY TO TEACH OUR YOUTH ABOUT
THEIR ANCESTRAL LEGACIES, AND
THAT IT'S THE RIGHT OF ALL
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
ACCESS TO A QUALITY ETHNIC
STUDIES CURRICULUM. JUST WANT TO
SAY WE'RE EAGER TO SUPPORT ANY
PROPOSALS WHICH IMPROVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF ETHNIC STUDIES
INSTRUCTION IN OUR STATE. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS THAT WE SEE IN THE
BILL, AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. WE
WILL NEED TO REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN IN
COMMITTEE TODAY, AND WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR ALSO FOR TAKING
AN AMENDMENT INTO THE BILL EARLY
ON. THAT IS VERY CLOSELY ALIGNED
WITH OUR POLICY, WHICH STATES
CTA BELIEVES TEACHERS SHOULD
HAVE THE CENTRAL ROLE IN THE
DEVELOPMENT, DEFINITION AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF CURRICULUM AND
SHOULD COMPROMISE A MAJORITY OF
ALL COMMITTEES MAKING OR
RECOMMENDING DECISIONS IN THE
AREA. THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY, MR. CHAIR.
THANK YOU, MR. MACHADO. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CARLOS MACHADO,
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION, WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HIS AVAILABILITY
AND FOR MEETING WITH US AND
REALLY ACCOMMODATING
CONVERSATIONS AND QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE INTENT AND THE
PROVISIONS. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK, MR. HAMPTON FOR HIS,
CONSIDERABLE WORK IN TRYING TO
FIND SOLUTIONS TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THE AUTHOR AND ALSO
ADDRESS CONCERNS OF STAKEHOLDERS,
AS ASSEMBLYWOMAN ADDIS HAD
MENTIONED, IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET
THIS RIGHT. THIS PROCESS WILL
APPLY TO ALL OF THE, 940
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE. AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE AREN'T
MANY OPPORTUNITIES LEFT TO,
DISCUSS THE BILL AND ITS
PROVISIONS IN THIS COMMITTEE, WE
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AS THE BILL MOVES
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE THROUGH
THE HOUSE. SECOND HOUSE, SCHOOL
BOARDS ARE COMMITTED TO ENSURING
THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
ETHNIC STUDIES AND THEY SEE THE
VALUE IN IN TAILORING THOSE
ETHNIC STUDIES TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND THAT, YOU WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
PRESERVE THAT ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO TAILOR THOSE COURSES TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE,
SPECIFICALLY ON THE
CERTIFICATION THAT'S IN THE
BILL, BY REQUIRING THE
SIGNATURES OF INDIVIDUAL BOARD
MEMBERS, DOESN'T REFLECT THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS THAT
HAPPENS AT DISTRICTS AND WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S ALIGNED
WITH, THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED UNDER AB 1078, AGAIN, WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FLEXIBILITY IS BUILT INTO THE
BILL, ESPECIALLY FOR RURAL AND
SMALL DISTRICTS WHERE THERE
MIGHT NOT BE WITNESSES
AVAILABLE, COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS OR PARENTS, TO
MEET THE REQUIREMENT THAT THEY
BE PART OF THAT PROCESS, THAT I
HAVE TO ASK YOU TO ANSWER, AND
THEN ALSO ABOUT THE IMPACT ON
EXISTING COURSES, SCHOOLS HAVE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME DEVELOPING
THOSE COURSES. WE DON'T WANT TO
ADD NEW REQUIREMENTS UPON THEM,
AND THEN ALSO, IF YOU'RE
ENCOURAGING, DISTRICTS TO USE
THE MODEL CURRICULUM, THEN THERE
SHOULD BE, THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO USE THE EXISTING PROCESS
THAT'S IN STATUTE. I APPRECIATE
THE TIME. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE CONTINUE. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU, MR. BROWN. LET'S SEE
IF YOU CAN, I'LL TRY TO BEAT THE
SHOT CLOCK, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME. TRISTAN BROWN,
CFT, A UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS, ECHO
THE COMMENTS YOU JUST HEARD FROM
THE OTHER TWEENERS. WE
UNDERSTAND IT IS REPUGNANT TO A
FREE AND OPEN SOCIETY FOR A
CLASSROOM TO ENTERTAIN THE IDEA
THAT FOR INSTANCE, THE HOLOCAUST
NEVER EXISTED. THIS SIMPLY
CANNOT STAND, AND WE AGREE WITH
THE OVERALL GOAL OF THIS BILL
THAT THE QUALITY OF ETHNIC
STUDIES MUST BE MAINTAINED AT A
AT A VERY HIGH RATE, AS HIGH AS
WE CAN GET IT. WHAT WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH ARE THE PROCESS TO
GET THERE. WE HAVE CHIEF
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DOXING AND
TARGETING OF THOSE INVOLVED IN
THIS PROCESS. THROUGHOUT ITS
PROCESS, WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
INSULAR COMMUNITIES AS THE BILL
IS WRITTEN, WHO MAY CREATE
OUTCOMES THAT ARE NOT INTENDED.
AND SO WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERN ABOUT THESE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF WHERE THE
PROCESS MIGHT LEAD. AGAIN, WE'RE
SUPER HOPEFUL TO LAND THIS PLANE
WORKING WITH THE GREAT COAUTHORS
WHO HAVE BEEN VERY OPEN AND
HONEST WITH US AS WE ARE TO
THEM. AND WE THINK THAT THERE IS
A THERE THERE AND THAT WE CAN
HAVE HIGH QUALITY ETHNIC
STUDIES, AND MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY COMMUNITY CAN CUSTOMIZE
THE HIGH QUALITY RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND AVOID ANY
CONFLICT AND FIGHTING ABOUT WHAT
IS FACTUALLY AND HISTORICALLY
ACCURATE AND THE LIKE. SO WE
THANK YOU AND THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE INCREDIBLE WORK OF YOUR
STAFF FOR GETTING US TO THIS
POINT. SO DON'T TRY THAT NICE
STUFF AT THE END, BECAUSE YOU
DID NOT BEAT THE SHOT CLOCK. BUT
I APPRECIATE THE Tê WIENER
TESTIMONY. I THINK. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT, SEEING NONE, NO
OTHERS. LET'S COME TO THE
MEMBERS. MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
SENATOR GLAZER THANK YOU. CHAIR.
WELL, FIRST, LET ME THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURR AND ADDIS
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
IT'S NOT AN EASY BILL TO CARRY.
I APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT YOU AND YOUR STAFF HAVE PUT
IN ON IT. IT'S I KNOW THAT, YOU
KNOW, BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMIND THOSE WHO ARE HERE TODAY
AND ARE LISTENING THAT ETHNIC
STUDIES IS A PRODUCT OF
LEGISLATIVE ACTION. IT IS
BECAUSE WE FELT IT WAS IMPORTANT
THAT IT BE A PART OF THE
CURRICULUM, THAT THAT BILL MOVED
AND WAS PASSED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE, AND I SUPPORTED IT.
BUT IT IT WAS A SENSITIVE, ROAD
BECAUSE EXACTLY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
ADDRESS, WHICH IS THAT THAT
SOMEHOW IT MIGHT BE USED TO
BRING IN BIAS AND BIGOTRY AND
DISCRIMINATION INTO OUR
CLASSROOMS, SOMETHING THAT WE
ALL ABHOR, AND IT'S, IT'S, BUT
YET THE, THE GOALS THAT WERE SET
AS ESTABLISHED FROM THE
BEGINNING ARE ALL THE GOALS THAT
WE EMBRACE. STUDENTS NEED TO
LEARN ABOUT THE NARRATIVES,
SOMETIMES ABOUT THEM, SOMETIMES
ABOUT THE WORLD AROUND THEM. AND
THAT THAT, THAT THAT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT, FUNDAMENTAL THING TO.
TO HAVE REQUIRED THIS MANDATE.
BUT ONCE AGAIN, THE CONCERN WAS
THAT IT WOULD BE USED BY,
ELEMENTS TO PROMOTE BIAS,
BIGOTRY AND DISCRIMINATION. AND
THAT HAS HAPPENED BECAUSE NOW WE
SEE IN PRACTICE, PARTICULARLY
FOR THOSE OF US IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY, TO SEE HOW, IN MY
VIEW, BAD ACTORS HAVE THE
PROCESS TO PROMOTE A CURRICULUM
THAT DOES THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
THE GOALS THAT WE HAD
ESTABLISHED BY, BY THAT BILL. SO
I THINK THAT THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE. I THINK IT WILL
STRENGTHEN AND PROTECT ETHNIC
STUDIES BY ENSURING COMMUNITY
VOICES ARE PRESENT, BY
PROTECTING AGAINST THE ELEMENTS
THAT WANT TO CAPTURE THAT
CURRICULUM, TO PROMOTE THE
OPPOSITE, IGNORANCE, BIGOTRY AND
BIAS. I KNOW THAT THERE'S STILL
WORK TO BE DONE. AS YOU AS THE
AUTHORS HAVE INDICATED, I
CERTAINLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THAT, AS I HOPE THE BILL WILL
MOVE FORWARD TODAY. THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD ON A
COAUTHOR. I'D BE APPRECIATIVE OF
THAT OPPORTUNITY. I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. APPRECIATE THAT. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU, I TOO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR. WE HAD A
VERY, VERY GOOD DISCUSSION LAST
NIGHT. I KNOW, AND HAVING AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. SO HAVING
BEEN LIGHTLY PART OF THE LAST
ITERATION OF AB 101 THROUGH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE MEDINA, WHO
I PERSONALLY CALLED, AND I KNOW
YOU PERSONALLY CALLED AS WELL TO
ENSURE THAT WE WERE ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH HIM. HE I WILL SAY,
AND I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK OUT OF
TURN HERE, BUT THERE WERE
FEELINGS OF UPSETNESS A BIT
BECAUSE OF THE WAY AND THE
PROCESS AND HOW THIS HAPPENED. I
AGREE WITH SOME OF THE COMMENTS
HERE THAT THIS SHOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN A GUT AND AMEND. YOU KNOW,
THIS SHOULD HAVE HAD A FULL
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND I GET IT
COMPLETELY GET IT. THIS IS
TIMELY. IT'S IMPORTANT. BUT THE
LATINO CAUCUS MEMBERS, TO WHICH
I'M A VICE CHAIR OF, I YOU KNOW,
I HAVE TO SPEAK FOR THEM, TOO.
AND MANY OF OUR ALUMNI TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS A FULL PROCESS AND
THAT WE ARE CONTINUING TO BE ARM
IN ARM WITH YOU IN THIS
DISCUSSION, BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT. THAT'S THE
NUMBER ONE THING IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS. AND I KNOW YOU WILL
TALK AND WE TALKED AT LENGTH
ABOUT THE REVIEW PROCESS, YOU
KNOW, IN MY COMMUNITY, I'VE GOT
A LOT OF, CONCERNS LAST NIGHT
FROM MANY OF MY SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES, MOSTLY LATINO,
TEACHERS, SOME PART OF UTLA,
SOME NOT TALKING ABOUT OF
COURSE, THE FACTUAL ACCURACY,
WHICH HAD BEEN MENTIONED AND THE
POSTING ONLINE AND I YOU KNOW, I
THINK THOSE ARE THINGS THAT CAN
ABSOLUTELY BE WORKED ON. AND I
LIKE WHAT OUR FRIEND TRISTAN
HERE FROM CFT HAD MENTIONED. YOU
KNOW, THAT THIS WE KNOW WE CAN
GET SOMEWHERE. THESE NEED TO BE
ANSWERED. THERE NEEDS TO BE A
LOT MORE DUE DILIGENCE IN TERMS
OF MEETING WITH FOLKS. I
SPECIFICALLY ASKED YOU IF YOU
COULD MEET WITH, YOU KNOW,
SOUTHEAST LA REPRESENTATIVES
THAT I KNOW HAVE A VOICE AND
WANT A VOICE AT THE TABLE AND
NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE INSTANCES
TO WHICH THIS, YOU KNOW, HAS
BEEN A REAL PROBLEM. AND I'VE
TALKED TO SENATOR BECKER ABOUT
WHAT THAT PROBLEM LOOKS LIKE IN
HIS COMMUNITY WITH HIS KIDS AND,
YOU KNOW, CURRICULUM COMING,
SEEMINGLY NO DISRESPECT, BUT OUT
OF NOWHERE AND KNOWING THAT HIS
KIDS ARE LEARNING THIS AND
REALIZING THAT THIS HAD NOT BEEN
VETTED BEFORE, BUT ALSO NOT
HAVING VOICES AT THE TABLE. SO I
THINK WE'RE IN A, IN A SPACE
HERE WHERE I THINK WE CAN WORK
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD. I'M NOT
HAPPY WITH THE CURRENT LANGUAGE,
BUT I WOULD BE HAPPY SUPPORTING
IT, KNOWING THAT YOU HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO AND I'M HAPPY TO
DO THAT WORK WITH YOU NOW, YOU
DID BRING UP A GOOD POINT LAST
NIGHT AS WELL, WHICH I REALLY AM
THANKFUL OF, AND I THINK NEEDS
TO BE BROUGHT UP, IS THE I WOULD
LOVE TO ASK YOU, THE LGBTQ, FAIR
ACT, A BILL BROUGHT FORWARD BY
THEN SENATOR LENO, I BELIEVE,
AND HOW THAT SORT OF IS PARALLEL
AND SIMILAR TO THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND WHY THAT'S
IMPORTANT, YOU KNOW. SO, I
REMEMBER WHEN I WAS AT EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA, WHEN THE FAIR ACT
WAS BEING IMPLEMENTED, AND THAT
WAS A BILL THAT REQUIRED THAT
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF LGBTQ
PEOPLE AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
WERE REFLECTED IN OUR HISTORY
AND SOCIAL STUDIES CURRICULUM.
AND I REMEMBER THAT ONE OF THE
FIRST TASKS THAT I HAD WAS
ACTUALLY TRYING TO FIND FUNDING
SO THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY REVIEW
EVERY SINGLE TEXTBOOK AND ALL
THE INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS THAT
COULD BE OFFERED UNDER THAT
PROGRAM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, AND SO I THINK THE
THING THAT IS, YOU KNOW, I THINK
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT
ETHNIC STUDIES, WELL, FOLKS ARE
BASICALLY, YOU KNOW, RAISING
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
THIS IS PRESENTING OBSTACLES TO,
TO ETHNIC STUDIES. I THINK
PEOPLE SHOULD UNDERSTAND THAT
THE PROCEDURES THAT ARE AND
PROCESSES THAT ARE THAT TAKE
PLACE FOR MOST OTHER CURRICULUM,
MANY OTHER CURRICULUM DO NOT
APPLY TO ETHNIC STUDIES. SO, SO
WHILE WE HAD THE MODEL
CURRICULUM DEVELOPED,
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS, ALL THE
DETAILS WITHIN IT ARE NOT. AND
THAT IS ACTUALLY LEFT TO THE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. SO, SO,
YOU KNOW, THIS IS SOMETHING
WHERE, AND EVEN WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE TRANSPARENCY PROCEDURES THAT
ARE IN THIS BILL, AND I KNOW WE
STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO
ON THAT, I'M NOT SAYING THAT
THESE ARE PERFECT, BUT WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO WORK WITH, WITH
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THEM,
THE INSTRUCTOR, THE TRANSPARENCY
PROCEDURES WE'VE TRIED TO MAKE
AS CONSISTENT AS POSSIBLE WITH
THE LOWER LEVEL OF REVIEW THAT
IS APPLICABLE IN CASES TO SOME
OTHER KINDS OF CURRICULUM THAT
DON'T GO THROUGH THE FULL. THE
FULL SET OF REVIEW BY THE STATE
BOARD AND OTHER AND
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMITTEE.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARDIS WANTS TO ADD
ANYTHING MORE TO THAT RESPONSE.
BUT BUT BUT I JUST REMEMBER WE
HAD LITERALLY I REMEMBER ON THE
FAIR EDUCATION ACT HAVING A BODY
OF PEOPLE WHERE WE REVIEWED, I
THINK SOMETHING LIKE 600
TEXTBOOKS, INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS, SEVEN DIFFERENT
VERSIONS AT EVERY GRADE LEVEL.
YOU KNOW, NONE OF THAT HAS
HAPPENED HERE. SO WE'RE LEAVING
THIS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON
THEIR OWN. AND THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR IS REALLY
JUST TO HAVE SOME LEVEL OF
ABILITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S ALL
COMMUNITIES TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT'S BEING, BECAUSE THIS IS
SUCH IMPORTANT MATERIAL THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT. YEAH THANK YOU.
AND I THINK, OH, GO AHEAD,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'LL JUST ADD
BRIEFLY, HAVING BEEN PART OF A
VERY INITIAL ROLLOUT OF ETHNIC
STUDIES, BOOTS ON THE GROUND,
WHEN I WAS WORKING IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT, WHICH WASN'T THAT LONG
AGO, UP UNTIL THE DAY BEFORE I
WAS SWORN IN, WAS DOING THAT
WORK. AND, YOU KNOW, ONE OF THE
THINGS WITH THE FAIR ACT, AS
WELL AS WITH ETHNIC STUDIES IS
THERE'S MODEL CURRICULUM.
THERE'S LEGISLATION, THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY A FRAMEWORK OR
STANDARDS, WHICH IS WHAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS USUALLY ARE ABLE TO
BASE THINGS IN. AND SO WITHOUT
THOSE GUIDEPOSTS AND WITH
SOMETHING THAT IS RELATIVELY
NEW, IT MAKES SENSE TO ME THAT
WE WOULD NEED TO REVISIT POINT
WELL TAKEN ON WHO NEEDS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AND ABSOLUTELY, THE LATINO
CAUCUS NEEDS TO BE INCLUDED IN
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHY WE'D LIKE TO HAVE
SOME MORE TIME OVER THE RECESS
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
PIECE AND HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS, BUT IT MAKES
SENSE TO ME THAT WE WOULD BE
COMING BACK TO THESE
CONVERSATIONS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE AS ROBUST OF A SITUATION IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS BOOTS ON
THE GROUND THAT WE DO WITH SOME
OTHER CURRICULUMS. RIGHT?
THERE'S HISTORY, STANDARDS AND
FRAMEWORKS, ELA, ELD STANDARDS
AND FRAMEWORKS, ETC. SO, I JUST
WOULD ECHO WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ZABIR HAS SAID THAT IT DOES TAKE
A LOT OF FINE TOOTH COMB WORK TO
GO THROUGH TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT, AND THAT SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BROUGHT UP,
WE'VE BEEN IN MANY, MANY
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
TRANSPARENCY, THE FACTUAL AND
HISTORICALLY ACCURATE AND VERY
COMMITTED TO GETTING THAT PIECE
OF IT RIGHT. AND TO HAVING MORE
EXTENDED CONVERSATIONS. WELL, I
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE,
I THINK I MENTIONED, OH, OH,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO, YOU KNOW, YOU
FINISH AND THEN WE'LL, WE'LL IF
YOU WANT TO, WE CAN GO RIGHT
AHEAD. I WAS JUST GOING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
STANDARDS, BECAUSE THAT HAS COME
UP. AND I THINK THAT THOSE OF US
WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CURRICULUM COULD
EASILY ANSWER THIS QUESTION,
ETHNIC STUDIES IS
INTERDISCIPLINARY, AND IT IS
MULTIDISCIPLINARY, RIGHT? SO
WHEN WE DEVELOP CURRICULUM, IT
IS THE STANDARDS THAT, THAT
DRIVE THE CURRICULUM ARE THE
STANDARDS IN THAT DISCIPLINE
PLUS THE MODEL CURRICULUM. SO
YOU HAVE SIX GUIDING PRINCIPLES
IN THE MODEL CURRICULUM THAT
DRIVE THE CURRICULUM. BUT IF I'M
DEVELOPING A US HISTORY COURSE,
THEN I, AS A TEACHER, MUST
UNDERSTAND THAT I AM ADDRESSING
THE US SOCIAL SCIENCE STANDARDS
IN DEVELOPING THAT LESSON. IF
I'M DEVELOPING A THEATER COURSE
USING ETHNIC STUDIES, THEN I'M
GOING TO USE THOSE STANDARDS TO
DEVELOP MY COURSE. SO WHEN WE
WERE HAVING THE CONVERSATION ON
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL ABOUT THE
ADOPTION OF ETHNIC STUDIES
STANDARDS, IT WOULD BE
RELATIVELY IMPOSSIBLE BECAUSE
WHAT YOU WOULD BE DOING IS
BRINGING IN ALL OF THE
DISCIPLINES AND THEN TRYING TO
THINK ABOUT WHICH STANDARD
APPLIES. SO THE STANDARDS ARE
THERE, THEY'RE CURRICULAR
STANDARDS THAT ARE ADDRESSED
ALONG WITH THE MODEL CURRICULUM.
SO IT'S NOT A LACK OF STANDARDS,
IT'S NOT THE NEED FOR STANDARDS.
AND I DO KNOW THAT THIS IS
DIFFICULT FOR SOMEONE WHO HASN'T
BEEN IN THE FIELD AND THAT
DOESN'T RECOGNIZE THE FOUR
DISCIPLINES OR WHAT COMPRISES
ETHNIC STUDIES. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONVERSATION TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE,
MISINTERPRETED IDEAS ABOUT
WHAT'S NEEDED AND WHAT'S MISSING
FROM THE MODEL CURRICULUM OR THE
STANDARD DISCUSSION. WELL, I, I
JUST OH, DID YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND RESPOND? YES. AND I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH ANY OF THAT.
I GUESS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS, YOU
KNOW, THAT COMPLEXITY I THINK,
IS ONE WHERE WE'VE GOT STANDARDS
IN ALL OF THE VARIOUS
DISCIPLINES AND THEN SORT OF THE
FRAMEWORK, THE RESULT OF THAT IS
THAT'S VERY COMPLICATED. AND
WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY GOING
THROUGH THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS, THAT'S
ACTUALLY HAVING TO HAPPEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AS OPPOSED TO
SOMETHING THAT'S GONE THROUGH A
PROCESS AT THE STATE LEVEL. AND
SO OUR BILL DOESN'T ACTUALLY DO
ANYTHING WITH RESPECT TO THE
STANDARDS. ALL IT REALLY DOES IS
IT ACTUALLY ADDS TRANSPARENCY
PROCEDURES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHAT'S BEING
ADOPTED. THEY'RE ALREADY THERE.
OKAY. LET ME LET ME NOTE JUST
FOR CLARITY HERE, THAT THAT PER
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS, WE
THE REQUIREMENT FOR FACTUAL AND
HISTORICALLY ACCURATE HAS BEEN
REMOVED. THAT'S BEEN REMOVED, AS
HAS THE REQUIREMENT FOR SELF
CERTIFICATION. YES. WE THAT
WE'VE ACCEPTED THOSE UNDERSTOOD.
I JUST IT CAN GET A LITTLE BIT
UNCLEAR AS PEOPLE AND I THINK WE
THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT, ABOUT
SORT OF SOME OF THOSE
TRANSPARENCY DETAILS. BUT AGAIN,
THOSE, THOSE, THOSE ISSUES HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED IN YOUR. I
APPRECIATE THAT. I ACCEPT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY'S
CLEAR ON KIND OF WHERE WE ARE
THERE. MEMBERS. MISTER CHAIR, I
JUST WANTED TO SAY I JUST WANTED
TO FINISH AND SAY THANK YOU. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS DEBATE
BACK AND FORTH, BECAUSE I THINK
EVERYBODY IS MAKING REALLY
RELEVANT COMMENTS. AND, I WENT
THROUGH THE CAMBODIAN MODEL
CURRICULUM JUST RECENTLY. SO
IT'S A FRESH OFF THE PRESSES IN
MY MIND AS TO HOW, DIFFICULT AND
RIGOROUS IT COULD BE, BUT THAT
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE AT THE
TABLE. BUT WE ARE AT A DIFFERENT
TIME NOW GEOPOLITICALLY. AND I
GET THAT, THAT THERE'S, YOU
KNOW, OTHER FACTORS TO CONSIDER.
AND SO WE HAVE TO BE OPEN TO
THAT, EVEN DESPITE, YOU KNOW,
THE ETHNIC STUDIES FRAMEWORK.
AND I KNOW THAT WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AGAIN, URGING THE LATINO CAUCUS
TO BE INVOLVED. THERE WERE OTHER
FOLKS THAT WERE HERE IN THE,
HERE IN THIS ROOM THAT
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO BE AT THE
TABLE OPPOSITION, AND JUST
ENSURING THAT THERE'S A PATHWAY
FORWARD. BUT, YOU KNOW, STILL
DISCUSSIONS TO BE HAD. THE ONE
LAST THING I'D MENTION THAT THE
POSTING ONLINE ISSUE WAS THAT
ADDRESSED BECAUSE IT WAS JUST A
SELF-CERTIFICATION. SO, I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE, I CAN'T REMEMBER
WHETHER IT'S IN THE, IN THE
AMENDMENTS, BUT THAT'S I KNOW IS
AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO WORK
ON. AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT. WE, WE THINK THAT REALLY
ALL OF THE, THE, THE ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED BY FOLKS IN THE
EDUCATION COMMUNITY ARE VALID
ONES, AND WE AND WE THINK THESE
ISSUES OF DOXING AND ARE REAL
ONES THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS,
AND WE'RE JUST COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT. THAT IS A VERY REAL
ISSUE. YES. DISCUSSED. SO, I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU. AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO TALKING TO
EVERYBODY ABOUT THIS. LOOKING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. AND I GUESS
TO SENATOR GONZALES POINT, AS WE
MOVE FORWARD, THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPLEXITY HERE. THERE IS. AND
THERE'S ADDITIONAL WORK THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY NEEDED, ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS, CONSULTATIONS
OBVIOUSLY NEEDED. SENATOR CORTEZ,
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS, I
CERTAINLY HAVE CONCERNS. AND I
WOULD SAY, YOU KNOW, IN A BROAD
BRUSH WAY, THE CONCERNS OF THE
TWEENERS THAT WE HEARD WHICH
WERE ENUMERATED BULLET POINT
AFTER BULLET POINT AFTER BULLET
POINT, YOU KNOW, I SHARE
COMPLETELY AND I THINK, YOU
KNOW, SOME SOME ADDITIONAL TO
ADDITIONAL TO THAT IS, WELL,
WHICH RAISES THE QUESTION THAT I
HAVE FOR THE AUTHOR. AND THEN I
HAVE A QUESTION OR TWO FOR, FOR
THE WITNESSES HERE. THERE'S A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT REACHING OUT,
YOU KNOW, TO STAKEHOLDERS. I
WILL STIPULATE, FIRST OF ALL,
THAT, THE, THE ANTI-SEMITISM
THAT WE'VE SEEN, THE
ANTI-SEMITIC, ENVIRONMENT, THE
MOOD THAT WE'VE SEEN, IN
CALIFORNIA, IN THE COUNTRY IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND IT NEEDS TO
CONTINUE TO BE ADDRESSED. SO I
COMMEND YOU FOR STEPPING INTO
THAT. THAT VERY SPECIFIC SPACE
HERE. WHEN WE TAKE THIS ME
TALKING NOW, WE TAKE THIS BROAD
BRUSH TO ETHNIC STUDIES, WHICH
IS A STATE WIDE FRAMEWORK. IT'S
STATEWIDE LAW. IT'S NOT ABOUT
JUST ONE ETHNIC GROUP OR ONE
CONCERN THAT WE'RE THAT WE'RE
SEEING SPIKE RIGHT NOW. IT
STRIKES ME THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO CHANGE THE WAY WE DEAL WITH
IT, WE HAVE TO THEN IN ORDER TO
GET TO THIS ISSUE AND OTHERS, WE
HAVE A LOT OF GROUND TO COVER AS
EVERYONE'S SAYING. BUT THAT'S
THAT'S THE NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. THAT'S THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY, THAT IS THE
LATINO COMMUNITY. WE JUST HEARD
THAT, IT GOES ON AND ON AND ON.
WE HAVE 100 DIFFERENT CULTURES
AND SUBCULTURES. PLUS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY, ACTUALLY OVER 100
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AND DIALECTS
SPOKEN JUST IN THAT COUNTY
ALONE. I JUST I JUST MET WITH
THE, CONSUL GENERAL OF
INDONESIA, WHO'S 500 NATIVE
INDONESIANS LIVING PERMANENTLY
NOW IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY, I
WILL THROW IN THE ITALIAN
AMERICANS, MY, MY HERITAGE, ONLY
TO MAKE A POINT THAT I WAS IN A
CLASSROOM MYSELF WHERE A STUDENT
WHO WAS NOT ITALIAN AMERICAN
ASKED THE QUESTION ABOUT THE
WORLD WAR TWO INTERNMENT OF
ITALIAN AMERICANS AND ASKED THE
PROFESSOR TO COMPARE THAT TO THE
JAPANESE INTERNMENT. IT WAS IT
WAS GIVEN THE MOST. UNACCEPTABLE
RESPONSE. THAT YOU COULD
POSSIBLY IMAGINE IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO EXPLAIN ITALIAN
AMERICAN ACCEPTANCE OF BEING PUT
IN THAT POSITION? YEAH I WILL
NOT REPEAT WHAT HE SAID FOR THE
SAKE OF TRANSPARENCY, BECAUSE I
DO NOT WANT TO FURTHER TAINT MY
OWN HERITAGE BY WHAT SOMEBODY
WHO WAS UNQUALIFIED TO TEACH
PROBABLY SAID IN THAT
ENVIRONMENT. BUT WOULD I GO
WRITE A BILL AND TRY TO CAPTURE
ALL SUCH VILLAINS OUT THERE WITH
A SINGLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION?
IN MY MIND, I THINK NOT. I THINK
THERE HAS TO BE ANOTHER WAY TO
GET TO THAT PERSON. I THINK THE
DEAN OF THAT SCHOOL SHOULD HAVE
TAKEN CARE OF THAT PERSON UPON
COMPLAINT, AND THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN. AND IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
SOMETIMES THAT WE KNOW, BUT
BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF THIS
SESSION, I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW YOU GET THERE IN
TERMS OF BRINGING ALL THAT IN.
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO SEE ME
CAST, YOU KNOW, SORT OF A
COURTESY VOTE TODAY, YOU KNOW,
TO LET THE BILL MOVE ON. MY
CONCERN ABOUT THAT IS IF I DO
THAT, IT DOESN'T HAVE AN
ASTERISK NEXT TO IT. WHEN I SAY
I, IT SAYS I'M ENDORSING WHAT'S
HERE TODAY. AND WHAT CAN BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH THIS BILL. AND
I DON'T KNOW HOW I DO THAT,
GIVEN WHAT I KNOW ABOUT HOW MUCH
REACH THERE NEEDS TO BE IN THE
OUTREACH REMAINING FOR THIS
BILL. BUT I WANT TO GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY WHATEVER YOUR
RIGHT, SENATOR, OR YOU'RE WRONG.
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET IT
DONE BECAUSE IN THE NEXT, YOU
KNOW, 35, 45 DAYS, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS
COMPREHENSIVE OUTREACH. YEAH. I
MEAN, I THINK IF WE WERE
BASICALLY GOING THROUGH AND
SAYING, LOOK, WE NEED TO SORT OF
REEVALUATE THE FRAMEWORK. WE
NEED TO DEVELOP INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS, WE NEED TO SORT OF
GET INTO SORT OF WHAT IS BEING
TAUGHT. THOSE ARE SO COMPLICATED
AND SENSITIVE AND NEED TO BRING
SO MANY STAKEHOLDERS TO THE
TABLE. I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU
WITH THAT. BUT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY, AND WE KNOW
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS UNDER
THE MODEL CURRICULUM, AS WELL AS
THEIR OWN ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES. AND THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN. AND WE HAVE
A REAL, VERY REAL PROBLEM. I
MEAN, IT'S NOT AND IT'S YOU
KNOW, I CAN'T TELL YOU THE
NUMBER THE NUMBER OF CALLS I GET
FROM FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT WHO
ARE IN NETWORKS WITH, WITH WITH
PARENTS ACROSS THE STATE WHERE
THIS IS HAPPENING IN MANY, MANY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. SO IT'S
SOMETHING WHERE, THIS DOESN'T
THIS IS INTENDED TO EMBRACE
ETHNIC STUDIES, TO UPLIFT ETHNIC
STUDIES. WE'RE NOT CHANGING
ANYTHING IN TERMS OF THE GOALS
OR THE CRITERIA OF ETHNIC
STUDIES. WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE JUST PROVIDING
TRANSPARENCY SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
KNOW WHAT'S HAPPENING AND THEY
CAN ACTUALLY PARTICIPATE IN IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND RAISE
CONCERNS IF THEY HAVE THEM, AND
SO I THINK WE CAN DO IT. I
THINK, I THINK WE CAN HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF WORK OVER
THE COURSE OF THE BREAK. AND THE
FIRST, YOU KNOW, WEEK OR TWO IN
AUGUST. BUT I'M I BELIEVE THAT
GIVEN THAT THE BILL IS SO
LIMITED AND ONLY RELATES TO
THESE TRANSPARENCY PROCEDURES, I
BELIEVE WE CAN GET THERE. I
DON'T KNOW IF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS WANTS TO ADD ANYTHING. I
GUESS I WOULD JUST ADD THAT, YOU
KNOW, WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS, HE HAS BEEN TIRELESS,
AS HAS OUR CAUCUS, HAVE BEEN
TIRELESS IN TRYING TO DO THE
KIND OF OUTREACH THAT IS NEEDED
FOR A TOPIC THAT'S AS IMPORTANT
AS THIS, THAT WE GET RIGHT FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. AND, I
THINK THAT WORK WILL CONTINUE.
I'M CONFIDENT, NUMBER ONE, THAT
WORK WILL CONTINUE OVER THE
BREAK. I DO THINK THAT WE HAVE
THE COMMITMENT AND THE TIME TO
BE ABLE TO DO THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS NEEDED. AND THE
POINT HAS BEEN WELL TAKEN THAT
MORE VOICES NEED TO BE INCLUDED
AS WE'RE CONSIDERING THESE, AND
IN NO WAY DO WE WANT TO DEGRADE
ETHNIC STUDIES OR TURN IT INTO
SOMETHING THAT IT WASN'T MEANT
TO BE. SO, I MEAN, YOUR POINT IS
WELL TAKEN, AND I ABSOLUTELY
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN GET THERE
WITH THE TIME THAT WE HAVE OF
OUR BREAK. I APPRECIATE THAT.
AND, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I
UNDERSTAND WE'RE NOT CHANGING
THE MODEL CURRICULUM WITH THIS
BILL. JUST REVIEW PROCESS. BUT
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, CHANGING
THE REVIEW PROCESS BY HAVING
FOLKS COME IN WHO ARE NOT
NECESSARILY SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS RAISES ENORMOUS
QUESTIONS IN MY MIND ABOUT HOW
THE BROADER COMMUNITY FEELS
ABOUT THAT. MEANING THE BROADER.
AND IF WE START GOING FROM
STAKEHOLDER TO STAKEHOLDER TO
STAKEHOLDER, ARE THEY
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT? ARE
PEOPLE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT? OR
HAS THEIR EXPERIENCE BEEN FOR
EXAMPLE, THAT IT'S NOT REALLY A
JURY OF THEIR PEERS, SO TO
SPEAK, WHO'S GOING TO END UP
BEING ON THAT REVIEW PANEL? I
COULD SEE THAT IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH WITH SOME
ETHNIC GROUPS, WHO ARE ALREADY
MARGINALIZED IN MOST
DISCUSSIONS, FEELING THIS, THIS
IS JUST GOING TO BE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE
OUTNUMBERED AND BE SHOVED INTO A
CLASSIC MINORITY POSITION WHERE,
WE CAN SPEAK TRUTH TO POWER, BUT
WE'RE NEVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTUATE THE CURRICULUM, AND
SO THAT IS A PIECE I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT. I WANTED TO ASK MISS
MONTANO, IS IT, YOU I DON'T KNOW
YOUR RESUME, BUT I KNOW YOU'RE A
PROFESSOR, BY THE DOCUMENTS
HERE, AND I KNOW THAT YOU ARE A.
YOU WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT
BEING, I THINK, CONSULTANT,
QUALIFYING YOURSELF AS AN EXPERT
IN CURRICULUM. COULD YOU SPEAK
TO THE LAST POINT I WAS TRYING
TO MAKE? IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ON THAT, WHAT IS WHAT ARE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF HAVING FOLKS YOU
TALK YOU ALLUDED TO IT, BUT WHAT
WHAT'S WHAT ARE THE IMPLICATIONS
OF HAVING FOLKS WHO HAVEN'T BEEN
ENGAGED IN THE BODY OF WORK? SO,
SO OUR CURRICULUM DOING THE
REVIEW PROCESS, I THINK THAT
THAT IS THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRUCIAL. I THINK EVEN IN THE
CONVERSATIONS LEADING UP TO THIS
MOMENT, THAT VOICE HAS BEEN
MISSING IN THE CONVERSATION. AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO, MY
UNION SIBLINGS, THAT THAT VOICE
ALSO NEEDS TO BE AT THE TABLE
WHEN ENTERING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. I MEAN,
THIS HAS BEEN A 50 YEAR STRUGGLE.
YOU KNOW, LET ME JUST SAY THAT A
50 YEAR STRUGGLE FOR ONE MEASLY
AND I WANT TO SAY MEASLY BECAUSE
I, I CELEBRATED IN THE VICTORY
OF IT ONE COURSE, ONE SINGULAR
COURSE THAT A STUDENT TAKES IN
HIGH SCHOOL WHERE FOR VERY
DISTINCT RACIALIZED COMMUNITIES
ARE DISCUSSED. AND OF COURSE,
ANY ANY ETHNIC STUDIES PROFESSOR,
JUST BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT THAT
YOU ARE THE MARGINALIZED, USES A
COMPARATIVE APPROACH IN TEACHING
ETHNIC STUDIES. SO IF I TEACH
CHICANO STUDIES, BUT IN TEACHING
CHICANO STUDIES AT CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE, I RECOGNIZE THE
DIVERSITY OF THE STUDENTS IN MY
CLASSROOM. AND SO IN TEACHING
THAT CURRICULUM, I HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITY AND
THE DIVERSITY. I HAVE SPENT 40
YEARS IN THIS DISCIPLINE. RIGHT.
AND I AM STILL HERE TODAY, 40
YEARS LATER, TRYING TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT THAT WHILE I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AN ENTRY IN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT IMPROVING,
WHAT IS CALLED THE TRANSPARENCY,
WHICH I BELIEVE IS ALREADY
THERE, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVE TO TACKLE SYSTEM WIDE. IT
IS NOT SIMPLY AN ISSUE WITHIN
ETHNIC STUDIES. IT'S AN ISSUE
WITHIN SOCIAL STUDIES. IT'S AN
ISSUE WITHIN ENGLISH. IT'S AN
ISSUE IN MATH. IT'S AN ISSUE IN
IN KINESIOLOGY. THAT ISSUE
SHOULDN'T BE LIMITED TO SCRUTINY
OF ONE DISCIPLINE. I WAS REALLY
GETTING INTO MORE WHETHER OR NOT
THE SCRUTINY SHOULD COME WELL,
AND I DO THINK THAT THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF CURRICULUM, THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE, INCLUDING THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT GREATER
TRANSPARENCY, NEEDS TO HAVE
THOSE WHO ARE INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN NOT JUST SECURING
THE LEGISLATION, BUT IN
IMPLEMENTING THE LEGISLATION. WE
ALL WANT TO BE A PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION, SO LET ME, LET ME
JUST, SENATOR, CAN I CAN I,
YEAH, I ETHNIC STUDIES EXPERT.
ONE OTHER ONE OTHER QUICK,
HOPEFULLY QUICK POINT BECAUSE I
KNOW THE CHAIR NEEDS TO KEEP THE
AGENDA MOVING, BUT I, I JUST
HAVE SOME RELEVANCE I DIDN'T
WANT TO RESTATE HAVE OR RESTATE
HER HER OPENING. THANK YOU. SO
WE'VE ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS THAT
CAME FROM OUR EDUCATION PARTNERS
THAT ACTUALLY REQUIRE THAT. I
THINK A MAJORITY OF THE
PARTICIPANTS BE EDUCATORS AS
PART OF THE. AND THAT'S NOT IN
THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU PROBABLY
SAW. SO, WE'RE WE'RE IN
AGREEMENT WITH THE THRUST OF I
THINK, YOUR COMMENTS AND WE KNOW
THAT WE STILL HAVE MORE WORK TO
DO, YOU KNOW, I THINK ONE OF
THE, ONE OF THE CHALLENGING
THINGS IS TO MAKE SURE, YOU KNOW,
ONE OF THE CONCEPTS THAT WAS
EMBEDDED IN THIS BILL IS THAT
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHETHER
OR NOT, YOU KNOW, AS PART OF THE
PROCESS, WHETHER OR NOT,
SOMETHING IS APPROPRIATE,
WHETHER IT'S BIAS APPROPRIATE
FOR ALL COMMUNITIES THAT YOU
ACTUALLY HAVE CONCEPTS OF
CULTURAL CAPACITY THERE, AND
YOU'RE LOOKING AT WHETHER OR
NOT, YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT FROM
THE VIEWPOINT OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE BEING IMPACTED, BEING
IMPACTED. AND SO THAT IS A
CONCEPT THAT WE EMBRACE. WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS PART OF
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THIS. AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
ON. I DON'T KNOW IF SOMEBODY HAD
ANY ONE MORE ONE MORE STATEMENT
ON THAT. A BRIEF STATEMENT,
PLEASE, WE'VE DONE A STUDY THAT
HAVING TEACHERS IN THE CONTENT
AREA OF SOCIAL STUDIES AND
ENGLISH DOES NOT NECESSARILY
MEAN THAT THEY'RE EXPERTS IN
ETHNIC STUDIES. SO HOW YOU
DEFINE THOSE EDUCATORS IS GOING
TO BE INCREDIBLY, CRUCIAL. AND,
YOU KNOW, WE WOULD LOVE TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU.
I KNOW WE'VE MET WE MET EARLY ON
WITH WITH CFA AND OR CONTINUED
WITH, YOU KNOW, VERY, VERY
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU AND LET
ME JUST TURN IT OVER. I KNOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER, JUST ONE
COMMENT. I'LL JUST I'LL JUST
REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE OF WHAT
WE JUST HEARD HERE, THE
IMPORTANCE OF TEACHER VOICE, BUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF TEACHER VOICE
IN THAT DISCIPLINE, IT DOES MAKE
A DIFFERENCE. AND I SAY THAT
HAVING 20 YEARS, EXPERIENCE IN
THE CLASSROOM, IT DOES MAKE A
DIFFERENCE TO HAVE THAT SORT OF
FINE TUNED UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DISCIPLINE YOU'RE TEACHING. AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE WERE IN LENGTHY
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR PARTNERS
IN LABOR, IN EDUCATION, CTA, CFT,
WHO BROUGHT THIS UP IMMEDIATELY.
I THINK WE WERE VERY AGREEABLE
TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS AND TO
MAKE SURE THOSE VOICES WERE
INCLUDED. SO VERY IMPORTANT. AND
THEN I WOULD JUST REITERATE WHAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAS SAID
ABOUT CULTURAL COMPETENCY,
COMPETENCY BEING A PIECE OF THIS
THAT GETS AT SORT OF THE BROAD
OVERLAY OF WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. WE CANNOT NECESSARILY
ADDRESS EVERY SINGLE GROUP ALL
THE TIME, AT EVERY MOMENT. BUT
WITH AN OVERLAY OF CULTURAL
COMPETENCY, WE GET AT THE
UNDERLYING CORE VALUE OF RESPECT
FOR OTHER CULTURES AND HAVING
WINDOWS INTO OTHER PEOPLE'S
CULTURES AND MIRRORS OF OUR OWN
CULTURE AND HISTORY. I'M. TRY TO
COOPERATE WITH THE CHAIR HERE.
I'M NOT GOING TO ASK A QUESTION,
BUT I'M JUST GOING TO MAKE A
STATEMENT THAT MAYBE IF THE
AUTHOR AUTHOR CAN SPEAK TO IT IN
HIS CLOTHES OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, THAT'S FINE. IF NOT,
THAT'S FINE. AS WELL. BUT, YOU
KNOW, I, I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
WHAT MY CONCERNS ARE. SO FOR ME,
THIS IS NOT ABOUT A SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OR LOBBIES ON ONE
SIDE OR THE OTHER, YOU KNOW,
APPLYING PRESSURE OR ANYTHING
ELSE. THIS IS ABOUT
CONSTITUENTS, ESPECIALLY OVER
THE LAST FEW MONTHS, WHO NEED TO
COME AND SEE ME ON SATURDAYS IN
MY DISTRICT OFFICE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT AVAILABLE DURING THE
WEEK MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY. AND
HARDLY AM I IN MY OWN DISTRICT,
TALKING TO ME ABOUT PUBLIC
RECORDS, REQUESTS AND AD HOC
GROUPS THAT ARE SETTING UP TO
OVERSEE OF PARENTS THAT ARE
THERE TO OVERSEE CURRICULUM THAT
ARE COMING TO CONCLUSIONS ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER, THAT ARE THEN
LEADING TO DISCIPLINE OR IN SOME
CASES, LITIGATION. I THINK ONE
OF THE WITNESSES SPOKE TO THAT,
I DON'T SEE HOW THIS FIXES THIS.
I'M VERY, VERY CONCERNED THAT IT
EXACERBATES THOSE KIND OF
PROBLEMS. ABSENT SOME SOME OTHER
KIND OF A FIX, RARELY AM I ONE
TO CONCEDE. AND SAY THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH TIME LEFT OR YOU CAN'T
GET ALL THOSE FIXES DONE, BUT
THAT'S HOW I FEEL THIS TIME. I
DO FEEL THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
LEGISLATION IN THIS AREA TO TAKE
IT TO THE NEXT LEVEL, LIKE
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
ASSEMBLYMAN, I JUST I CAN'T PUT
MY NAME NEXT TO AN AYE VOTE ON
SOMETHING THAT EVERYTHING IN MY
CORE BEING IS TELLING ME, RIGHT
NOW, AS IT'S CURRENTLY PUT
TOGETHER, IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
HAVE THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF EXACERBATING, THE INTENSITY
OF DISPUTES AT THE LOCAL LEVEL,
AND, YOU KNOW, THAT'S THAT'S HOW
I FEEL. SO I'M GOING TO BE
STAYING OFF TODAY. MR. CHAIR,
AND I'LL TURN THE FLOOR BACK
OVER TO YOU. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR CORTEZ, ANYTHING
ELSE FROM MY COLLEAGUES? LET ME
LET ME SAY A COUPLE OF THINGS,
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT SENATOR CORTEZ
RAISED, BUT ALSO, YOU KNOW, SOME
OF THE VERY VALID POINTS RAISED
BY THE WIENER COMMENTS, WHO YOU
KNOW, IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THEY REPRESENT A BROAD CROSS
SECTION TEACHERS, STAFF, SCHOOL
BOARD, TRUSTEES, ALL OF THE
FOLKS INVOLVED AND THEIR
CONCERNS, I JUST WANT TO AS THE
CHAIR TO MAKE SURE THEY THOSE
CONCERNS ARE ON THE RECORD. SO
ONE POINT, I THINK DOCTOR
MONTANEZ MADE IT. ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES ARE ALREADY SOME OF THE
MOST SCRUTINIZED COURSES IN
TERMS OF BOTH THEIR DEVELOPMENT.
ALSO, WHAT CALIFORNIA LAW
ALREADY REQUIRES. AND I DO THINK
IT'S FAIR AS AS SOME FOLKS HAVE
NOTED, IT'S FAIR TO WORRY ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROSPECTIVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THIS
BILL MIGHT CREATE, ESPECIALLY
ABSENT THE CLARITY, I THINK THAT
WE'RE WE'RE ASPIRING TO HERE.
AND I THINK, DIFFERENT FOLKS
HAVE MADE IT. YOU KNOW, WE'RE
HAVING ORGANIZATIONS WITHOUT
TEACHING EXPERIENCE AND
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT TEACHING
EXPERIENCE INVOLVED IN
DEVELOPING HIGH SCHOOL COURSES
IMPROVE OR DILUTE THE QUALITY OF
THOSE ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES. AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION WILL SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES GET UNNECESSARILY TO
SENATOR CORTEZ'S POINT?
UNPRODUCTIVELY CAUGHT UP IN
CONTROVERSIES OVER WHOSE VERSION
OF HISTORY SHOULD BE TAUGHT IN
OUR SCHOOLS, SCHOOL BOARDS AND
STAFFS, AND WE'VE HAD A NUMBER
OF BILLS IN THIS SPACE OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS. OUR ALREADY
UNDER UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF
ATTACK, OFTEN BY GROUPS THAT
AREN'T FROM THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND IN FACT, OFTEN BY GROUPS
THAT AREN'T EVEN FROM
CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK THERE'S
A VALID CAUSE FOR CONCERN THAT
THIS, THIS BILL, IF NOT
PROPERLY, EXECUTED, MAY BRING
ADDITIONAL UNWANTED AND IN MANY
WAYS, YOU KNOW, REALLY DANGEROUS
ATTENTION IN THIS REGARD. AND AS
WE'VE SEEN RECENTLY AS IT
RELATES TO SOME OTHER TOPICS
THAT MANY, MUCH OF WHICH HAVE
COME THROUGH THIS COMMITTEE. AND
SO, FOR MY PART, I'D ALSO AGREE
THAT ANY CHANGES SHOULD BE
PROSPECTIVE AND NOT IMPACT
ETHNIC STUDIES PROGRAMS, WHICH
BY OUR ALL ACCOUNTS ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WELL. AND I
HOPEFULLY THAT'S A GIVEN IN
THIS. IT SEEMS LIKE SOME
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENT LANGUAGE IS
NEEDED TO FURTHER CLARIFY THIS
INTENT. AND I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE,
YOU KNOW, MADE THAT OFFER. AND
I'D ASK YOU TO REAFFIRM
EXPLICITLY YOUR COMMITMENT TO
DOING THAT. I DO APPRECIATE
SENATOR CORTEZ'S CONCERN ABOUT
TIME. SENATOR GONZALES IS
CONCERNED ABOUT GOTTEN AMEND AND
TIME. AND I THINK, YOU KNOW,
IT'S ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE AGAINST THAT POINT THAT THE
ETHNIC STUDIES LEGISLATION WE
DID TOOK A LOT OF TIME AND
IMMENSELY COMPLICATED. AND MANY
OF MY COLLEAGUES, ESPECIALLY,
JEWISH CAUCUS COLLEAGUES, WERE
VERY INVOLVED IN THAT OVER A
NUMBER OF YEARS, AND SO IT IS
WORTH BEING WARY ABOUT TRYING TO
SOLVE A BIG PROBLEM IN SUCH A
SHORT TIME. BUT I AM ACTUALLY,
YOU KNOW, WILLING, IN FACT, GLAD
TO PUT MY NAME AGAINST A VOTE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY. AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT IT
MOVE FORWARD. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION, AND I
SALUTE BOTH OF THE AUTHORS. BUT
I ALSO WANTED TO, YOU KNOW,
DOCTOR MONTANO MADE A REALLY
GOOD POINT AT AT YOUR OPENING
THAT ETHNIC STUDIES IS COMPRISES
90 OUT OF APPROXIMATELY 13,000
HOURS OF STUDY ACROSS AN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE, AND THAT
SHOULD ALSO BE SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE MINDFUL TO, WHICH IS IF WE
CAN IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND THE
PARTICIPATION AND THE INPUT IN
THAT OTHER 13, 12, SOMETHING
THOUSAND HOURS, WE PROBABLY
WOULDN'T HAVE THESE PROBLEMS. WE
WOULD PROBABLY BE HAVING A VERY
DIFFERENT DISCUSSION. AND SO
THAT'S SEPARATE ISSUE FOR I
GUESS, MANY SEPARATE DAYS. BUT
IF THIS THIS BILL DOES GET TO
THE FLOOR AND THEN THESE VERY
VALID CONCERNS HAVE NOT YET BEEN
RESOLVED, AS ANY CHAIR IN MY
POSITION WOULD DO, I DO RESERVE
THE RIGHT TO CALL IT BACK. BUT I
KNOW THAT YOU, AS AN AUTHOR ARE
GOING TO WORK VERY DILIGENTLY TO
PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING. SO
WITH THAT, GLAD TO SUPPORT IT,
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
YES. SO FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL. I WANT TO THANK
THANK EVERYONE FOR THE VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS. I WANT TO
THANK MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ALSO,
THE OPPONENT TODAY, VERY
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU, I'LL SAY, FIRST OF
ALL, IT'S JUST SOME OF THE
DETAILS THAT RAISED THE FACTUAL
AND ACCURACY HISTORICALLY
ACCURATE THAT WAS AMENDED OUT OF
THE BILL, WE THE RETROACTIVITY,
WE HAVE NO, NO INTENT TO REQUIRE
ANYTHING THAT IS ALREADY
ADOPTED. AND IN PLACE TO BE
AFFECTED BY THIS. I THINK WE'VE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS THAT DO THAT.
BUT IF THERE'S ANYTHING
REMAINING, OBVIOUSLY WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN MAKING SURE THAT
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY CRYSTAL
CLEAR. I DO THINK THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY THROUGH, YOU KNOW, WE
SORT OF HAVE TWO CHOICES. ONE IS
WE EITHER HAVE MORE TRANSPARENCY
IN THIS PROCESS OR WE SORT OF
MOVE THINGS TO THE STATE LEVEL.
AND OF COURSE, THAT IS NOT A
PART OF THE GOAL. I MEAN, THAT'S
INCONSISTENT WITH THE GOAL OF
ALLOWING LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACTUALLY TAILORING THESE TO THE
TO THE HERITAGE AND THE AND
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. SO WE HAVE
BASICALLY FOCUSED AS
TRANSPARENCY AS THE WAY TO
PROVIDE SAFEGUARDS ON THIS, I DO
THINK THAT THE ISSUES WITH
RESPECT TO DACA, DOXING THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED AND TARGETING
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT ONES. I
THINK WE WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
ENGAGING WITH THE EDUCATION
EXPERTS ON THAT. I THINK THERE
ARE SOME THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
TO ADDRESS THAT AS WELL, GLAD TO
BE SENATOR GONZALEZ WITH YOUR
STAKEHOLDERS, IN YOUR AREA AND
ANY OTHERS THAT ACTUALLY ARE
INTERESTED, AM I? I KNOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAMS AND I HAVE
BEEN HAVING MANY, MANY, MANY
MEETINGS. CLEARLY WANT TO DO
THAT. WE ARE REACHING OUT NOT
ONLY TO THE LATINO CAUCUS, BUT
ALL THE DIVERSITY CAUCUSES,
WE'VE HAD SOME INITIAL
DISCUSSIONS WITH ALL OF THEM AND
OBVIOUSLY NEED TO HAVE MORE
IN-DEPTH ONES, AND THEN I THINK
THE LAST THING THAT I'LL SAY AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO, TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ADAMS FOR HER
CLOTHES AS WELL, IS, THIS IS
THIS THESE TRANSPARENCY
PROCEDURES? WELL, WE ACTUALLY
HAVE ISSUES NOW THAT ARE REALLY
ARISING THAT ARE THAT ARE
AFFECTING THE CLIMATE IN SCHOOLS
FOR JEWISH STUDENTS. AND SOME OF
THE CONTENT FOR JEWISH STUDENTS.
THESE THINGS ARE SORT OF
COMMUNITY NEUTRAL. THIS AFFECTS
ALL COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO BIAS AND DISCRIMINATION. AND
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THIS, YOU KNOW, THAT
ETHNIC STUDIES IS ONE COURSE OUT
OF MANY, AS AN LGBTQ PERSON, IF
YOU ACTUALLY HAD CONTENT THAT
WAS BEING TAUGHT IN A SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT WAS BASICALLY
LGBTQ PHOBIC, HOMOPHOBIC, YOU
KNOW, THE FACT THAT IT'S ONLY
ONE COURSE IS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY HAS THAT CREATES A WHOLE
SENSE OF, YOU KNOW, AFFECTS THE
CLIMATE FOR THESE KIDS IN THE
SCHOOLS. AND IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO GET THIS
RIGHT FOR EVERYONE, FOR NO
MATTER WHAT YOUR BACKGROUND IS,
WHETHER YOU'RE JEWISH OR WHETHER
YOU'RE MUSLIM OR WHETHER YOU'RE
CHRISTIAN, OR WHETHER YOU ARE
ANY RACIAL OR ETHNIC COMMUNITY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
IS RIGHT FOR ALL. AND THAT'S WHY
I THINK YOU KNOW, THESE ISSUES
OF CULTURAL COMPETENCY. THIS
JUST DOESN'T AFFECT THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY. I MEAN, WE KNOW ABOUT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
COMING INTO CURRICULUM IN
FLORIDA NOW, WHICH I DON'T THINK
IS VERY FAR AWAY FROM IT, SORT
OF SEEPING INTO CALIFORNIA. THIS
WILL HELP THIS TRANSPARENCY WILL
HELP MAKE SURE THAT OUR THAT OUR
CURRICULUMS ARE GOOD, YOU KNOW,
AND SAFE FOR ALL COMMUNITIES. SO
WITH THAT, I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR THE VERY INSIGHTFUL
AND IMPORTANT QUESTIONS AND ASK
FOR YOUR. I VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND WOULD LIKE
TO TURN IT OVER TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ADDIS. WELL, THANK YOU
AND I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
ROBUST AND IN-DEPTH QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS AND CONVERSATION. AND I
DO WANT TO THANK THE OPPOSITION
WHO HAS BROUGHT UP SOME VERY
SALIENT POINTS ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF ETHNIC STUDIES FOR
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS,
ACROSS THE BOARD, AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE UPLIFT
THE REAL STORIES OF CHILDREN AND
ADULT STUDENTS IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND, AND RESPECT FOR TEACHERS,
VOICES AND TEACHERS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE IN THIS DISCIPLINE
AND THAT WE REALLY EARLY ON, I
KNOW THE COMMENT WAS MADE THAT
BECAUSE THIS WAS A GUT AMEND, IT
FELT LIKE A SURPRISE. I WILL
ALSO SAY, THOUGH, THAT WE HAVE
TRIED TO BE PROACTIVE IN
REACHING OUT TO OUR EDUCATION
PARTNERS AND TAKING THEIR VOICES
INTO CONSIDERATION, NOT JUST
INTO CONSIDERATION, BUT TRUE
COLLABORATION. IT'S CLEAR TO ME,
HAVING BEEN IN THE HEARING
TODAY, THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE
THOSE EFFORTS, THAT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE THOSE
EFFORTS. AND, AND I DO THINK WE
CAN GET THIS RIGHT IN THE TIME
WE HAVE. I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT
SOME OF WHAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THAT WE'RE AFRAID OF HAPPENING
IS ALREADY HAPPENING. AND THAT'S
WHY WE'RE SITTING HERE TODAY
DISCUSSING THIS IS BECAUSE
THERE'S ALREADY A CONTENTION
AROUND HOW THIS CURRICULUM IS
BEING TAUGHT. AND THERE'S
ALREADY SOME SCARY THINGS OUT
THERE. AND SO YOU KNOW, THE GOAL
HERE IS TO HELP MAKE THIS BETTER
SO THAT ETHNIC STUDIES DOES
THRIVE. AND THAT ALL CHILDREN,
ALL STUDENTS THAT ARE ABLE TO
TAKE ETHNIC STUDIES THRIVE AS
WELL. AND SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. WONDERFUL. WE'LL TAKE THAT
AS A CLOSING. RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION. ALL RIGHT. I'LL NATURE
CALLS, BUT I CAN WAIT. SO, SO WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR SENATOR
GLAZER. THIS IS SERIOUS THING,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? WHAT I
SAID BEFORE WAS ABOUT CLOSING,
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU, OKAY, MADAM. CONSOLE,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR ITEM 18
AB 2918. ZIPPER MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
NEWMAN I OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI.
CORTESE GLASER. GLASER. I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I IS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. WILK I.
ALL RIGHT. THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS FIVE VOTES AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN. ACTUALLY
KNOW THAT THAT BILL IS OUT.
EVERYBODY'S HERE. OH SMALL CLOSE
HERE. WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR,
SENATOR SMALLWOOD TO WEIGH IN.
SO THANK YOU, EVERYBODY. YEAH.
JUST HOLD ON. OH
YEAH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. CARR, THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I DID A BILL
ON BATHROOM LAST YEAR. I'M
PROUDER THAN EVER OF THAT BILL
RIGHT NOW. SO, YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. AB 2441 WILL GIVE OUR
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE WHEN TO
REPORT A STUDENT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR CERTAIN
INCIDENTS CAUSED BY THEIR
BEHAVIORS. UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW,
TEACHERS AND ADMINISTRATORS ARE
REQUIRED TO CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR CERTAIN VIOLATIONS, SUCH AS
ASSAULT AND BATTERY, WITHOUT
INJURY OR LOUD AND DISRUPTIVE
NOISE. AT SCHOOL, REGARDLESS OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OR STUDENT
SITUATION. EVEN IF A TEACHER
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS THE
INCIDENT DIFFERENTLY, SUCH AS
THROUGH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OR PARENT TEACHER CONFERENCES,
AND NOT REPORT THEM TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT, TEACHERS AND STAFF
FEEL FORCED TO REPORT THE
STUDENT OUT OF FEAR OF BEING
FINED. SADLY, THIS OUTDATED
SYSTEM HAS LED TO ALARMING
DISPARITIES IN THE TYPES OF
STUDENTS MOST LIKELY TO SUFFER
THESE HARMS. BLACK STUDENTS,
LATINO STUDENTS, STUDENTS OF
COLOR, AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE MORE THAN OFTEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY REFERRED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT CITED AND
ARRESTED, IN MANY CASES
HANDCUFFED AND TAKEN OFF THE
SCHOOL PREMISES. OVERPOLICING IN
OUR SCHOOLS HAS FUELED THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE AND
ONLY HINDERS THE ABILITY FOR A
STUDENT TO GET THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED. AS THE STAFF ANALYSIS
APPROPRIATELY POINTS OUT, WE'VE
MADE REALLY GREAT STRIDES IN
FOCUSING ON RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
AND OTHER MEANS, AND AB 2441 IN
REGARDS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
MANDATES REALLY MAKES IT
OPTIONAL RATHER THAN MANDATORY
FOR STUDENTS TO BE REFERRED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN THEY
WILLFULLY DISTURB A PUBLIC
SCHOOL MEETING OR WHEN A TEACHER
OR STAFF IS ATTACKED, ASSAULTED,
OR THREATENED. THIS BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE EXISTING LAW AROUND
LAW ENFORCEMENT INVOLVEMENT FOR
STUDENT FIGHTS, OR WHEN A
STUDENT IS ATTACKED AND
ASSAULTED OR THREATENED OR
HARMED. FURTHERMORE REMOVING
THIS MANDATE DOES NOT MEAN
STUDENTS WON'T BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
RATHER, AB 2441 GIVES TEACHERS
AND SCHOOLS THE AUTHORITY TO
MAKE THAT JUDGMENT CALL. AND
WHAT IS THE BEST APPROACH FOR
THE STUDENT? WHETHER IT'S BEST
TO ADDRESS THIS IN THE
PRINCIPAL'S OFFICE, PARENT
TEACHER CONFERENCE, SOCIAL
SERVICES, MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES, OR IF THE INSTANCE
DOES WARRANT THE POLICE TO BE
CALLED. LASTLY, NOTHING IN THIS
BILL PROHIBITS OR BANS TEACHERS
OR SCHOOLS FROM COMING FROM
CALLING LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN
FACT, THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
NOTES THIS IS PART OF THE MANY
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN IN
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
ONE CANNOT IMPEDE OR IN ANY WAY
DISCOURAGE SOMEONE FROM CALLING
THE POLICE IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
CHOOSE TO DO. WE NEED TO TRUST
AND EMPOWER OUR TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS THAT THEY BELIEVE ARE
BEST FOR THEIR STUDENTS. SUCCESS
AND THE SAFETY OF THE CLASSROOM
ENVIRONMENT. I APPRECIATE ALL
THE BILL SPONSORS, INCLUDING
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR, BLACK
ORGANIZING PROJECT, DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA, THE DOLORES
HUERTA FOUNDATION, AND PUBLIC
COUNSEL, AS WELL AS THREE DOZEN
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT,
INCLUDING THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS,
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS, AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION'S OF
EDUCATION. I DO WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR FOR HIS ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS BILL. AND WHILE WE'VE HAD
CONCERNS AND I'VE EXPRESSED
CONCERNS WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT REQUIRE LAW ENFORCEMENT
NOTIFICATION FOR IMMEDIATE
MEDICAL ATTENTION, I'LL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS TODAY
AND WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CHAIR'S COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH US ON FURTHER
CLARIFYING AND MUTUALLY
AGREEABLE LANGUAGE AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. I KNOW IN THIS
BUILDING, WE USUALLY ARE ABLE TO
COME TO AN AGREEMENT AND
SOMETIMES WE DON'T. WE JUST WANT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION AND HOPEFULLY GET
TO A PLACE OF AGREEMENT, THE
LANGUAGE AS IT IS, YOU KNOW, IT
IS TROUBLESOME FOR US, BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THE INTENTION OF THE
CHAIR, IS GOOD AND THAT IN
GENERALLY SPEAKING, THE CHAIR
HAS INDICATED SUPPORT FOR WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN OUR
BILL AS WELL. AND SO I FEEL
HOPEFUL WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET TO
A PLACE OF AGREEMENT IF THIS
BILL WERE TO MAKE IT THROUGH
THIS COMMITTEE, WITH THE CHAIR
AMENDMENTS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT ARE ZULEMA BAQUEDANO, A
MIDDLE SCHOOL TEACHER FROM SANTA
ANA, AND DOLORES HUERTA, OSCAR
DANIEL LOPEZ, SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS,
CALIFORNIA, WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
YOU GOT TO SEE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
LEGISLATING BEFORE THIS BILL.
NØ. IT'S FASCINATING TO ME. SO
THANK YOU. BUT GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE TO FIRST,
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
CONSIDER THIS BILL, MY NAME IS
CARDANO. I'M A MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER FROM SANTA ANA, AND I'M
FROM SENATE DISTRICT 29. AS A
TEACHER THAT'S BEEN WORKING IN
EDUCATION FOR ALMOST TEN YEARS,
THIS TOPIC IS SOMETHING VERY
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART AS I
TAKE YOU TO MY TIME AS A FIRST
YEAR TEACHER. WHEN I WAS
ASSAULTED BY A SEVENTH GRADE
TEACHER OR STUDENT, SORRY, WHO?
I'LL CALL MARY. MARY WAS BRIGHT,
FUNNY, AND A WONDERFUL DANCER.
SHE ALSO HAD AN UNDIAGNOSED
CONDITION THAT LED HER TO HAVE
DIFFICULTIES CONTROLLING HER
EMOTIONS, SOMETIMES RESULTING IN
SCREAMING OR THRASHING. IT
WASN'T ALWAYS OBVIOUS WHEN MARY
WAS GOING TO REACT THIS WAY, BUT
WE TRIED TO TEACH HER HEALTHY
COPING MECHANISMS. THE SCHOOL
WAS DOING THEIR BEST TO HELP HER
GUARDIANS FIND ANSWERS, BUT SHE
WAS IN AND OUT OF FOSTER HOMES,
MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO GET
CONSISTENT MEDICAL CARE. ONE DAY
IN CLASS, I REDIRECTED HER AS
SHE WAS YELLING ACROSS THE ROOM
WHEN SHE SNAPPED AND STARTED
YELLING AT ME. I APPROACHED HER
DESK TO ASK IF SHE'D LIKE SOME
TIME OUTSIDE TO COOL DOWN, AS WE
HAD PRACTICED MANY TIMES OVER,
BUT SHE BEGAN SHOVING THINGS OFF
HER DESK IN A RAGE, KICKING HER
BACKPACK OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
IN THE PROCESS KICKING ME AND
SENDING ME TO THE GROUND.
ANOTHER TEACHER OVERHEARD AND
CAME TO TRY TO TALK MARY DOWN,
WHO WAS STILL SCREAMING AND
THRASHING IN HER SEAT, UNAWARE
OF WHAT HAD JUST HAPPENED.
AFTERWARDS, MY ADMIN ASKED IF I
WANTED TO CALL THE POLICE. THEY
EXPLAINED THAT MARY ACCIDENTALLY
KICKING ME CONSTITUTED ASSAULT,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE SHE WAS
UNDIAGNOSED AND THEY HAD NO
PROOF SHE DIDN'T DO IT
MALICIOUSLY. THE TEACHER THAT
CAME TO HELP ME TRY TO CONVINCE
ME TO PRESS CHARGES BECAUSE SHE
SHOULDN'T GET AWAY WITH IT, BUT
WHAT SHE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND IS
THAT IF I DID, MARY WOULD
PROBABLY NEVER BE DIAGNOSED. AS
I'M SURE WE ALL KNOW, FEMALE
BLACK STUDENTS STATISTICALLY
HAVE A HARDER TIME BEING
FORMALLY DIAGNOSED FOR THEIR
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES. SHE WAS
FINALLY LIVING WITH FAMILY, ABLE
TO HAVE DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENTS,
BUT CALLING THE POLICE WOULD
HAVE SENT HER BACK TO FOSTER
CARE. THIS TEACHER DIDN'T KNOW
ANYTHING ABOUT MARY, BUT FORMED
AN OPINION ABOUT HER WITH A
SNAPSHOT. BECAUSE I WAS ALLOWED
TO USE MY PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT,
MARY WAS ABLE TO GET THE HELP
THAT SHE NEEDED AND ENDED UP
GOING TO HISTORICALLY BLACK
COLLEGE. AB 2441 GIVES EDUCATORS
LIKE ME THE ABILITY TO CHOOSE
HOW WE REACT TO INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS NEEDS AND
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS BILL COULD
LET US HAVE THOUSANDS OF MARY'S
ABLE TO PURSUE THEIR DREAMS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON AB 2424 2421. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WELL DONE. THANK
YOU, MISS SCHWARTZ. SO NICE TO
SEE YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, MY NAME, MY NAME IS
DOLORES HUERTA WITH THE DOLORES
HUERTA FOUNDATION FOR GRASSROOTS
EMPOWERMENT AND ORGANIZING. WE
HAVE CHAPTERS OF OUR FOUNDATION
THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AND PARTS OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND IN EACH CHAPTER, WE HAVE AN
EDUCATION COMMITTEE THAT WORKS
WITH BOTH PARENTS AND STUDENTS
TO ENGAGE IN THE EDUCATIONAL
PROCESS. AND WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS, AB 2441 WILL ALLOW
EDUCATORS TO UTILIZE ALL OF THE
TOOLS AT THEIR DISPOSAL TO
PURSUE PUBLIC SAFETY. EDUCATORS
ARE CONSTRAINED CURRENTLY BY
STATE LAWS THAT WERE PASSED
DURING THE SUPERPREDATOR ERA, A
LONG DEBUNKED MYTH THAT
PROCLAIMED THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
WERE BECOMING MORE VIOLENT AND
REMORSELESS. DESPITE THE DESPITE
THE LACK OF EVIDENCE,
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT FORMED THE
BASIS OF MUCH OF OUR 1990S
POLICY MAKING AND THE LOOSE THE
LAWS THAT WE HAVE AT ISSUE
TODAY. JOHN DILULIO JR, WHO
ACTUALLY, CONCEIVED OF THIS
THEORY, ACTUALLY DENOUNCED HIS
OWN THEORY, SAYING THAT IT WAS
NOT RIGHT, IT WAS NOT WORKING IN
OUR ORGANIZATION. WE HAVE ONE
CHAPTER IN CALIFORNIA CITY,
WHICH IS PRIMARILY A BLACK AREA.
AND, OUR THE KIDS IN CALIFORNIA
CITY, EIGHT OUT OF TEN CHILDREN
HAVE THE HAVE THE TEACHERS HAVE
CALLED IN TO THE SCHOOL TO TAKE
THE KIDS OUT OF SCHOOL. EIGHT
OUT OF TEN BLACK CHILDREN. AND
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS NOT RIGHT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT OR
IMPEDE SCHOOL PERSONNEL FROM
CALLING OR WORKING WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THIS BILL IS
LIMITED TO BEHAVIORS THAT
SCHOOLS HAVE EXPERIENCED
RESOLVING, SUCH AS MARIJUANA OR
ALCOHOL USE OR TEACHERS
ASSAULTS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
ALTER MANDATES OR OTHER
BEHAVIORS SUCH AS POSSESSION OF
A FIREARM. RESEARCH ON SCHOOL
SAFETY HAS GROWN, AND METHODS
SUCH AS RESTORATIVE JUSTICE HAVE
PROLIFERATED, BUT OUR STATE LAWS
HAVE NOT CAUGHT UP ON THIS
RESEARCH. TODAY, EDUCATORS HAVE
NO CHOICE BUT TO ALWAYS NOTIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT CONTACT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT DECREASES GRADUATION
RATES AND INCREASES RECIDIVISM
RATES, AND IS VERY TRAUMATIC FOR
STUDENTS. THE DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE SHOWS THAT DISPARITIES
THAT STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
AND BLACK STUDENTS AND BROWN
STUDENTS ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
SEARCHED AND HANDCUFFED THAN
THEIR PEERS. THERE'S ONE
INSTANCE IN MORENO VALLEY WHERE
A YOUNG A YOUNG DISABLED STUDENT
WAS ACTUALLY HANDCUFFED AND
ARRESTED 30 SINGLE TIMES BY THE
LOCAL RESOURCE OFFICERS AND FOUR
TIMES BY POLICE, THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT INCREASES THEIR
ABILITY TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS AND
OUR EDUCATORS SAFE. WE PLEASE
HELP US STOP THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE TRUST THE
TEACHERS. AND BY THE WAY, I
FORGOT TO MENTION I WAS A FORMER
TEACHER. I HAVE A DAUGHTER WHO
WAS A TEACHER FOR 14 YEARS, ALSO
TRUST THE TEACHERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOU GOT WHAT I LIKE
TO CALL THE DOLORES HUERTA BONUS,
AN ADDITIONAL MINUTE. BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY AND
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, AS YOU JUST
HEARD, THE CFT IS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. WE URGE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU. STELLA JOHNSON, ON
BEHALF OF SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER, ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA PROUD CO-SPONSORS.
THANK YOU. HELLO, MEGAN. BEAR
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI. FAITH LI WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE,
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI, SALLY
CHING WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR CO-SPONSORS AND
STRONG SUPPORT. ALSO READING OFF
THE NAMES OF OTHER CO-SPONSORS
IN SUPPORT BLACK PARALLEL SCHOOL
BOARD COLEMAN ADVOCATES
CALIFORNIANS FOR JUSTICE AND
BROTHERS SONS SELVES. THANK YOU.
HELLO, RACHEL BOGERT WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. ALSO
RECOGNIZING OUR CO-SPONSORS,
BLACK ORGANIZING PROJECT SOCIAL
JUSTICE LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE AND
PUBLIC COUNCIL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI, JESS CONTRERAS, DOLORES
HUERTA FOUNDATION AND
REPRESENTING ARVIN, CALIFORNIA.
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
JUANITA CHÁVEZ WITH THE DOLORES
HUERTA FOUNDATION AND JUSTICE
FOR MY SISTER IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOU CAN COME TO THE TABLE IF YOU
LIKE AND WELCOME. MR. SHERMAN,
GENTLEMEN, YOU CHOICE. OKAY, MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION, HERE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL, SCHOOL OFFICIALS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT SHOULD WORK
COLLABORATIVELY, ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO STUDENTS WHOSE
BEHAVIOR VIOLATES THE LAW AND
JEOPARDIZES SCHOOL SAFETY.
REMOVING THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT THESE
INCIDENTS BE SHARED WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT RUNS COUNTER TO THAT
NOTION AND IMPEDES LAW
ENFORCEMENT, FRANKLY, FROM BEING
ABLE TO BEST PROTECT OUR
SCHOOLS, WE FEEL THAT SUCCESSFUL
MODELS OF SCHOOL AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERSHIPS BENEFIT
FROM THIS COLLABORATION AIMED AT
KEEPING CLASSROOMS AND CAMPUSES
SAFE AND REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT EDUCATORS
REPORT UNLAWFUL BEHAVIOR ON
CAMPUS WILL ONLY REDUCE THE
LEVEL OF STUDENT SAFETY. WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE BILL ALLOWS FOR
THESE REPORTS TO TAKE PLACE, BUT
WE AGREE THAT EXISTING LAW IS
THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO HANDLE
THIS, PARTICULARLY IN THE
LIMITED SITUATIONS THAT ARE
DESCRIBED IN EXISTING LAW AND
THAT ARE ADDRESSED BY THE BILL.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS. RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION.
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH A LIST
OF SOME OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA RESERVE
PEACE OFFICERS, DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION OF PLACER COUNTY,
THE POLICE OFFICER ASSOCIATIONS
OF ARCADIA, BURBANK, CLAREMONT,
CORONA, CULVER CITY, FULLERTON,
MURRIETA, NEWPORT BEACH, NOVATO,
PALOS VERDE'S POMONA, RIVERSIDE,
SANTA ANA, UPLAND, LÀ SCHOOL
POLICE ASSOCIATION, THE LA
SCHOOL POLICE MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION, CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF SCHOOL SAFETY
PROFESSIONALS, VERDE UNIFIED
SCHOOL POLICE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION, AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL POLICE
CHIEFS, ALL IN OPPOSITION TO
2441 CALIFORNIA'S LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
OPPOSED. TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
WOULD ENDANGER OUR SCHOOLS STAFF
RESOURCE OFFICERS, AND
ESPECIALLY STUDENTS BY
ELIMINATING CURRENT MANDATED
REPORTING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT
ABOUT VIOLENT AND DANGEROUS
INCIDENTS ON A PUBLIC SCHOOL
CAMPUS. MANDATED REPORTERS WERE
ESTABLISHED IN SCHOOLS AFTER
OFFICIALS REPEATEDLY FAILED TO
EXERCISE COMMON SENSE BY
NOTIFYING LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
VIOLENT ACTS WERE COMMITTED OR
DANGEROUS DRUGS WERE BROUGHT
ONTO SCHOOL GROUNDS.
REGRETTABLY, 2441 WILL MAKE
SCHOOLS LESS SAFE, AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED, ALTHOUGH THE
LANGUAGE HAS NOT YET BEEN AGREED
TO YET. IT REMOVES THE DUTY OF
ALL SCHOOL STAFF, INCLUDING THE
VICTIM, TO REPORT TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHEN A STAFF MEMBER
IS ASSAULTED, ATTACKED OR
THREATENED BY A STUDENT,
ALTHOUGH IT DOES ALLOW FOR AN
EXCEPTION TO THIS RULE IF THE
ATTACKED. IF THE ATTACK RESULTS
IN NEED FOR IMMEDIATE MEDICAL
ATTENTION. DEPENDING ON THE
LANGUAGE OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN
YET. AB 2441 INEXPLICIT
INEXPLICABLY ALSO ELIMINATES THE
REQUIREMENT TO REPORT POSSESSION
ON CAMPUS BY STUDENTS OF METH,
HEROIN AND FENTANYL, WHILE
NARCOTIC SALES STILL MUST BE
REPORTED TO LAW ENFORCEMENT, AB
2441 RESTRICTS SUCH NOTIFICATION
TO BE MADE ONLY BY THE PRINCIPAL
OR HIS DESIGNEE OR HER DESIGNEE.
DESPITE THEIR LACK OF TRAINING
AND INVESTIGATORY EXPERIENCE TO
APPROPRIATELY DETERMINE WHETHER
THESE DEADLY DRUGS HAVE BEEN OR
ARE INTENDED TO BE SOLD ON
CAMPUS, THIS BILL PROVIDES NO
AUTHORIZATION FOR ANY OTHER
STAFF MEMBER TO REPORT DANGEROUS
DRUG POSSESSION OR SALES ON
CAMPUS. IT'S NOT THAT THE MERE
CONTACT OF WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
RESULTS, AS WAS PREVIOUSLY
STATED IN LOWER GRADUATION RATES
AND FUTURE INCARCERATION, IT IS
THE BEHAVIOR AND PROPENSITY FOR
VIOLENCE AND CRIME THAT LEADS TO
REDUCED GRADUATION AND
INCARCERATION. BECAUSE THIS BILL
WILL MAKE OUR SCHOOLS, STUDENTS,
AND STAFF LESS SAFE, WE MUST
OPPOSE AB 2441 AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST A NO VOTE. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIRMAN. YOU ALSO GOT THE
LAST WORD OF BONUS. IN THE
INTEREST OF FAIRNESS, SO ALSO
OPPOSITION. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON, JULIO DELEON ON
BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF CHAD BIANCO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE ANY
TWEENERS SEEING NONE. LET US
COME BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS?
SENATOR CHOBOQ HI AND WELCOME,
MEMBER CHOLERA TO SEE YOU HERE.
SO, YOU KNOW, I, I'M READING
HERE THE ARGUMENTS IN SUPPORT,
WITH THE CONCERNS WITH
OVERPOLICING OF CHILDREN IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, CLAIMING THAT IT
HAS FUELED SCHOOLS TO PRISON
PIPELINES. AND THAT THIS
CONNECTION OF POLICE WITH
INTERACTIONS WITH THE STUDENTS,
CAN BE HARMFUL PRACTICE AND
PROTECT FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
STUDENTS, IT SAYS HERE LAW
ENFORCEMENT, JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEMS, SORRY,
I'M READING MY NOTES HERE.
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL AND MORE
LIKELY TO WIND UP IN JAIL OR IN
PRISON IF THEY MAKE CONTACT WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT, ALSO CITING
THAT, THEY WILL BE ARRESTED AND
REFERRING STUDENTS TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WILL ONLY CAUSE
FURTHER HARM TO MINOR TO THE
MINOR THAN CORRECTING THE
BEHAVIOR AND ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE. SO, I WANT TO MAKE TWO,
TWO POINTS AND THEN QUESTIONS
AND BE HAPPY TO HEAR MORE OF THE
TESTIMONY ON THAT. IF THIS BILL
WERE TO GO INTO EFFECT HERE,
WHAT ALTERNATIVES OR INCOMING,
TO THE PLACE OF THIS PARTICULAR
BILL, WHAT ALTERNATIVES AND
CONSEQUENCES? DO SCHOOLS HAVE?
TEACHERS HAVE, OR WHAT EXAMPLES
DO YOU HAVE OF SUCCESSFUL MODELS
THAT WOULD LIMIT THIS IN IN
PLACE? WHAT WHAT DO YOU ENVISION
ON THAT END? WELL, ONE EXAMPLE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION,
SENATOR. ONE EXAMPLE IS MY OLD
HIGH SCHOOL, OAK GROVE HIGH
SCHOOL IN SOUTH SAN JOSE, PART
OF THE EAST SIDE UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT, SENATOR CORTEZ
USED TO SERVE ON THAT BOARD SOME
SOME YEARS AGO. I WENT THERE
RECENTLY IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS AND THEY NOW HAVE ON SITE,
A SOCIAL SERVICES CENTER WITH
COUNSELING AND SERVICES THAT I
WISH THEY HAD WHEN I WAS YOUNGER.
AND SO THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY,
TO HAVE A BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SPECIALIST TO HAVE, YOU KNOW,
COUNSELORS TO HAVE OTHERS ON
SITE ON CAMPUS THAT CAN DEAL
WITH BEHAVIORAL ISSUES THAT A
STUDENT MIGHT BE EXPRESSING. AND
SO IF THERE WAS A SITUATION LIKE
WAS MENTIONED BY THE WITNESS,
THERE ARE OTHER ALTERNATIVES
THAT CAN BE MEANINGFUL
ALTERNATIVES THAT LEAD TO BETTER
OUTCOMES THAN CALLING THE
POLICE. AND IT'S NOT AGAIN, IT'S
NOT TO SAY THAT CALLING THE
POLICE IS NOT ALWAYS IT'S NOT
THE WRONG THING IS THE WRONG
THING TO DO ALL THE TIME. BUT I
THINK NOW MORE THAN EVER BEFORE
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES, WE'RE HAVING
ALTERNATIVES THAT WE NEVER WOULD
HAVE IMAGINED 30 OR 40 YEARS AGO
BECAUSE OF, FRANKLY, A LOT OF
THE MANDATES AND EFFORTS OF THE
STATE. BY PUTTING MORE MONEY
INTO COUNSELING AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES ON CAMPUSES,
WERE ACTUALLY HAVING OTHER
OPTIONS THAN WE THAN WE'VE EVER
HAD. AND SO THAT WOULD BE THAT'S
ONE OF MANY DIFFERENT EXAMPLES.
YOU CAN CALL THE CERTAINLY CALL
THE PARENTS IN BACK IN, YOU
KNOW, IN FACT RIGHT NOW AS THE
LAW, IF THERE'S A FIGHT BETWEEN
TWO STUDENTS, THAT'S THE
DISCRETION OF THE, THE
PRINCIPAL, THE ADMINISTRATOR,
THE TEACHERS AS TO WHETHER THEY
WANT TO CALL LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
NOT. SO THAT ALREADY EXISTS. THE
DISCRETION ALREADY EXISTS. AND
WE TRUST OUR STUDENTS, OUR
TEACHERS, WE TRUST OUR
PRINCIPALS, OUR ADMINISTRATORS
TO MAKE THE RIGHT CALL. IN THAT
CASE, I THINK THAT IF THEY ARE
ACTUALLY THE VICTIM OF THAT KIND
OF BEHAVIOR, THEY'RE EVEN IN A
BETTER POSITION TO MAKE THE CALL
AS TO WHETHER OTHER ALTERNATIVES
COULD WORK. AND GRATEFULLY,
THANKFULLY, THERE ARE MORE
ALTERNATIVES NOW THAN THERE HAVE
BEEN EVER BEFORE. AND I DON'T
ARGUE WITH WITH WITH THE POINT
THAT WE DO HAVE ALTERNATIVES
RIGHT NOW AVAILABLE. AND, YOU
KNOW, IF SCHOOLS ARE ABLE TO
SECURE THE PROGRAMS, THE FUNDING
AND THE PERSONNEL TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT WORK. EXCELLENT, I STILL
DON'T SEE THE REASON WHY WE NEED
TO REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT, TO
NOTIFY IF THEY IF THEY HAVE
POSSESSION OF NARCOTICS
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE BY A
STUDENT. BY A STUDENT, IF IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE A FIREARM, A
FIREARM. THAT'S WHAT YOU
CURRENTLY HAVE RIGHT NOW. AND
THE REASON BEING, AND I'M WE
DON'T HAVE A DEFINITION OF WHAT
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE IS,
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF THE
RECENT DEATHS THAT WE HAD, AN
INCREASE ESPECIALLY REGARDING
FENTANYL IN THIS STATE, WHICH WE
HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM, IN MY
DISTRICT, WHICH ACTUALLY HAS
BEEN REPRESENTED TODAY BY, BY
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION IN SAN BERNARDINO,
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE, ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE THAT THERE
ISN'T, I'M GOING TO GO TO THE
NEXT POINT THAT I HAVE RIGHT
NOW. SO WE IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
PRECLUDE ONE IN ORDER TO HAVE
THE, THE HELP THAT YOU HAVE.
RIGHT NOW TO BE ABLE TO PRECLUDE
CALLING OR NOTIFYING LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I'M GOING TO THIS
IS GOING TO GO TO MY SECOND
POINT THAT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A
COMMENT OR THE NOTICE HERE THAT,
YOU KNOW, WE IT'S CLAIMED THAT,
HAVING CONTACT WITH A POLICE
OFFICER OR LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN
THEY'RE YOUNG, OR BEING EXPOSED
TO THEM, IN SCHOOL VERSE IS IT'S
A NEGATIVE. IT'S A NEGATIVE.
COMPONENT BECAUSE IT MAY LEAD TO
THE PRISON PIPELINE. AND, AND
THERE'S A STUDY THAT'S QUOTED,
TRYING TO PROVE THAT SCENARIO,
THE DATA THAT THEY, THEY
COMMONLY QUOTED HERE, IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO, TO JUSTIFY
LIMITING EXPOSURE TO, TO POLICE.
RIGHT HOWEVER, I ACTUALLY HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH, WITH, SOMEONE
AT BERKELEY THAT HAD THAT
ACTUALLY WORKED IN THIS SPACE OF
THIS PARTICULAR STUDY. AND WHAT
WAS INTERESTING TO NOTE WITHIN
THAT STUDY, WHEN IT WAS,
ACQUIRED, THE DATA WAS BEING
ACQUIRED, I ASKED SPECIFICALLY
WITHIN THAT STUDY IF, IT TO
CONSIDERATION OR QUESTIONED, OR
BROUGHT IN THE FACT OF THE
CULTURE OR THE VALUE ON
EDUCATION AUTHORITY, IN THE HOME.
SO WHAT WAS THE CULTURE AND THE
VALUE AT HOME WITH REGARDS TO
EDUCATION, WITH REGARDS TO
AUTHORITY, WITH REGARDS TO,
RESPECT OF PERSONAL SELF AND
PROPERTY, ALL OF THESE OTHER
FACTORS THAT KIND OF HAVE NOT
KIND OF HAVE AN IMPACT ON
PERSONAL BEHAVIOR AND HOW THAT
IMPACT OR THAT, THAT, THAT
MINDSET WILL IMPACT BEHAVIOR
OUTSIDE MOVING FORWARD AND
MAKING DECISIONS THAT WOULD LEAD
INTO, YOU KNOW, BREAKING THE LAW
PER SE, AND INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH, WITHIN THAT STUDY, NONE
OF THAT WAS TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION. THE ONLY
CORRELATION THAT THEY HAD WAS
THAT, THERE WAS EXPOSURE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN SCHOOL, OR
OUTSIDE AND PRISON FROM A YOUNG
AGE OVER. BUT NOWHERE THAT WE
ACTUALLY CONSIDER HAVE DIALOG OR
CONVERSATIONS WITHIN THAT NOT.
WELL, YES, THEY HAD TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS TO GET THAT
DATA TO PUT IT IN THERE AS A
FACTOR IN, BASICALLY CONCLUDING
THAT THAT WAS THE REASON THAT,
THAT THE STUDENTS OR THE, THE
YOUNG ADULTS ENTERED THE PRISON
SYSTEM. SO I, I WANT TO
CHALLENGE THAT NOTION THAT
BECAUSE YOU'RE EXPOSED TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT, IN SCHOOL BECAUSE
YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING. AND
ASIDE FROM THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
OR LEARNING DISABILITIES THAT A
CHILD MAY HAVE, ASIDE FROM THAT,
THE FACT THAT WE ARE
CONTINUALLY, CONTINUOUSLY
STATING, SORRY, I'M COLD, AND
WHEN I'M COLD, I'M SHAKY AND MY
VOICE IS, MY HANDS ARE SUPER
COLD RIGHT NOW. I'M SHAKY, BUT,
WE'RE CONTINUING THAT NARRATIVE
THAT IF A CHILD IS EXPOSED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT, AT A YOUNG AGE
OR IN SCHOOL, IT AUTOMATICALLY,
YOU KNOW, THE PERCENTAGE OF THEM
ENTERING THE PRISON SYSTEM IS
REALLY HIGH WITHOUT TAKING INTO
CONSIDERATION THE PERSONAL
VALUES AND CULTURE OF THAT
PARTICULAR STUDENT WITHIN THAT,
WITHIN THE HOME. OR WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY, MOVING FORWARD. AND
SO I, I HAVE A REALLY HARD TIME
WITH THIS BILL ON THAT END
BECAUSE, FIRST OF ALL, I THINK I
THINK WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT QUITE
LOOKING AT THE WHOLE PICTURE. WE
NEED TO REASSESS AND HAVE A
REALLY, MORE COMPREHENSIVE STUDY
AND DATA BEING, ACQUIRED AND
ANALYZED AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH, WITH SCHOOL POLICY,
BECAUSE AS I SPEAK TO MANY
TEACHERS AS WELL, AND I HAVE
THERE'S A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
THAT WE ARE TAKING A LOT OF, A
LOT AWAY FROM REVIEWING,
REMOVING STUDENTS WHO MAY BE A
THREAT, OR A PRETTY SERIOUS
DISTURBANCE WITHIN THE
CLASSROOM, ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES TO HIGH SCHOOL. IT'S A
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
HAVE NOW. SO AS OF RIGHT NOW, I
WON'T BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
YOUR BILL ON THIS, ON THIS
MEASURE, BUT I APPRECIATE THE
EFFORT. AND I DO REALIZE THAT WE
DO NEED TO HAVE, BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH, ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
THE CULTURE THAT WE HAVE, IN SO
MANY ASPECTS, BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NEEDS TO BE ASSESSED, AND
TRAINING AND AWARENESS ON THAT
END, I'M IN FULL SUPPORT. BUT,
BUT ON THE OTHER, ON THE OTHER
END, I DON'T THINK OUR THE DATA
THAT WE HAVE IS ACTUALLY
CONDUCIVE TO WHAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY TRYING TO PURSUE
LEGISLATIVELY. AND, SENATOR, IF
I COULD, MISTER CHAIR. SENATOR,
FIRST OF ALL, THIS BILL ADDS
TOOLS. IT DOESN'T TAKE TOOLS
AWAY. RIGHT NOW. THERE'S A LIMIT
OF TOOLS YOU CALL THE POLICE.
AND SO WHAT THIS DOES IS
ACTUALLY GIVE DISCRETION TO
THOSE THAT KNOW THE STUDENTS,
THE BEST IN TERMS OF THE
STUDIES. IT'S NOT JUST ONE
STUDY. THERE ARE ACTUALLY
NUMEROUS STUDIES THAT SHOW EARLY,
IN NEGATIVE INTERACTION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT DOES LEAD TO
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES LATER IN
LIFE. ARE THERE OTHER FACTORS?
ABSOLUTELY. I TAUGHT IN INNER
CITY HIGH SCHOOLS IN DC FOR TWO
YEARS. OUTSIDE OF THE FOUR WALLS
OF THE SCHOOL, THERE WAS A LOT
GOING OUT ON IN THE HOMES IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS. BUT WHO'S
IN THE BEST SITUATION TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
THAT INDIVIDUAL STUDENT OUTSIDE
OF THE SCHOOL, IN THOSE HOMES,
IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS? IT'S THE
TEACHERS AND THE COUNSELORS, NOT
LAW ENFORCEMENT. NOT BECAUSE LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS BAD OR WANTS TO
JUST BECAUSE THEY ONLY HAVE A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF TOOLS THAT
THEY HAVE. THEY'RE NOT THE ONES
THAT ARE TASKED TO RAISE OUR
KIDS FROM 9 TO 5 OR 9 TO 3 AND,
YOU KNOW, TAKE CARE OF THEM. AND
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS. AND SO
REALLY, NOT ONLY DO THE STUDIES
SHOW THAT EARLY INTERACTION, THE
STUDIES ALSO VERY CLEARLY SHOWED
THAT IT MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE
IF IT'S A CHILD OF COLOR, IF
IT'S A BLACK OR LATINO KID, IF
AND YOU MENTIONED SETTING ASIDE
WHETHER SOMEONE HAS BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES, WE CAN'T SET THAT ASIDE
BECAUSE THERE'S A DRAMATIC
INCREASE OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES THAT GET ARRESTED,
COMPARED TO THE REST OF THE
POPULATION, BECAUSE WHEN YOU
HAVE TO CALL THE POLICE AGAIN,
THE POLICE HAVE A LIMIT AS TO
WHAT THEY CAN DO. AND IT'S HARD
TO KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH SOMEONE
THAT'S ACTING UP AND HAVING A
BEHAVIORAL CRISIS. IF WE GIVE
OTHER TOOLS TO OUR SCHOOLS, THEY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRY
SOMETHING ELSE. AND THAT'S WHY
IT'S NOT, YOU KNOW, THIS BILL
DOES NOTHING, IT DOES NOT
PROHIBIT CALLING THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT AT ALL, WHETHER IT'S
FOR, YOU KNOW, WHETHER IT'S THE
DRUGS OR IT'S A VIOLENT, ACTING
OUT DISRUPTION. ABSOLUTELY. YOU
CAN CALL THE POLICE. IT'S ADDING
IT'S WHAT IT'S DOING IS IT'S
TRUSTING THOSE THAT KNOW THE
STUDENTS THE BEST TO MAKE THE
RIGHT CALL AND TO MAKE THE RIGHT
CALL FOR THE BEST INTEREST OF
THAT STUDENT. BECAUSE IF THEY IF
WE CAN REDUCE THE NEGATIVE
INTERACTIONS AND I SAY NEGATIVE
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE PARK AND
YOU'RE HAVING A, YOU KNOW, AN
EVENT, A FARMERS MARKET, AND
THERE'S POLICE OFFICERS HANDING
OUT STICKERS AND HAVE POSITIVE
INTERACTIONS, THAT'S FANTASTIC.
WE WANT THAT. WE WANT THOSE
POSITIVE INTERACTIONS. WE DON'T
WANT THE FIRST INTERACTION OF A
YOUNG PERSON TO HAVE OR AN EARLY
INTERACTION WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT, BE THEY'RE BEING
TAKEN AWAY IN HANDCUFFS. IF
THERE ARE OTHER ALTERNATIVES,
THAT THAT'S THE ONLY CHOICE AND
THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE CHOICE,
THEN SO BE IT. WE DON'T WANT TO
TAKE THAT POWER AWAY FROM THE
SCHOOLS OR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THE SAFETY OF
THE CAMPUS. IT'S REALLY ABOUT
GIVING OPTIONS AND DISCRETION TO
THOSE THAT KNOW THE STUDENT, THE
BEST, ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE MORE TOOLS NOW
THAN EVER THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
LET'S ALLOW OUR SCHOOLS TO USE
THOSE TOOLS RATHER THAN CONTINUE
TO BE LIMITED BY A POLICY THAT'S
TRULY OUTDATED. SO I KNOW, JUST
TO WRAP IT UP FOR ME, SO ONCE
AGAIN, I'M NOT I'M AN ABSOLUTE
SUPPORTER OF BEHAVIOR
COUNSELING. SUPPORTIVE, BEING
BEING PROVIDED AT OUR SCHOOLS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. BUT THE
BILL, YOU KNOW, AS I'M READING
IT WITH THE SUMMARY, IT SAYS
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT THAT
SCHOOLS NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT
REGARDLESS REGARDING INSTANCES
INVOLVING THE POSSESSION OF
NARCOTICS OR CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE BY A STUDENT. IF IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE A FIREARM. SO I
GUESS THAT A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
WOULD BE, HAVING THE PRESENCE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. I GUESS IT'S A
QUESTION. SORRY. WE DO HAVE AND
I COMPLETELY AGREE. I HAVE TO
GET MOVING. BUT BUT BUT THE
QUESTION LIES ON WHETHER OR NOT
OUR STUDENTS ARE AUTOMATICALLY
ARRESTED AND TAKEN AWAY IF
THEY'RE CALLED FOR NARCOTICS
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE, OR A
STUDENT, OR IS THERE AN
EVALUATION WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE TAKEN? MR. CHELSEA, GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THROUGH THE
CHAIR. WAIT. NO SENATOR, THERE'S
NO THERE'S NO MANDATE THAT THAT
ANYTHING HAPPENED IN TERMS OF AN
ENFORCEMENT ACTION. AGAIN, IT'S
THE IT'S THE CALL TO SAY, YOU
KNOW, THE MANDATE IS THIS HAS
HAPPENED, YOU KNOW, A PHYSICAL
ATTACK ON A TEACHER, AN ASSAULT,
A THREAT, OR, AGAIN, THE
POSSESSION OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE. THAT'S THE MANDATE
THAT HAS TO HAPPEN. THE CALL HAS
TO HAPPEN. BEYOND THAT, THE
OFFICER OBVIOUSLY HAS
DISCRETION. JUST LIKE THEY WOULD
IF THEY ENCOUNTERED A SITUATION
ON THE STREET THAT HAD NOTHING
TO DO WITH A STUDENT OR A
SCHOOL, THAT THEY WOULD LOOK AT
THE SITUATION, INVESTIGATE IT,
AND THEN THEY WOULD MAKE A
DECISION BASED ON THAT. AND EVEN
IF THEY DID HAVE SOME KIND OF
DETENTION OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
WITH THE SUBJECT, THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT THE PERSON GETS
CHARGED WITH A CRIME, GOES TO
JAIL, ANYTHING LIKE THAT. SO,
OKAY. THANKS SO BASICALLY, IF
THE IF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
THERE, THEY DO NOT AUTOMATICALLY
NEED TO ARREST THE STUDENT AND,
AND TAKE THEM AWAY. BUT IT DOES
GIVE THE ABILITY TO GIVE A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE AS FAR AS
TRYING TO ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT
THE NARCOTICS, THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE THAT THE CHILD THAT
THE CHILD OR THE STUDENT IS
CARRYING IS SHOULD BE
INVESTIGATED OR NOT. IF THERE'S
SOMETHING MORE, EGREGIOUS THAT
NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED IN THAT
SCENARIO, WOULD IT BE MORE OF A
PERSPECTIVE RATHER THAN AN
AUTOMATIC ARREST? YES, MA'AM.
OKAY. THANK YOU. YOU'RE GOOD.
OKAY, SENATOR CORTESE, JUST VERY
QUICKLY, APPRECIATE WHAT THE
AUTHOR IS DOING HERE. AND,
TRYING TO STRIKE THAT BALANCE.
IT KIND OF REMINDS ME OF THAT
OLD, YOU KNOW, TELEVISION SERIES
TYPE OF LANGUAGE. WELL, DO YOU
WANT TO PRESS CHARGES OR NOT?
YOU KNOW, AND, YOU KNOW, IT'S
SORT OF A FALSE REALITY. BUT IN
THE SCHOOLS, THEY, ASIDE FROM
THIS BILL, REALLY HAVEN'T HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SORT OF MAKE
THAT DECISION. DO YOU, DO YOU
WANT TO KEEP THIS AS AN INTERNAL
DISCIPLINARY MATTER? AND THEY
HAVE THEIR OWN COMPLETE PROCESS
FOR THAT, INCLUDING EXPULSION
HEARINGS AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
AND OR DO YOU WANT TO GET THE
POLICE INVOLVED? AND THAT COULD
ALSO INVOLVE INTERACTION WITH
THE PARENTS THAT ARE INVOLVED
WITH THAT STUDENT OR STUDENTS,
PLURAL. SO I LIKE WHERE THIS HAS
GONE, IT'S HARD TO DO BILLS LIKE
THIS. AND STRIKE A BALANCE,
WHICH MEANS I ALSO REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND THE
COMMITTEE. I WASN'T INVOLVED
WITH IT, BUT THE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE STAFF, REALLY GETTING
INTO THIS AND GETTING INTO THE
DETAILS AND, WHEN SOME MEMBER
CALLERS SAID, YOU KNOW, HE HAS
AGREEMENT WITH THE CHAIR ON HOW
TO GO FORWARD ON THE ONE
REMAINING ITEM, YOU KNOW, IN
SOME SORT OF COLLABORATIVE WAY.
I APPRECIATED HEARING THAT VERY
MUCH, BECAUSE I HAVE GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR AND GREAT
RESPECT FOR THE CHAIR. SO I
APPRECIATE, YOU KNOW, MAKING IT
EASIER FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD
HERE TODAY. AND I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. YOU KNOW, FOR MY PART, I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BEING WILLING TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION. I THOUGHT THEY
WERE IMPORTANT. AND TO SENATOR
CORTEZ'S POINT, IT'S ABOUT
BALANCE. RIGHT. SO WHERE ARE YOU
AND I WERE AT AT ODDS FOR A
TIME. WAS THE EXISTING SORT OF
THRESHOLD WAS WAS BATTERY WITH A
DEADLY INSTRUMENT? I TO MY MIND,
I THOUGHT THAT WAS TOO HIGH.
SIMPLE BATTERY WAS TOO LOW. I
THINK, GIVEN WHAT YOU'RE
ASPIRING TO DO. SO I APPRECIATE.
SO I'M GOING TO READ THE
LANGUAGE JUST SO IT'S ON THE
RECORD HERE, AND THE LANGUAGE
AND WAS STIPULATING LIKE, I'M
GLAD TO WORK ON REFINING THAT
LANGUAGE RIGHT TO YOUR REQUEST.
BUT BUT THE PLACEHOLDER RIGHT
NOW IS WHENEVER AN EMPLOYEE OF A
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE A COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IS
SUBJECT TO AN ATTACK BY A PUPIL
THAT CAUSES BODILY HARM,
SUFFICIENT TO REQUIRE IMMEDIATE
MEDICAL MEDICAL ATTENTION, THE
EMPLOYEE SHALL NOTIFY THE
APPROPRIATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY OF THE COUNTY OR CITY
IN WHICH THE INCIDENT OCCURRED.
AGAIN, YOU KNOW, THAT SEEMS LIKE
A REASONABLE THRESHOLD TO ME,
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO ACCOMMODATE THAT.
GO AHEAD. WELL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND APPRECIATE
YOUR MOVEMENT AND TRYING TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE, AS SENATOR
CORTEZ WAS JUST MENTIONING. AND
WE'LL CERTAINLY BE ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT AS IT'S
CURRENTLY WRITTEN, IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE NECESSARILY FOR
MYSELF OR THE CO-SPONSORS, BUT
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
WE'LL CONTINUE TO TALK. AND IF
WE FIND AN AGREEMENT, WE DO.
SOMETIMES WE DON'T IN THIS
BUILDING. BUT I KNOW THAT GIVEN
YOUR INTENTIONS, AND I THINK
GIVEN OUR INTENTIONS, I BELIEVE
WE'LL BE ABLE TO FIND AGAIN. I
HOPE SO, BUT, YOU KNOW, TO POINT
OUT THAT THAT WILL BE THE BILL
OF RECORD AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
SO I'M GLAD TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THAT. YEAH. AND I'M GLAD TO TAKE
INPUT FROM PUBLIC SAFETY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FIND THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE. RIGHT. I
THINK WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CORTEZ, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I THINK YOU HAD AN
AWESOME CLOSE EARLIER. YEAH.
WELL, AND WHAT I JUST SAID, I
THINK JUST TO KIND OF CLARIFY
THE POSITION AND THAT, YES, WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING,
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, WITH THAT, WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR SENATOR
CORTEZ. MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CALL. ITEM 13, AB
2441. COBRA MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. NEWMAN
A, NEWMAN I OKOBOJI. NO.
OKOBOJI. NO CORTEZ. CORTEZ I.
GLASER. GLASER, I. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WILK ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE HAS. WHERE
AM I? HAS THREE VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN. THERE'S SOME
OTHER MEMBERS CLOSING OUT OTHER
VOTES. LET US NOW, FOR THE
BENEFIT OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE,
LET'S LET'S REOPEN THE ROLL.
STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. OR DO WE. YES. CONSENT
CALENDAR. OKAY. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. GLASER. GLASER. I
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. THAT MEASURE HAS
FIVE VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR NOW, NEXT IS AB 1142 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG. WE DO NEED
A MOTION. SAID WE HAD ONE FROM
WILK. SORRY GOOD. SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. OKAY AB 1140, AB 1142
MIKE FONG. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
A SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE. NEWMAN A
NEWMAN. AYE. OKOBOJI OKOBOJI.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. NO. NO. NO. NUMBER ONE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE. FONG Ó. KHÎI
WILK A BOLD DECISION. I ALL
RIGHT, THAT MEASURE HAS FIVE
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
NOW, AB 20 104 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SORIA. WE DO NEED A
MOTION FOR THAT. ARE WE DOING.
OH, WAIT. NO SIX. NO. NUMBER
SIX. NUMBER SIX THERE ON
CONSENT. TWO THROUGH FIVE ARE ON
CONSENT. SO NUMBER SIX, AB 20
104 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA.
WHAT WERE YOU ON? COME ON. I SO
WE NEED A MOTION BY
RECOMMENDATION. WE DO NOT. I'LL
MOVE IT I THINK I THINK SENATOR
CORTEZ WAS WAY AHEAD OF SENATOR
GLAZER, DO WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CORTESE, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OKAY. FILE ITEM SIX AB
2104. SORIA MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN NEWMAN I
OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ.
GLASER. GLASER. I GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. NÓ.
WILK. NÓ. THEIR MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES TO ONE. WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR NOW, AB 2193 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN. NEED A
MOTION ON THAT? THAT'S ABOUT
HAZING. I'LL MOVE IT. A MOTION
FOR SENATOR WILK, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE. ITEM SEVEN, AB
2193. HOGAN. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. I OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI. CORTEZ CORTEZ I. GLASER
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK
I WILK I THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES. WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
NOW, NEXT IS AB 2277 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE. FALL
ITEM NINE, AB 2277 WALLACE.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NO'S, WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER NOT
VOTING. GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR
VOTES. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
NOW, AB 2381 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA, WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR WILK. IS THAT
CORRECT? YES. OKAY. PLEASE CALL.
THE ROLL MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN. AYE. OKOBOJI.
OKOBOJI AYE. CORTEZ. CORTESE.
AYE GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE THAT
MEASURE HAS FIVE VOTES TO ZERO
FOR THE TIME BEING, NEXT IS AB
2441. WEAVE FROM SENATOR. I
MEAN, FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
OKAY. SOMETHING'S MISSING. GO
AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL. AB
2441, CALL FOR MOTIONS. DO PASS
AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
ONE NO, WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. NO. WILK. NO ALL RIGHT.
THE MEASURE HAS THREE VOTES FOR
TWO AGAINST. WE'LL MOVE ON TO.
AB 2586 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ ABOUT STUDENT
EMPLOYMENT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I'M SORRY. 2586 ITEM 15 AB
2586 ALVAREZ, STUDENT EMPLOYMENT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. NO. WILK. NO. THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS THREE VOTES FOR
ONE AGAINST ONE. ARE YOU GOOD ON
THAT? YOU'RE OKAY. OKAY, GOOD.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT IS AB 2711 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS. WE DO
NEED A MOTION. SO MOVED BY WILK
MOVED BY WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ITEM 16 AB 2711 RAMOS.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE
OKOBO. OKOBO. NO. CORTEZ CORTEZ.
AYE. GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. WILK. AYE. THAT MEASURE
HAS FOUR VOTES FOR ONE AGAINST.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN. NEXT IS AB.
IT'S COVERED AB 2999 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO.
HOMEWORK. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT VOTE IS
FOUR EYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. THAT MEASURE
HAS FIVE VOTES. NO VOTES
AGAINST. WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN.
Ã. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN'S AB
3167. WE DO NEED A MOTION. SO
MOVED BY WILK WILK MOVES. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OKAY. FINAL ITEM
21 AB 3167. CHEN MOTION IS DUE.
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN Ã NEWMAN.
AYE. OKOBOJI. OKOBOJI CORTEZ.
CORTEZ. GLASER. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. WILK. AYE. THAT MEASURE
HAS FIVE VOTES TO ZERO. WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN. AND I BELIEVE
THAT COVERS EVERYTHING FOR ALL
THE MEMBERS PRESENT. YES, SIR. I
WAS IN THE ROOM FOR A PILOT OF
18 TO VOTE. YOU SEE. WE HAVE YOU
AS AN AYE. IS THAT CORRECT?
OKAY. THAT'S THE CORRECT VOTE,
CHAIRMAN. YES, SIR. IS THIS YOUR
LAST MEETING AS CHAIR THIS YEAR?
THIS IS YOUR LAST MEETING AS AS
A MEMBER. WELL, I, I JUST WANTED
TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
YOU AND THE WONDERFUL STAFF HERE
AT THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE,
MINORITY, MAJORITY STAFF TO
EVERYBODY PRESENT. THANK YOU FOR
EVERYBODY IN THE AUDIENCE TODAY,
EVERYBODY THAT KEEPS THIS
COMMITTEE HUMMING THEIR
CHALLENGING ISSUES. AND I KNOW
YOU AND SO MANY HAVE PUT SO MUCH
TIME INTO GOOD, DEEP THOUGHT TO
WHAT WE DO. AND I WANT TO JUST
SAY THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY. I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND WE AND WE
THANK YOU. WE TRY TO SALUTE BOTH
OF YOU. YOU WERE OTHERWISE
ENGAGED AT THE BEGINNING. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR A VERY EXTENDED PERIOD AS A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE, I WILL
I, I MIGHT GET YOU A PLAQUE. I'M
GOING TO GET YOU A PLAQUE AND A
CINNABON. OH ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. SO WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE THE
ROLL OPEN FOR THE TWO MISSING
MEMBERS, BUT THANK YOU TO THOSE
MEMBERS WHO ARE FINISHED. WE'RE
GOING TO RECESS UNTIL SUCH TIME
AS THOSE FOLKS RETURN, AND WE
WILL RE ADJOURN WHEN THEY DO.
DIRECTION, WE ARE GOING TO OPEN
THE ROLL FOR OUR TWO COLLEAGUES
WHO HAD, SIMULTANEOUS OTHER
HEARINGS, MADAM CONSULTANT, I
THINK WE START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. AYE.
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT. SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO, AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 1142 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG. OKAY.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS A
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE THAT ITEM
IS OUT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. NEXT
IS AN ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB 2104
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. THAT MEASURES OUT
SIX VOTES TO ONE. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB 2193 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. THAT MEASURE IS OUT
SIX VOTES TO ZERO, AGAIN. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT WAS PULLED. THAT'S
22 TO 34. ITEM NUMBER NINE, AB
2277 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALLACE. MOTION IS DUE. PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. MEASURE IS OUT. SIX
VOTES TO ZERO, NEXT IS ITEM
NUMBER 12, AB 2381 FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. MOTION IS DUE.
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. THAT
MEASURES OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. ITEM NUMBER 13 AB 2441
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
MOTION IS DUE. PASSES AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT. FIVE VOTES TO
TWO, NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER 14, AB
2473. ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURES OUT 7 TO 0, NEXT IS
ITEM NUMBER 15 AB 2586 FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURES OUT FIVE VOTES TO ONE,
NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER 16, AB 2711
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
MOTION IS DUE. PASSES AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. ALL RIGHT. THAT
MEASURES OUT SIX VOTES TO ONE,
NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER 18 AB 2918
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. BURR.
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. ALL RIGHT.
AND THAT MEASURE IS OUT FIVE
VOTES TO ZERO. NEXT IS A 2999
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO
MOTION IS DUE. PASS IS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. AND LAST ITEM, NUMBER 21
AB 3167 FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN. MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. AND THAT MEASURE IS
AT SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO. WITH
THAT, WE HAVE COMPLETED THE
AGENDA, THANK YOU EVERYBODY,
ESPECIALLY STAFF, FOR YOUR GOOD
WORK. AND WITH THAT, THIS
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
EVERYBODY. THAT WAS FAST.